this is jocko podcast number 340 with
carrie helton and me jocko willink good
evening carrie good evening
that's when the explosion rocks me
it's so big that at first i thought our
vehicle had been hit
my vision goes completely white and
there's a ringing in my ears a gentle
whine as my brain reignites and starts
working again
sort of
it is the same feeling i had in the old
days when chuck liddell used to hit me
sure i'm conscious
but i'm not quite right
my brain doesn't feel like it's
processing at full speed my vision
slowly returns and white flecks of light
frolic through my eyes as my situation
comes back to me in a jolt i realize
we're okay but immediately no
we're totally [ __ ]
the vehicle in front of me hit my roof
i don't know if it hit a pressure plate
or what but a two and a half ton armored
vehicle just did a back flip 20 meters
in the air is completely shredded and
missing everything from the front wheel
forward and is now sitting on top of my
vehicle
bullets from machine gun nest high above
us start
to hit the ground around us
i can hear rounds pinging off our
vehicle the rpg nests
come seconds later but luckily the
[ __ ] shooting them at me suck and
they fly over our vehicle
i can now see that the firing positions
have been built up these aren't hastily
made these [ __ ] planned on killing us
right here
i need to move
the whole fight is right here in the
front the guys in the back are so far
away that all they can do is listen to
the gunfire
the pass is so narrow that you can
barely fit two vehicles in the gap while
they are able to hit us from every
conceivable position and angle
there is no way to reinforce us
wisely like the grizzled combat veteran
he is the oda sergeant major starts
pushing all the units to the high ground
to take the fight to them and get the
guys out of the line of fire
that is great and all
but it doesn't do jack [ __ ] for me
the lead three vehicles one completely
blown up are stranded with nowhere to go
while death reigns down around us
i [ __ ] know i'm about to die
i'm not going to see my wife again
i am not going to see my kids again
i don't want it to end like this
and that right there is an excerpt
from a book called
scars and stripes which is
written by
green beret
special forces sniper ufc fighter
and all-around incredible human
tim kennedy
and it's an honor to have tim with us
here again i think about five years
after the first time maybe even almost
six times
six years after the first time we did
this
the first one was episode 21 and he's
here to talk about his book his lessons
learned and his experiences
tim welcome back man what's up man
thanks for coming by yeah my pleasure
a lot of stuff going on
yeah it was a heavy book to write it was
a heavy book to read it was uh it was
hard
did uh did it help you
um
there are a lot of surprising things and
i think i'm a pretty smart fella
i think i have a pretty good memory even
though i've been blown up and punched a
bunch of times
going back and cooperating first i
testimony you know first i went like
witness to what happened in some of
these situations um
it was really hard to cooperate there'd
be six shooters three different people
died and all six of us were arguing over
who shot who
you know like one guy's like i shot that
guy i'm like no no you didn't shoot that
you're right next to me and you're
engaging this dude over there you know
and it was so wild um you know going
back to even an 18 year old firefighter
emt
in san luis obispo california
just south of atascadero
a vehicle rollover
i lived pretty much my whole entire
adult life thinking that this little
girl that i worked on died in writing
this book i found out that she actually
lived
so there's some really great things like
that but then there were also
moments where you know like when my best
friend died when i was 15
i haven't i've intentionally not thought
about that
for 20 years and um
having to write it having to remember
what it felt like you know that was
really hard
so i don't know if it helped um it
definitely provided clarity and i'll
always take clarity and truth over
anything else
yeah i i mean
i always think it's helpful to talk
about write about it talk about it
because like you said when you write it
when you write something down like even
from a historical perspective of like
writing it down and checking with your
teammates and being like hey did how do
you remember this so you get the facts a
little bit more straightened out
and then just the understanding of what
you went through and the understanding
of the lessons learned when you write it
down it like clarifies it for you yeah
you know so
i in reading the book answer first of
all let me say this out of the gate it's
a freaking outstanding book um and i'm
gonna read some of it today but if you
haven't already gotten this book then
you order it immediately uh cause it's a
it's an awesome read and it's a wild
ride
this is like you know people say oh you
if you if you
made this into a movie script or
whatever people wouldn't believe it it's
kind of like that you know what i mean
it's
it's it's that
it's that freaking
your life has been that wild it has been
that wild you know but even though it's
been extraordinary stories and um
the the
the resounding theme i've heard from
everyone is how relatable
moments of that was you're like man i
remember smelling you know like the the
the smell of the valleys in afghanistan
how you talked about the dirt like i
grew up on a farm in fresno and that's
exactly what it smelled like you know
and um
you know guys that fought and people
that do jiu jitsu like remembering
walking into mats in in like the early
2000s and it smelled like puke it
smelled like piss you know the ammonia
like as our bodies would be eating
themselves because we were training so
hard that weird smell that the off gas
of our body like eating its own muscle
the same smell that you get from like
dudes and buds and the same smell that
you get from guys in like sf selection
like during kind of peak mma
those gyms smelled like that oh yeah
where you can't eventually you have to
throw your clothes away because they
wreak and nothing gets rid of them you
can't vendor them you can't put them in
the sun you can't bleach them that smell
is just like part of it now
and uh so like
it's been wild but it's it's cool to to
have people
get context into some
some of the reasons why i am the way
that i am and i think more important now
in 2022
is uh
the book is mostly failure you know like
the book is mostly struggles the book is
mostly it is not like this crescendo
moment of me doing this great thing it's
like here's what crotch rot feels like
you know
here's what trench foot feels like um
here's what it looks like to go into a
fight and lose um it's not you know
world champion tim kennedy it's like
not well you know jockery gets his hand
raised luke rockhold gets their hand
raised and i stand there not as world
champion
those moments are the moments i really
really focus on because i think those
are the moments that shape us yeah
yeah those are
i mean i don't know you that well but
i've known you for a long time and i've
you know obviously when you were
fighting i was always watching you and
stoked that you were doing it and
you know those when you'd be fighting
for the championship and i'd be watching
going come on man come on
and then you would but you know what i'd
do i'd like turn off the tv and go back
to work and
you'd have to do you know suffer through
the loss and all that i mean it like
hurt me a little bit but like i said i
just like grabbed another freaking piece
of chicken and carried on with my day
you had to like
look at all your sacrifice everything
that was going on how the how the army
was looking at you how the rest of your
friends were looking at you
ugh
yeah humiliation is a powerful tool for
good sometimes you know i know we're not
we can't fat shame people these days but
like i was shamed in moments and that
shame
first time out on an oda like the
mistakes i made i'm still embarrassed
thinking back to the way that i behaved
as a new guy on a team dude that shame
is so powerful
you know it's so important oh that's
freaking legit and you know that's i
guess that's what
that's what makes any any like uh book
or
yeah i guess any book or writing or talk
that you're gonna give
is how honest you are about who you know
where you came from and what happened
along the way you are very honest man
you're so honest sometimes i was like
dude maybe you should have put that in
there bro
i feel like in in 2022 right you're on
social media
the the fake fabrication that is the the
current existence that we live in right
the news is is eight second headlines
that's not truth it's just little tiny
tiny bits um every single
social media
is curated and editorialized you know
it's a filter that makes me look good um
it's my best moment with the best light
um you know and even if it's like here's
me struggling it's like me walking into
an interview and somebody's like hey
tell me something that's not great about
yourself well well honestly i work too
hard yeah
you know the thing is i'm a
perfectionist
i care too much
knock it off you know and that's like
our world right now and i think people
have been starving for truth and
transparency and they wanted
vulnerability
and um and we've i'm starving for it you
know like when i
one of the main reasons why like i love
listening to you and i love your books
is it's just like this is real this is
who i am this is my approach to things
it's not for everybody you're like i'm
not going to get up at 4 30 a.m but like
this is you and i love that you know one
of the many reasons that the circle of
friends that i have is like they're just
the real humans that they say that they
are where everything else around me is
fake
yeah you know even um
so in the book extreme ownership the
opening chapter is we had a blue on blue
i was in charge on a friendly iraqi
soldier got killed one of my guys got
wounded a few other iraqi soldiers got
wounded as well
and when i got home from that deployment
i would briefed everybody i mean i would
brief every seal platoon every seal team
that was going out i had a full brief
about exactly what happened what went
wrong how you can prevent it from
happening how we prevented it from
happening again
and why it was my fault that this
happened
and as we were writing extreme ownership
that chapter wasn't in there
and we talked i talked about a bunch of
other little mistakes that i made and
leif talked about some mistakes that he
made and hey we should have done this
better and here's
and finally the one day leif was like
hey
you know the blue on blue and i'm like
yeah and he says you should put that in
here and i said
i thought about it of course in my mind
i'm like damn it
now i gotta tell everybody yeah that oh
this big combat operation the as far as
i'm concerned the worst thing that can
happen in war is friendly fire yeah and
i gotta it happens yeah i gotta put
myself on report for doing that and
being in charge of it and
you know i was like yeah absolutely i do
and so i when i got done writing the
chapter i was like well here i go hey
bro here's the first chapter because if
we're going to go hard let's just let
everybody know what's up out of the gate
yeah and he was like absolutely
so
i think that's the same reason that that
book uh hits people
this is the same way that your book hits
where you're like man
some heavy [ __ ] you're going through
dude
but you can't do it another way yeah
yeah i mean you can yeah you can but
you're not a liar yeah yeah then you're
just like everybody else out there in
this in this current generation this age
where um and i don't i don't want to be
that you know i'd rather
continue to suffer i'd still continue to
learn from my pain and make mistakes
hopefully fewer of them and uh
but we'll see how that shakes out
right on all right let's let's go back
to the beginning a little bit where you
came from and all this i'm going to go
to the book for a second
um because it's a pretty good opener it
gives a good assessment right here it
says i'm an atypical dude with an with
atypical parents and an atypical
childhood
i don't exactly know how i ended up like
this but here's my closest guess as to
the recipe that made me to start i had
three cup cups of i grew up in the 80s
so like many of you gen x types every
day was an adventure there were no cell
phones no helicopter parents we left in
the morning and came home when the
street lights came on then add two
teaspoons of my mom a highly educated
classically liberal woman who valued
books arts and dance
she probably fit best teaching at an
elite easter west coast college than
anywhere else on the planet now add
three heaping tablespoons of my dad an
elite counter narcotics officer who
literally was going up against pablo
escobar on the daily at the peak of the
war on drugs
he had seen the worst in life and wanted
his children to be tough quick thinking
ate and able to survive in any condition
he valued martial arts gun work and more
risk taking than most parents would feel
comfortable allowing finally add one
bucket of my insurmountable drive to
prove i can do anything and you now have
an idea of what makes me
me yeah
you were
homeschooled that's right right yep so
what's that you were homeschooled before
homeschooling was even a thing yep
it wasn't a thing it's a thing i grew up
in the 70s but it definitely wasn't a
thing in the 70s by the time i had kids
homeschooling was a thing yeah i
homeschooled one of my kids
uh it wasn't a thing though in the 80s
no where'd your parents even come up
with that it was like hell they're
they're radicals you know uh they were
they're radical centrists in the sense
that
they believed uh in the roosevelt
idea of what a citizen is like it's my
job to be self-sufficient it is my it's
the individual responsibility to be able
to provide and protect for my family you
know as a contributing member of society
is a good citizen of america like so
that kind of old-school roosevelt
approach to being a good citizen
it is
our job to educate
my children it is not the government's
job to do anything like that that is how
my parents subscribed like religion
ethics morality um
the the classical part you know we had
we had
box seats in uh at the san francisco
symphony uh davey's hall you know we we
travel all over the nation to to go to
operas and ballets and you know i grew
up on chakowski's you know watching
beautiful little bound arenas move
around and remember
uh chakowski is a composer that uh swan
lake okay
um so this is when you made that
freaking swan lake video all those years
ago there was there was so real
there was some tide of that yeah i
remember like thinking okay yeah yeah
there's layers there man yeah i get it
now when i was when i was born i was
born with a with a bad heart murmur and
i was a runt child compared to the rest
of my family uh my dad's a giant
olympian water polo player you know my
brother's an actual olympian
yeah yeah he's a freak still to this day
when you're standing next to you know
this guy that's stole
a plane full of cocaine from pablo
escobar and uh you know he's six three
280 pounds you're you're just kind of
like
you're unnerved in his space he's
gregarious he's so sweet but you're also
like
do i make eye contact with him you know
uh but being small and being a runt uh i
had like a chip on my shoulder
and uh
how tall are you i'm 511. so you're 511
but you
but you had like napoleon complex
yeah 220 pound hairy uh you know
and i'm nothing compared to the rest of
my family's athletic gifts
so like that that teaspoon of crazy part
you know that was me just trying to keep
up that was me just trying to be with my
big brother who was faster and stronger
and his friends were bigger and meaner
um so like that that came to be a pretty
big driving force for me and this was
all taking place in up and around san
luis obispo yep and a tascadero pass
robles templeton cambria which is
some of the most amazing
just just region of the world it is
we've been everywhere we've been
everywhere right and i still go home i
go to my parents property it's in in
lockwood right right off of lake
nacional we back up to camp roberts
and uh that's just
amazing truly elk walking through my
parents yard you know and uh
i'm looking down the back side of the
hearst castle property we look at the
the mountains
and it is so wild that i'm in california
when i'm there because i'm like it's so
beautiful and it's so serene and then
i'm like i'm in california
was like a movement a little while ago
to make
to separate california into different
three regions
i was like yes yes
i think it just needs to be to re re or
i guess yeah
two regions one of the regions would be
san francisco and la and then at
california would be the rest of it yeah
that'd be pretty cool it'd be pretty
awesome yeah yeah never gonna happen
uh
you you so you're running around as a as
a kid you're doing just full-on kid
stuff you're freaking running around the
wood you got the creek gang
yep
there's no there's no one monitoring
[ __ ] with you no i mean there's no
parental it's so difficult for people
now to understand what it was like in
the 80s you know no bicycle helmet's not
going to happen oh no and when i say
we'd leave at sunrise and come back at
sunset it wasn't
the door was locked like we could not
come home
you know my mom would close the screen
door and had one of those lashes and
should latch that thing and we would
knock on the door when the sun went down
to come in to get dinner outside of that
you got 10 hours to pretty much be a
feral
a feral ravenous child
and you you spent time in the water too
you're like a waterman too right 100
yeah you know with a
dad that was water polo
pool in the backyard our house was where
everybody would go and it was like the
center of gravity for our church and our
community
so every friday the whole entire city
was pretty much invited to our house so
we would have a few hundred people at
our house every friday
and it was a melee pit in that pool you
know only the strong survived and it was
it was
bad um i don't know how kids didn't die
like to this day lord of the flies type
things
and uh
but you know with the the coast being
right there morro bay you know like
spear fishing scuba diving like i got my
paddy jr scuba diving license at 13. you
know as a surfer kid growing up before i
was allowed to scuba dive you know like
we're we're free diving you know using
hawaiian slings and spear fishing
we would swim out to rocker to the
breakers and uh we would take a broom
handle with a
wire clothes hanger and i'd attach a
fishing lure to the end of it and we'd
swim out all the way out to the breakers
like you know
a quarter mile off off the beach and we
would we call it poke hole fishing and i
take this dowel with this long
broken wire that i'd bend into like this
crescent and i'd dip it around over the
corners of the of these rocks 10 10 feet
down as the waves were to smash into the
breakers but we'd get the rock cod that
weren't so far out that the fish that
the boats would get but not but they're
big enough because they weren't by the
beach so i would i would get five six
rock cods in a couple hours but i just
had to endure getting my ass beat
on the rocks
it's uh man it's kind of strange you
didn't end up in the navy i wanted to
yeah yeah when i on 9 11 um
the navy office was closed
so the marine office was open i talked
to them first
and the army office was open and uh
on 9 12. yeah nothing was really open on
9 11. it wasn't until the day after that
i finally got to talk to recruiter and
that was uh the marines and the army
first
because the water is such a huge
obstacle
in in buds yeah and it's also
it's also like part of being in the seal
teams like you're in the water a lot so
if you grow up in the water it's kind of
kind of nice to be able to return to it
from time to time
um
so you're growing up and and
let me jump into the book here and again
look i'm i'm like reading a small
percentage of this book
the stories in here are amazing i'm
going to hit on one of them right now
uh
here we go jared and jordan cunningham
two members of the creek gang and two of
my best friends on planet earth were
heading to a party driven by teenagers
in two separate cars when i say heading
to a party i mean that in the lamest
most wholesome possible way they weren't
going to some hollywood style teenage
kegger they were going to hang out at
someone's house and play games maybe if
things got wild they'll they'd wrestle
in the grass
just good wholesome fun it was a kids a
church kid hangout
but church kids
are still kids
and as you've seen from me
and you know from your own childhood
hood kids do dumb things
the two teenage drivers finding
themselves alone on a long country road
started racing each other taking turns
passing each other in the oncoming
traffic lane it was jared's car's turn
to speed by
and they slid out from behind jordan's
car and started to pass
the brothers were right next to each
other their respective drivers in mid
acceleration in that horrible moment
i know what the moment was like as do
you boys yelling at each other through
windows laughing swearing
feeling the invincible rush of
adrenaline-filled youth
then the oncoming car came around the
corner
they were doing nothing wrong just
minding their own business doing some
last minute shopping before christmas
neither driver saw the other in time to
hit the brakes or swerve
jared died
age 13
december 20 1994
five days before christmas
in front of his 16 year old brother
jordan
so
yeah that sucked
that's going to leave a mark
the the cunninghams they were
late cunningham was the district
attorney prosecutor for san luis bispo
jordan was like
the quintessential
a hero like if uh friday night lights
the movie was made like he is that he is
the the gorgeous
athletic um everybody you know he's the
smartest
um and jared had all of that going with
him you know that family was really not
just the most popular family in the city
but like they're the most generous and
kind and sweetest people
so uh
like that law
when jared died like
your children had to live with the jared
brady law that was because of jared
cunningham
you know you can't drive under the age
of 18 with other kids in your car that
was because of this
wow and um you know jordan
being my brother's one of my brother's
best friends and jared being one of my
best friends
the uh it
is such a crucial moment you know in in
that like post-pubescent you know you're
you're still figuring out who you are
frontal lobes not working yet and when
tragedy like this happens it just
reshapes and reorganizes everything
and um the the city just
one rallied around the cunninghams which
was really cool to see
but um that
that generation that little group you
know there a whole bunch of my friends
from that era are dead now
they committed suicide or
they lived a very reckless life
as did i
and
so you know i had
second and third order effects that
lasted for decades
an interesting thing about the book is
it's like like we've been talking about
it's very humble for you to point this
out but you'll go through these things
where there should be some big lesson
learned and you'll literally say like
this was a huge lesson that i could have
learned
and i missed it and and i mean
this this kind of like what happens here
this doesn't this doesn't slow you down
at all i mean you're still like just
going wild as a kid doing normal kid
[ __ ] yeah and it sounds like everyone
else was too yeah
the there was
a direct intent from us to not point out
any lessons and anything
i wanted people to learn
not not from an antidotal hey here
here's
what you should do instead here's the
repercussions of it are you smart enough
to to
extrapolate out of this what you need to
do to not make the same mistake um
hopefully people are smart enough to to
realize
the consequence of every single one of
these things
i don't know yeah so you're running
around i mean you're getting in fights
you're getting jobs you're getting fired
you're attacking people
it's just freaking classic
well the attack
even though i was being an absolute
psychopath um
so
at
in-n-out burger where i get fired when
they fire their best fry guy yeah steve
um
there was a like she legitimately got
assaulted you know and
me being a 13 year old boy when my my 11
12 year old sister when she gets like
inappropriately touched by dude like i
throw him through a phone booth like
that's what you do you know when i was
five years old when i got the reason i
got homeschooled is i got kicked out of
private school you know and my parents
were already homeschooling my brother
but
so that was going to be an option but
they're going to see if if if this
little hairy-handed idiot
was going to be able to handle school
see if he could be civilized and
socialize could not happen no they
little dude made fun of laura's hair she
got a little bowl cut and i followed him
up on the playscape punched in the grill
and i shoved him off and it broke his
arm it's not my fault
so by the time i'm 16 you know and i
have a little bit of testosterone
finally going on and somebody touches
brianna
i'm like a dart a lawn dart across that
that polished stainless steel counter
into this dude
as i drag him out the front door after
beating him
yeah
so at some point it sounds like your dad
realizes you need
some some kind of harness some kind of
direction
and then comes uh
wrestling
other martial arts what's what's that
like it's weird because you you wrestled
but you weren't allowed to wrestle
in like the cif that's right california
state problem homeschooled program
that's homeschooled so
uh now there's mechanisms yeah there's
mechanisms now but in
1985 they thought they were dealing with
a freaking cult member
they were and they basically were they
were
so
you know i would like club wrestling uh
freestyle wrestling um i could do greco
camps um i could go to drop in
tournaments you know but there was no
there was the like the collegiate
approach to wrestling
not accessible to a homeschooling kid so
how old were you started wrestling 10.
and then you were doing your dad was
getting you into other like traditional
martial arts as well
uh what do you got dokkan jiu jitsu what
was that all about yeah that was the
japanese uh
takarayaki jiu jitsu you know some if
you go back to halo gracie the origin of
it is japanese jiu jitsu so this was a
very very traditional japanese jiu jitsu
school so you'd still do you know stick
fighting you know
screamless sticks and boast bo staffs
and
a little bit of weapon takeaways wrist
locks
striking but very traditional japanese
striking
and uh
and i i loved it my favorite part was
the grappling part of it
so at 10 you know like i i played around
in clubs with the in
in wrestling and
[Music]
taekwondo and um
karate
and it wasn't until
about 5 15 where
it was a mandated activity where my dad
was like you will go and do this
and that's was that was jujitsu and
wrestling it got real at 15 16.
and then but you could only compete in
just club tournaments you couldn't
compete in the cif that's right
how'd you do against kids that were good
wrestlers from from that were wrestling
in cif i got smashed yeah everywhere my
first
um my first tournament was a single
elimination
tournament and i got pinned in like 38
seconds
and um
in the gymnasium big huge you know
old-school wooden floor
gymnasium with like the wooden
uh bleachers
you could hear every
echo and i could i swear i could hear
my
embarrassment
like echoing off the walls
like it just got louder and louder and i
couldn't look at my dad who is who is
next to me you know i know he was you
know he was cheering for me he was a
short match and he was disappointed and
of course he's hey like come on bud
you're all right let's go
so but i was so embarrassed
like your dad is such a beast and he's
got this freaking scrawny kid that he's
got his ass beat
i'm just going to leave you here son
i remember the first tournament first
high school tournament that my son
wrestled in he was so he had might have
just turned 14
and
and he might have even still been 13
anyways he was young but he was he was
on the varsity team because he's pretty
good
and so he take him to the big tournament
there's 64 people in the bracket he's
the 64th seed because he's a little kid
and the first so he's going up against
the number one number two seed in the
first his first match
and this dude comes out he's got he's
freaking got like a full firefighter's
mustache he's like 19. a full-grown ass
man right like just a man he had a
big-ass tattoo uh on his arm and i
looked at my son i said hey no matter
what happens you just hold your head up
high when you walk off the snack he got
pinned in 38 seconds yeah
it's like one of those things there's
something good about that though man it
is so important it is so important
i can't
stress as even though i think back and
i'm i'm humiliated um it's shameful
moment right where like my dad would
look at me for a second and that might
even be like projected my own brain i'm
sure he was just sitting there being
like come over here son but my brain
like he looked away in that glance like
just was a knife in my chest that shame
going on and being able to like hang
with rashad evans and the jon joneses
you know 15 years later that would never
ever ever happen without me standing
there as a pathetic loser getting
destroyed in seconds in my first match
there's no participation trophy there's
no coach being like hey that was a great
match you tried your hardest you know he
came over he's like
you suck
you know like
i hope i don't have to see you on monday
please don't come back
you know but i showed up because i was
furious yeah and um and if there that
that fire is so important and it's not
being harnessed right now because it's
it's absent from this
generation yeah and we we have to let
people fail again
yeah even for me like the first time i
ever did jiu jitsu
against this old master chief who was
probably like 10 years younger than i am
right now but he seemed like the oldest
dude in the world
and you know he just like choked me out
arm locked me and i was like oh i'm
literally thinking whatever this dude
knows i'm gonna do everything in my
power to learn everything about it
because i don't ever want this to happen
again this is this is what i'm doing
yeah
and and you got to get your ass beaten
yes you do yes you do
it is good for you
when somebody's lecturing me about some
significant thing about you know hard
work or you know how somebody should do
something i always look i'm like
have you ever been hit
in the face
you know have you ever had your ass beat
have you ever losed so bad
you you felt like you couldn't breathe
and they're trying to impart some ways
down like
i can't listen to you yeah there's
nothing else you can say and then
there's a dividing line too because some
people when they feel that they just
want to avoid that thing forever for us
for life and that's a bummer because
that's just the wrong path to go down
some people when they experience that
like oh this other human being
can hold me and do whatever he wants to
me and i hate that yeah i'm going to do
everything i can to be able to stop that
from happening in the future well that's
that's evolution that's adaptation right
so if i put my hand on something i burn
my hand i'm going to learn not to put my
hand there if i go with this
really brilliant
crazy hot chick on the like hot crazy
scale and she cheats on me with this
other better looking dude that has more
money
hopefully i emotionally learned that i
maybe should not find somebody that
looks like that and behaves like this
i'm gonna pick somebody slightly
different like those are all painful
lessons to learn and that's how we adapt
and uh like the adaptation process
should involve pain
pain is the is is the thing
that fuels the change
i'm gonna fast forward a little bit in
the book um
this is good yeah it's tasty
um
so here i am at slow kickboxing walking
into the one of the most dilapidated
buildings i've ever seen i'm going to be
training with a rising star in the ufc a
guy by the name of chuck liddell
alongside his merry band of badasses
first we have gann mcgee an almost 300
pound wrestler from cal poly who fought
for the ufc world championships against
tim sylvia gann lost but tim popped for
steroids that that fight
next we have eric schwartz another cal
poly wrestler who is undefeated in wec
and k1 kickboxing circuit he's chuck's
main training partner
never far from him was scott lights out
lighty a k1 kickboxer and mixed martial
artist then there's jason von flu you
know the guy that the famous jiu jitsu
choke is named after that guy
cruz gomez is the only
little guy in the mix meaning he was
about my size 511 170
but what he lacked in stature he made up
for an abject savagery
finally there's glover textura a jiu
jitsu badass who would go on to become
the ufc champion with the most subs at
light heavyweight in ufc history
it's a rough room that's a freak that's
a that's a freaking that's them you
gotta get some trading in that yeah man
and then there's john hackleman oh yeah
who was just you know he was the
he just sat there with like a hot iron
poker of emotional because he knew all
of our buttons and he would just like
beep
beep just walk around instigating
he's a psychopath i love him so much
and so he's how did he found the pit
uh so hawaiian kempo yeah
and uh he got his black belt he when he
was in the army he was boxing and he was
traveling he got stationed in hawaii and
while he was there he
um
i'm grossly summarizing falls in love
with hawaiian kempo um you know
ultimately becomes a black belt in
hawaiian kempo comes back to arroyo
grande where he opens up the pit in his
backyard
um
this was before they even had a cage
built back there it was like a rope ring
inside of a barn an outside barn
and we had his hill we had a wheelbarrow
and we had sandbags and that was all the
apparatus that we had to train to
which became a whole bunch of world
champions
but uh that was it and then he opened up
his actual martial arts school you know
the inner roy grande the the pit and
then san luis bispo kickboxing was an
offshoot of the pit
where we had the ring
the an actual mat for us to wrestle
uh not in the grass or dirt
which was nicer
so you're sparring uh
chocoladelle
how old are you at this time
i am 18. and what's how is chuck he is
26.
a 26 year old chuck liddell and then the
rest of the guys in that room being
around that age too i imagine yeah
yeah and what's wild about this room is
like eric schwartz nobody knows that
name you know i think he retired at like
12-0 he only retired because chuck
retired he was really only fighting so
he could stay relevant for his his best
friend chuck that was he was the best in
the room right then he had scott adams
who also retired as an undefeated ufc
fighter with again the first three
leglocks in the ufc were were from scott
adams and um man i think you have a
shared opponent with him in um
monson
oh yeah yeah yeah i think they fought in
the ufc really really early did did
scott win yeah
and yeah there's that video there's a
video of me and jeff monson and
unfortunately it's like a three-minute
video
and the the the match was
triple overtime
so like i've seen the full video though
yeah it's not on youtube oh okay but i i
um man where did i see that that's that
was one of the most competitive and this
was peak monsoon when you fought him
yeah yeah this is voided out of his
gills
this is like you could see all of the
d-ball like just like pumping out of his
neck and the testosterone was like
dripping out of his eye like this was
like anabolic steroid monsoon of massive
proportions
that was a badass strong guy yeah but
but also
very technically he's good too he's good
oh yeah for sure no she's better than i
was obviously nah that was a great match
i don't know i i know just like anybody
else you know i look back that was so
long i look god that's oh my god what am
i doing with my hips over there where's
my weight you know you look you just
think you're pathetic but um good times
you know
yeah but that room even the no names
were
just could have been world champions
yeah you know gann
that
when when he lost to tim sylvia um
lost you know again so this is like pre
usada yeah so if now yeah
[Music]
yeah if you're getting popped back then
man nobody cares yeah
so they they made it like they dequeued
it but that you don't get a belt from a
dq so
so gan would be world champion but is
now just gets a win over tim sylvia for
a championship fight but non-champion
that sucks yeah that's a bummer the room
was vicious and everybody hit hard
everybody how many times how often were
you training i train
14 times a week
you end up your first your first fights
for money and this is such a like this
book is insane uh your first fights for
money are you get it you you do somebody
a favor of driving some weapons down to
new orleans for some kind of an event or
something like this
and you're uh you're standing in the bar
and you see people getting kind of like
taken away they look guys that look like
you first of all uh-huh yeah they do
explain it okay so my buddy gary cobble
um he owns this weapons manufacturing
company and i'm driving the prototype
weapons from san luis bispo
from paso robles all the way to new
orleans for trexpo east which is like
this law enforcement government
um convention think shot show or nra but
just specific to law enforcement and
military
so
instead of
doing the rational thing of you know
stopping to get sleep i take gatorade
bottles i'm pissing and gatorade bottles
and i drive straight through it like 90
miles an hour so i can have extra time
in new orleans
right of course no doubt this is like
you don't even have to explain this
so i get there i have
a lincoln navigator with you know half a
million dollars of experimental weapons
in the back and i park it on bourbon
street
and i go into the first bar i can find
and i was like this is awesome and i see
these dudes with chunked up ears
gigantic shoulders you know big like
massive hands and they're like bumping
into little
bros that are just hanging out in the
bars and then they walk out and somebody
intervenes
before they start fighting in the bar
and they say come down to my bar and
i'll pay the winner of the two of you
well it was just a scam where the
professional fighters were going and
luring little traveling tourists that
were drunk out of new orleans to go
fight this bar
so like this is brilliant this is the
best thing that could have happened to
me so i wait for the next bump shoulder
bump to happen and i go over there and i
bump into him and i was like what's your
problem
wait a second what's going on here i was
like i'm in let's go fight
so i became the new like [ __ ] that
they'd bring in the college kids too and
i just beat them and i get a couple
hundred bucks per beating um and it was
a great plan until i have to show up to
work the next morning with swollen hands
and black eyes from bare knuckle fights
yeah
good uh initiation though when you
thought to yourself hey i can make money
doing this [ __ ]
um
it's hard to i mean you remember
the early 2000s mma
mma is not legal in probably 45 out of
50 states in california i had i would
have to go to indian reservations or i'd
have to come down here and go to tijuana
um you know i'd fight in literally every
single indian reservation up and down
the state with about 10 of them and uh
you know of the few states that would
allow it it was usually on indian
reservations in the state that it was
kind of pseudo-permitted there was no
athletic commission there was no drug
testing
and um and you're getting paid in cash
or a check that would probably bounce
uh that like that was that was the mma i
grew up in for sure yeah yeah the the
other wild thing is like you don't know
you don't have any clue who your
opponent is no youtube yeah and and you
know when i would be working with young
fighters
you know get these hyped up young
fighters they've been training for two
years like i want to fight when i do an
amateur fight i'm like okay but you
don't know who your opponent's gonna be
and i'd call out one of our guys that's
like a black belt that wrestled in high
school i go you know that guy upstairs
yeah you train with him yeah he's got
his first amateur fight in two weeks too
like think about that you know think
about you don't know who you're getting
in with yeah but luckily you were kind
of you were well-rounded for the time
for sure for the time the pit was
way advanced in the sense that um you
know we had brought up glover texara
from brazil we had brilliant by john
hackelman to bring up
i would have to drive two hours to find
a purple belt to train with in jiu jitsu
two hours like it wasn't there's a black
belt on every corner yeah like it is now
i guess now you know like in austin i
think we have 160 black belts in the
city of austin
and
yeah
i mean i would drive two and a half
hours to go to santa barbara to train
with the closest purple belt who was it
i don't remember
no or i'd have to drive up to
um san francisco
to train with like the
the um half gracie's crew
yeah those are my two options three
hours north
brought glover in
and now you got on tap yep
badass jiu jitsu guy we have all the cal
poly and
cal poly wrestling team um they would
come in just to train with us just to
work on our wrestling then we had
hawaiian kempo john hackelman teaching
all of our striking you know we had
three k1 kickboxers that were there so
it was a very rare thing to have that
this the pit was the first
super fight club it's like a gladiator
school
yeah but now we you know we have
american top team you know there's a
bunch of you know we have aka you know
you have jackson winkle john the list
goes on and all these great schools um
and teams but back then there weren't
any you know like the tito ortiz would
come up from huntington beach and then
randy couture and matt lindell come down
from oregon and washington you know it's
just
this was the spot and i was just born
there yeah that's cool
these poor freaking kids on the indian
reservation just signed up to fight your
damn the funny thing is though i'm just
thinking about this you posted a picture
a while back of like you when you're
just in the army
and
you know you look young
you look young yeah and so
that's also going to throw people for a
loop they're looking at you like oh
who's this little guy i'm going to beat
his ass and he's like oh no this guy's
been training to fit
you know you got another thing coming
boy yeah it's awesome
um
meanwhile while all this is going on
with this kind of like fight career
which by the way is also like a stretch
i mean i guess you could look at the ufc
at the time be like oh yeah maybe i
could do that but it seems like a
stretch you know yeah you're not gonna
make money yeah at that time um
so you're trying to become
a cop which
you you're not old enough for that's
right so therefore in the meantime going
to become a firefighter in order to
become a firefighter the the first step
on this track many times is emt yep
that's right so you decide you're gonna
come uh become an emt
yep at 18.
i'm gonna go to the book
as i step off the truck and my boots at
the ground i can already taste the dust
continuing the horror movie motif
the things that immediately catch my
eyes are hymnals being gently blown
toward me across the ground
i can smell
the burning fuel of the vehicle
interlaced with the dust i also smell
the burning weeds near the van and the
acrid smell of blood urine and feces
i now hear the wailing of people in pain
seemingly coming from everywhere i
realize quickly several people have been
thrown from the vehicle
the whales are not screams
when people are screaming
they have their facilities and are
generally aware of the acute pain and
injury
whales are worse they come from a deeper
place
inside a person
they happen when one's body is so broken
that it cannot muster a scream or even a
full breath
and those whales and moans flood my
senses freezing me where i stand
again i was just 19.
i hear tom finishing up the radio call
send everyone he says
the radio operator understands and
confirms
tom places the radio back in its proper
place and he hops out of the truck and
as he strides past me he says
pick one
that's something my teenage brain
can understand
well that's a rough one
there's a
basically a church van
yeah that crashes and you guys are first
on scene yep driver fell asleep
stepped on stomped on the gas they think
they rolled over at 85 miles an hour
northbound on the 101 crossed
uh across
where the center divider doesn't exist
rolled
launching you know you're in a van
church fans you're not buckled up
nobody's bulked up and all it did was
launch bodies across
this uh
a rural landscape on the side of this
hill
and uh you know
i just turned 19.
i'd been uh with the fire department for
five months i had graduated from emt
school at cuesta college
six months before that
uh like i knew nothing you know i knew
how to take vitals i uh i knew how to
like treat bleeding wounds and i and my
only experience in trauma had been you
know a couple of people self-inflicted
you know mental health type things
so this was on a scale of something i'd
never seen and and trauma that i'd never
seen before
and uh it was
i didn't know what to do
as a child
um 14 people were in the crash and and
again you you describe everything with
some some awesome detail in the book but
all but one had critical kind of
life-threatening injuries
and out of those 14 7 were actually able
to survive
uh because the work of you and and the
team and you give a lot of credit to the
the team um as you're saying right now
you were young just kind of following
directions trying to trying to put
together what you could but a guy named
tom way anthony stornetta and keith
aggston um just more experienced guys
that could
make things happen and
the kind of guys that you looked at and
you said to yourself all right that's a
good role model for me to try and
emulate yeah you know when you've seen
this chaos screams fire blood pain
there's always somebody that's cool
right there's somebody that's always
just like
all right this is what we're gonna do
and that just
i didn't have that and i wanted that and
uh there's not a there's not a linear
path to become that and uh
in
the frustration of of standing over a
body
and again in in this triage sense the
first body i run to i start working on
and tom way just walks up he's like hey
man
go find somebody else and then i watched
tom not start working on that body
but just this does not compute right
then like the neuros in my brain are
like
why is he not treating this person that
he just told them oh they're going to
die
got it so go to the next one i start
work which is a child and i start
working on the child
and tom comes over and he's like
hey go find another one and like that
was just a knife like this hot searing
poker straight through my chest of like
oh my god this little girl is gonna die
and then i see tom start working on her
i'm like
oh okay she's got a chance you know
but now what do i do right i just booked
i picked oh for two you know like so
apparently i'm not picking the right
ones
so uh
go off to the next one start figuring
out and there's still three of us
there's 15 14 bodies and there's three
of us on the ground
um you know then then help another
another truck rolls up then the
ambulance rolls up now we have
what seven people
that are there to work
we still have 14 bodies like we still
don't have enough hands
um so it's it is i mean it is
i describe it nightmarish and there's no
way
besides in like a horror film to depict
what it feels like to be to be hearing
those sounds to be smelling all of those
smells and to be seen this just carnage
you know with the fire truck lights and
the dust that's still settling you know
in the california dry
um
environment that we live in it's you
know it's wild
shapes shape somebody though
yeah again for me though just you i even
being able to identify hey
these guys tom way the way he was just
acting that's the way i should be acting
that's what i need to figure out and
like you said it's not going to happen
overnight but at least you have some
kind of a goal
and you see a good example yeah there's
this dude dave payton you that another
example big house fire
i'm running off to to go do like fireman
things you know and dave like grabs me
by the scuff of the neck and it's like
that's not gonna do anything hold on a
second he sets up the truck gets water
pressure and then he's like
go you know there's
there's so cool to have people like that
that
that were able to shape young men and be
able to like you know save this one for
example
so
speaking of firefighting you end up
becoming a firefighter yep um
and
it's an interesting
you can't look at you like you look up a
god this guy this guy i remember a guy
like this i kicked him off
oh man um
you got
well what's a bummer for me is like you
had a fire chief that wasn't a great guy
and what's a bummer for me is just like
any like like what you just said you
could you're a freaking dog right you're
an attack dog and with without a good
like leader you're just gonna bite the
first forever freaking thing that you
see but when someone's when you've got a
good guidance and good leadership you're
going to get pointed in the right
direction you're going to be awesome
and you know your first fire chief
didn't wasn't that kind of guy
and and so you
do things that in some respects are
awesome and what exactly what you would
want for your young
firefighters to be like and to think
like they just need a little bit extra
guidance they just need to oh yeah you
know what i gotta keep a freaking eye on
kennedy right now let's make sure we got
the leash hold on hold on all right now
go you know that's exactly what you
needed and
and uh but you end up getting in trouble
for a lot of this [ __ ] again some of
it's you're doing dumb [ __ ] but you're
doing dumb [ __ ] cause
it's not like you were being neglectful
you're actually doing dumb [ __ ] that was
aggressive and heroic to try and help
just sometimes you could need a little
extra guidance uh
the guy had a three-strike rule yeah
and you write about the strikes
yeah uh the first one there's like a
female cop
who's
what there's like a suicidal guy in an
apartment it's right by your apartment
yeah is it bordeaux apartment complexes
if you know it tascadero sketch
sketch
and uh like my you know like you have
these little pagers and i was like beep
beep beep testicator of fire and then
you'd get the address and what type of
call it was the address pops on i was
like dude that's like six doors down
i can do this so i walk out there and
and this young
police officer she's standing out in
front of the door
um i'm fighting i'm i've been a
professional athlete at this point you
know i have 50 something amateur fights
i have a handful of of pro fights now
and uh she is dealing with a dude trying
to kill himself and he has like a box
cutter and he's cutting his wrists and
the white the mom had called 9-1-1 and
she's waiting for backup and she can't
go in by herself and uh and i look in
there and it is it is just like a child
you know it's it's a 19 year old frail
you know mental health
is such a problem right now
but you very often see not physical
specimens that are struggling with these
problems so when i peek my head in there
i was like all right you know this is i
got this i got this
this is not a problem are you going to
go and shake out my going i'm going with
you and firefighters should not do that
they should wait
until it's safe and then they should go
in they're the they're the second
responders not the first responders and
then i got in trouble mm-hmm cause that
was strike one that was true by the way
you went to the fire academy your number
one graduate the fire academy is that
right
so again to me that that reflects
someone that when you give them the
parameters of what they're supposed to
do they're going to knock it out of the
park yeah you know and you just got to
make sure those parameters are in place
test conditions yeah let's keep this
[ __ ] in the box a little bit
here's our line
uh second one there's a car crash and
it's in ravine
and they're waiting to set up the rig to
rappel down into the ravine and you're
like i got this creek gang kid
you know it was on the in between
itascaro and morro bay california um uh
i was at highway 41
and uh there's a big huge drop off that
goes down to the creek big huge like
it's not like
this is my backyard where i grew up so
this the a motorcycle it's such a fun
road to ride motorcycles on i go there
all the like i grew up riding my my was
a cfr250
up this road and so i know exactly what
this guy was doing an oncoming car sees
this motorcycle swerves to avoid it and
goes off into the ravine
um they they tumble down the hill when
we get there they're down at the bottom
and uh and i the doors kind of like
i can see blood coming out the side of
the door and the door is kind of a jar
and i see this woman like messing with
her leg and the other guys tore up on
the other side so like i go grab a tool
and i just walk down the hill pop the
door open and i start treating this girl
it was not not even an event in my brain
all the while the rest of the team was
setting up to do a high angle rescue
so
i got in trouble for that yeah so you
got in trouble because you didn't you
follow the protocol or something like
this yeah so this this was strike two
um strike three it sounded like you
deserved a little bit
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm sure we're in us we're in a
studio right now you know fires do weird
things and um
studios make fires do even weirder
things like there's nowhere for heat to
escape got a bunch of electrical
equipment
um and in that fire there was a studio
in there and the inversion layer so like
the the smoke and the heat was so thick
that you couldn't see where the fire was
and if you know you go up inches you'd
start going up hundreds of degrees you
go up feet you're talking like a
thousand degrees in indifference
and um and i was trying to find the fire
which is like what a nozzle guy is
supposed to do
i didn't have the experience to
understand or realize how dangerous it
was
so when like the little particles in the
air just started combusting as the
temperature of the room started reaching
a flash point like an experienced person
is going to be like oh this is about to
go down you know like instead i'm like
no no let's find the fire like you're in
the fire bro like the fire is above you
you just can't see it you know if you in
in the top of your helmet that popping
sound is your helmet melting you're just
too dumb to know it
so when the fire when the room firing
finally flashes like if you see the
movie backdrop backdraft where the room
finally just goes
that's what happens i just crank open
the nozzle put it on flood and wide to
try to not get us to burn alive
in an effort to
um which was the right thing for us not
to die but also you know like a not
great thing for a lot of steam
oh steam sucks
got it
so i burnt me and alan lanier
the dude behind me on the nozzle being
like hey you're being stupid
were they was he trying to pull you back
yeah
i think so i think that's what it's loud
fire nozzle water
um and me pulling him forward and and
being that dog being that bull you're
like no let's go find the fire let's
find the fire let's find the fire i
think him being behind me and being that
second set of eyes like that the the
pulling back was literally him saying no
no no like we we have reached our
limited advance we need to back up
um but i was just too dumb and too
stubborn
yeah it sounded like uh pretty sketchy
you roll out of there and your helmet's
like melted and your mask is all jacked
up yeah so we have these self-contained
breathing apparatus and you have a layer
of plastic glass plastic glass
so
plastic had melted glass had shattered
plastic and melted and i had one layer
of glass in front of my face
and my the top of my helmet
with my firefighter number 42 i still
have my firefighter number on my desk
which is like burnt and charred and i
keep it there to remind me
how dumb i am
that helmet
um
had melted the top of it was like all
bubbled and boiled
it's weird
you don't want to see a helmet like that
and that ended up being a strike three
that's right so you get kicked off
the fire department which in your mind
um
unstoppable tim kennedy's like good
because i want to be a cop anyways yeah
right that was kind of that was kind of
what you're doing
uh
meanwhile your your fight career is
going mm-hmm what year is this now this
is uh 2000.
um
you lost your first pro fight scott
smith that was embarrassing
[Music]
and arrogance i fought him five weeks
before that
and like smacked him uh-huh and so i
walk into my pro debut and uh how do you
how did you beat him how did he beat you
um he beat me tko stoppage big huge cut
doctors like i can see your cheekbone
get out
um how did you beat him
three rounds of
domination domination
what'd he catch he just caught you yeah
you just went clear man he got 15
minutes of of first person preparation
and i did exactly the same thing that i
did in the first round in the first
moment of our first fight where i had a
big change level i was going to push him
up against the cage
you know make it dirty for a second so
that changed a level he just blew me
open with an uppercut
jack yeah like literally the exact same
thing that i was like ah i'm gonna do
the same thing i did to him last time
and he's like i'm gonna do a different
thing
last time
and it worked out
how when did the fight get stopped after
the first round or oh no no like like
immediately yeah
we're two minute minute minute half into
the first round
walking into the pit as a zero one
fighter walking into gann and chuck and
scott and eric
and uh john hackleman and i already felt
like i didn't belong and i'm walking as
an 0-1 pro
loser loser
what did you do it's like it's so crazy
to think you know even walking into that
place you're by no means yeah like
you're just walking in that place and
training you're sparring with chuck
lodel like you're a bad you're a badass
and yet you get
beat you feel like a loser
uh you but you are moving up like moving
up the respect
ranks at the pit and you're you end up
going to some of chuck's
won a chuck's fights championship fight
um against bustamante
i was chuckling this whole time you know
anyone i don't know what it's like maybe
it's gotten better but back in the day
if you were like a teammate
you were like gonna pay your own way to
get up there you're gonna sleep with six
other guys and some you know in the same
room you weren't gonna get fed anything
you're cutting weight with your with
your fighter
it just like sucked sleeping on the
hotel room floor getting beat up by the
way you can't win any of your sparring
you're just getting beat up you're just
getting punched in the head just a bag
of blood yeah for this dude to punch
there's no there's like no glory in
being a second or a third
or a fourth which is basically what it
seemed like you were oh
yeah yeah they're like body get in here
yeah when eric or ganner or you know
scott retired or bored that just
throwing me so i don't even i don't even
think i was like fourth string okay i
was not even acknowledged in at being
present did you get a ticket to the
fight because that was another thing
there was no guarantee you were getting
to the fight i didn't get a ticket to
like the first three fights i was at and
when i finally got to i think vito
belfort was the first fight that i
physically got to be
in the arena for
it was so cool yeah like we used to run
every kind of scam to get into those
fights we i i would go i would get in
every single time 100 of the time and we
were running all kinds of you know
tactical operations and i left the best
seats i got the sickest seats you know
i've seen i've seen so many ufcs from
like road three that i had no tickets to
we'd we we did all kinds of tactical
maneuvers to get into those fights
because because that's the crazy thing
right you'd go up there you'd be
cornering someone i would literally be
cornering someone and not have a ticket
to the fight you know but i mean come on
i'm already back there right yeah this
is just let me in
the security would walk up and be like
nine of us in front of four seats you
know they're like do you guys have
tickets yeah yeah yeah this is our
ticket and they're like that well that
was his ticket
no no no this is my ticket where's his
ticket like
i don't know i'm going to get a beer
i'll be back yeah yeah cool uh
you end up becoming the extreme
challenge champion
and in this are you starting to think
maybe this is a thing like when you when
you go up with chalk or you're starting
to know i still don't think it's not
right i still don't think it's like an
actual i still like fighting
right in that that tournament that
eight-man tournament that was the who's
who of middleweights at the time
um jc mayhem miller dennis king ryan
norte me
um like
for
early 2000's when when you put like
these are the eight best dudes on the
planet
that's that's money right there and uh
that's a tough freaking tournament yeah
and i think i i think i won enough to
pay for a computer for my next semester
in school
you know like there's no money
chuck paid for my pizza kitchen post
fight meal chuck paid for my ymca
um to go in to cut weight in the sauna
it was the only sauna we could find in
salt lake city like chuck out of pocket
like there was no money
and i'm like the ecc champion yep so
yeah those are the good old days right
there no no one was fighting for the
money back then we just fought i just
wanted to fight
uh
you fight and win in the wec as well was
that any better was there any anything
at the wec i got a hundred bucks to show
and 100 bucks to win
to fight at as a heavyweight
god you fought as a heavyweight 194
pounds
and i fought as a heavyweight
you kind of get you this is kind of
you're getting like a minor level of
fame though at this point would you say
yeah like the the mma weeklies are
starting to write you know
the
up and comer you know on the top 10 top
10 rankings i'm like uh mentionable no
mentioned like notably mentioned type
categories uh so
who is this guy type questions
but
and the the wec was nothing to sneeze at
back in the day you know like i remember
it was like kind of on the same level
like ufc was obviously the bigger
promotion but you know some incredible
fighters came out at the time
i mean it was a great
great place to be at that stage yeah wc
was totally legit yeah um
you got
you you you are you getting wrapped into
the whole fighter
kind of thing right now i'm starting to
live in
the booze the everything else
not the booze as much
but the women the traveling the fighting
i mean it is it's a real unhealthy
lifestyle when you're like committed to
it um you know you'd wake up you'd fight
uh no you'd wake up you'd rinse off
whatever
debauchery is on you
and so you don't carry those diseases
into the gym and then you'd go and train
and then um you'd try and do some form
of recovery and get some type of food
and then debauchery training again
and then debauchery like that's about
your day so that's so you see you were
rolling
rolling rolling in that rolling deep and
that what a weird it was a weird time
too because it was like
the fighters weren't really getting paid
much money but you kind of had
recognition
and like people that were kind of
fanboys like club owners would be all
hyped to bring everyone in and set up
tables and whatever yeah you'd get like
bottle service because you were the
fighter and the guys the the bars wanted
you in there because it made them seem
more famous because they had like the
tough guys in their gyms or in their
bars
but we still didn't have enough money to
even buy the bottles it's like it is
this bottle are we gonna have to pay for
this like we didn't know how it's always
working out
um
it was a really like the ring girls they
weren't like real ring girls they were
just kind of like local girls that were
getting paid
it was a wild wild circus yeah it was a
wild wild interesting time i was for
sure
i you know
i like you just talking about bottle
like i remember being at like things at
like post fight parties and stuff like
this and there's like bottle service and
people are ordering bottles and i'm like
i have i'm in the navy bro i'm like i'm
in the navy i got three two or three
kids bro i'm not paying for [ __ ] like
you can [ __ ] get out of here but i'm
not paying for a 400
bottle of some [ __ ] i don't even know
what it is it's not happening and i'd
just be like you know i'll drink some of
this but like i'm you're getting no
money for me of course like whoever
whatever fighter i'm with is like i'm
not paying for anything either so we
don't know who's paying for this stuff
but somebody's getting stuck with this
bill and it could be us no
those are some wild times it's hard
there's no way with people that are
looking at you know that even after
pride like ufc
proper now or that you know they see
guys in suits and doing proper weigh-ins
and athletic commissions and you know us
the anti-doping coming in
we're talking back then i'm at the wild
west oh yeah of everything like warm-up
rooms that were there's literally like i
remember being intense there's the
ground is just tar it's just a it's a
parking lot it's like oh we're gonna
yeah you guys can warm up right over
there it's tar it's a [ __ ] parking
lot you're like what
okay
races to the banks afterwards to try to
cash your check because only the first
five checks were clear there's probably
i would say a dozen fights that we had
to fight our way out of like out of the
audience like if you beat a local you
would have to fight your way out of it
and try to not get stabbed and if you
heaven forbid you fought an indian on an
indian reservation and you beat that
indian like you
dude it is it's on it is every dude's
eyes are open you know chuck's leading
the way gans dropping elbows as we're
busting through and we're just trying
not to get stuck
like this is that era of mma uh
meanwhile um
all that's going on you're trying to
become a police officer yep right yep
that's your that's your goal which is a
smart goal because you realize you know
there's no money in fighting um
you go to the academy
you're the honor graduate of the academy
no runner-up oh you're a runner-up uh
huh oh did i read that wrong yeah so i
have highest gpa i have highest score
um like highest physical score i have
like highest everything
i get in a fight
with one of the instructors over report
writing
and oh that's right i
tell him how he should do report writing
and like this is a better way with more
with a with a clear narrative and he
didn't say wow cadet
thank you so much for your input that's
incredible he did not say that
no and i stuck to my guns i was like no
this is a course
you're right i am right how could he
know so he he failed me and you can't be
undergraduate with a failure that's
right so then i retake the test and i do
it exactly how he wants and i get my
passing grade of 71 percent or 70
percent and uh even though like my first
one was perfect and it should have been
100
so you cannot graduate if you fail a
test you can't be honored as a failure
no so i have my
ass tricks and i'm number two
number one but number two gets
undergraduate yep um
and you had a good story in there about
you know the combatives course that they
taught you were once again they're
looking like oh who's this little uh
youngster that's in here oh you think
you're tough oh watch this
and you're like no watch this
tell me if i'm wrong jiu jitsu is a
superpower
it's a superpower and uh when if i'm in
a room with a bunch of cadets and i say
you cannot put cuffs on me unless i let
you put cuffs on me and they go like
there's 40 of us like i don't care
that is how powerful jiu jitsu is when
you
empower somebody with that type of skill
and knowledge if i can take my hands and
put my hands on a grown person and they
can do anything that i want them to like
that's the power of jiu jitsu
and they did not have that power
but they needed to know it so again
here's
so stupid tim of like okay well i will
teach you guys then this this is how
better and you know so arrogant
so pathetic but you guys can't do
nothing to me yeah that's what it was
uh
it's true though man it's hard it's hard
when you when you when when someone
knows how to fight
it is really hard to get control of them
yeah it is really hard to get control of
them
and especially if the other people don't
really know how to fight you know if
they learned whatever uh
four-step procedure for getting control
you know it's like no
that procedure is not gonna work for a
millisecond against me no go away yeah
i you know i beg and i plead law
enforcement to go and do jiu jitsu yeah
you know if if there were ten there are
ten police officers that are
police academy trained they do their
cuffing their defensive tactics and they
say jocko you're under arrest i'm going
to put cuffs on you
zero chance all ten grown
adults who are trying to cuff you zero
chance
you know but then you take
one
that trains totally different totally
different story yep yeah and it's gotten
really bad now not to derail this
conversation but i was just talking to a
couple police officers and
i won't mention the state where they are
if they put a choke hold on someone if
they put a rear naked joke on someone
it's lethal force um
they they
i'm trying to think of the steps it's
like a full it's a full-on like felony
first degree murder
if if the person dies yeah it's but but
even if the person does if you just do
it it's like it's like a assault with a
deadly weapon or something like this
and it's so hard to explain to people
i don't know i don't know what you think
but
if i had to subdue
someone that i cared about
th the number one thing i would do is
put a rear naked choke on the best
choker in the world it's so safe it's
the gentlest nicest way to get someone
under control and it's so effective and
there's nothing you know like
it leaves no marks like you know you
could choke me right now and i'd wake up
and be like oh dude you know you could
have cuffs on me and i'd be like oh what
just happened and i'd be totally fine
you could uncough me and i could go and
freaking teach a class in whatever and
carry on with my day as opposed to you
hitting me in the in the head 19 times
with a baton to get to subdue me where
pepper spray
no all those things are so hard and we
like people just have no understanding
of the power of jujitsu and the power of
the rear naked choke it's it's it's so
sad and so many more people are going to
get hurt because of it
and all it takes is if you're in law
enforcement or if you're in charge of
law enforcement mandate everyone should
be trained in jiu-jitsu yeah you should
be training jiu-jitsu all the time
um
my i've been saying
20 of what police do 20 of the time
should be training yeah it not only
shapes the body but also shapes the mind
it does such a beautiful thing to ego it
tears things back and it makes you human
um and when you're in a position of
power like that
you have to have your ego checked and
the best way to do it is to put you on a
mat and have you lose back to those
people that have never been hit in the
face the city councils that enact those
type of policies for their cities those
are the people that have never been in a
fight that have never gone on a
ride-along that have never been punched
in the face but they're like dude this
police officer can't do do a chokehold
you don't know anything about anything
and and you're the one that's mandating
and your ignorance is causing more
damage to your community because you
don't understand you don't understand
violence because you've never been in it
but like as men that are pretty
intimately familiar with violence listen
to city council people go get punched in
the face and learn how important it is
to know how to effectively do violence
yeah and i'll tell you what go get go
get hit in the face with a baton three
times
and see how you feel the next day and
then let me put a rear naked choke on
you and see how you feel the next day
and by the way the the rear naked choke
will make you want to just kind of
comply and if you don't you're just
going to wake up in handcuffs in the
back of a car so easy yeah so so good
and um
yeah so you so you end up
uh hooking these people up during that
and they have to take how many guys did
it finally take to get cuffs on you i
didn't no this didn't happen never
happened i mean but at the by the end of
it i mean we're probably 30 minutes
later from wrist to elbow there's cuffs
hanging off me and i'm there's like i'm
bleeding from you know because like
they're snapping them on i'm bruised at
my radius and old and it's like bone
bruised
and uh there's blood like dripping off
of my arms and i looked like a like an
animal a pit bull that's been tased a
bunch of times it's in the corner i was
like
who's coming at me next and you know
what sucks is
uh
a lot of times people would just think
oh he's just a really good athlete or
something like this and that was one of
my problems like i'm the worst person to
introduce jiu jitsu to someone
you know because they're like well of
course you freaking beat me you're
freaking 225 pounds yeah it's like the
best people to introduce is like jeff
glover
who's 150 pounds
he's
like
not intimidating to look at
and he's got a big smile on his face and
he's just breaks it off on people yeah
that's who should introduce people to
jitsu i'm no you're no good either like
you're not a great like introduction to
jesus because people are like oh what
just happened but that guy's an [ __ ]
you know that's what they say about me
like
we get done rolling you're really strong
like thanks man i appreciate it yeah i'm
not that's that's it i work on that yeah
yeah well that's why i left my little
liquors um
yeah so it's not great to have people
that are big introduced jiu jitsu but
also it's strange that even in a
situation like that like if i was the
overall trainer i'd be like hold on a
second what just happened yeah nine of
my cops couldn't get this guy under
control there's something wrong with you
so the defensive tactics instructor for
the academy was a jiu jitsu guy
and i think he wanted i think he let it
go oh
got it i think he did he was lit looking
back i was like oh he knew what was
happening he knew what was gonna happen
he wanted them to know
and but at my expense you know i lost
rapport with my classmates i looked like
a total [ __ ] um as a feral animal in
the corner uh yeah like
for like a while people wouldn't even
look at me
but i think he knew exactly what he was
doing yeah so i'm tipping my hat to that
clever little [ __ ]
um
you
graduate which is cool um at this point
you you had a girl you have a girlfriend
yep named casey yeah she's great
and
you find out that she's pregnant
at this point
um
and at some point
you had had a one-night stand with
another girl yeah
and she's pregnant yep
and at some point
you had a one-night stand with another
girl
yep
and she tracks you down
and she's like a ring girl from the ufc
or from one of these
one of these fights you've been in
she's a ring girl
and
she shows up at the pit where you're
training
not to tell you that she's pregnant
which
i would have taken that
yeah she tells you that she has hiv
and then finally
um
you're like
trying to blow off some steam and you go
to play paintball with your with your
with some friends with your brother and
and like some people huck rocks at you
yeah
and you
and by the way you're you're a police
where are you cop right now at this
point uh i'm applying to everywhere okay
so i was like testing for santa barbara
stockton
sacramento so you're about to get hired
somewhere
i'm in background which is kind of like
the last step to get hired by these
departments well speaking of background
what you decide to do is these guys huck
rocks at you and you assault the vehicle
yeah
which
which i can imagine these guys
that's always it's always a funny look
on people's face when they realize that
they did something that they shouldn't
have done yeah and tim kennedy moves 200
yards in 3.8 seconds with a fully loaded
paintball game sticks it into their car
and unloads as many rounds as you can
that's right
which
is kind of funny and we can laugh at it
now but
sounds like there was some politics
uh in your town yeah and small town
stuff with you know a famous police
officer father with uh you know a
brother that is working for a different
apartment or a department who's who's
physically at lots of just kind of small
town
uh egos fall into here and uh i get
screwed and and you get the
the
basically
you're not gonna be a cop that's right
that's not happening
um the whole background now you're
getting charged with some kind of thing
and they're making it look like you're
crazy yeah
so you're racking them up
yeah great decisions just lining them up
and knocking them down
i'm gonna go to the book here
i'm standing naked at the end of at the
edge of the ocean halfway through my
23rd year the cold surf washes over my
feet and the wind spreads goose fish
across my skin goose flesh across my
skin
the sun will be up soon but for now i
remain wrapped in darkness it's nice to
bask in the stillness of this moment the
only sounds of the waves lapping against
the shore there is something cathartic
about being alone on the beach i grew up
on and stripping my clothes off and
letting them hit the sand i feel
incredibly free for the first time in
ages normally i'd worry about my wallet
and keys getting stolen
but i do not care at all
what difference does it make
i weighed into morro bay just north of
the rock ignoring my brain's warnings
that it's too cold and too dark there's
a wall of fog closing in that will soon
make it hard to see my way through the
black water i don't worry about that
either
as i way deeper my legs start to burn
from the cold water i pay attention pay
no attention though even as it covers my
legs then waist then chest i barely
acknowledge the surf's effects i don't
want to acknowledge it i don't want to
think about
it i don't want to think about anything
when the waves start picking me up off
the sandy ocean floor
i begin to swim west
i have failed everyone i know
and there's no way to fix it what the
[ __ ] is wrong with me how the [ __ ] how
did i [ __ ] up everything this quickly
i'm a strong swimmer and in no time the
shore is a distant memory it's so
peaceful out here
my breath mists a little in the waning
moonlight
but other than my own breathing and the
sound of my hands and legs cutting
through the surf there is nothing
i didn't plan on going for a long swim
to nowhere in the pre-dawn blackness but
i needed to forget all of it
my actions
they hurt the hurt that they caused and
the disappointment they manifested in
everyone around me
i can't hold on to this pain anymore
i'm just not strong enough
yeah
you know i kind of breezed through like
oh you had this girl pregnant and you
had this girl pregnant and then you you
had this possible hiv you can't get the
job you want to get like this is
you're 23 years old you know sometimes
i'll talk to people that are 16 or 17 or
15 years old and they broke up with
their girlfriend or they made this
mistake and
and i i always say listen it seems like
your whole world right now but
there's so much more to life you know
there's so much to carry on there'll be
other girls there'll be other
opportunities it's okay
but damn yeah that's a lot like that's a
lot of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] going on man
yeah and
you know
an order out of there my grandpa who's
like the patriarch of our family you
know the greatest generation world war
ii he's dying of emphysema you know
every breath he takes is is slightly
less than the prior breath you know just
he's just fighting
so he's just becoming a shell of a man
and he he would be the person that i
would go to
to go go to the beach house in cambria
like listen to the waves crash and just
dump on him and and you know he had the
grandpa wisdom he's dead he's dying
riding the motorcycle i already crashed
that you know like that thing's going so
my other cathartic release is gone um
like i was too embarrassed to be back in
to walk into the pit you know walk in
and be like hey i think i i can't train
right now because i don't know if i have
aids um
so
uh i was just in morro bay
and i walked to the coast guard station
and i knocked on the door
the door flew open and they all knew who
i was
explain that so i didn't i'm not going
to read that part of the story but you
swim out to sea
and you know it's weird it sounds like
it sounds like you weren't intent on
killing yourself
but
doesn't sound like you were all that
intent on living either i don't know
what's what's the there's definitely i
think a wish for like a baptism and this
is a really unique thing as you and i
are dealing with lots of mental health
and suicide within the military and and
addressing it and how do we there is not
like this linear line of
where is depression where is suicide
where is mental health you know what you
have here is you know an early 20 year
old boy who
has made a bunch of bad decisions and he
feels hopeless and i didn't know what to
do i didn't know where to go next um and
i'm doing something that is very very
dumb and dangerous and could be the end
of my life
um
but i didn't have an intent that i'm not
trying to kill myself you're like
there's there's no cognitive there's way
more efficient ways than swimming out
into the ocean
um i definitely kept swimming and this
is that's a big takeaway that is you
know not at the end of the book there's
not that adage that's oh here's what you
should take away from this
is i kept swimming you know i was my
balls were essentially up inside my body
as i was frozen to death and i it still
doesn't make sense
the coast guard said that somebody
called this is but pre-dawn this is
pre-cell phone
there's no way that any of the houses
along morro bay on the north side of the
breakers on the north side of the rock
could have seen me and there's nobody in
the parking lot when i got in the water
so i'm not saying there's like a divine
intervention but
it doesn't make any sense how somebody
called the coast guard station said they
saw a young man take his clothes off and
swim into the ocean
you know as a
my open water swim time i get 28 30
minute mile so an hour into this
from the time the coast guard said they
got the call to the time that they found
me i've been swimming for just over an
hour so i'm two miles out into the fog
two miles out past past the rock
and um
a really cool
thing i discovered when i went to the
coast guard station and they throw the
door door open like we're listening to
joe rogan's podcast listening about this
right here they have a log book
and one of the most
darkest hardest moments of my life i'm a
single log tag in a date time group
like time
date
captain boat remarks
that's it
that's it
what could have been me dying
what what became like a moment where i
start to make start to make right
decisions is a single line written in
pencil
in a log book in a coast guard shop
it's wild
um um
down to that
it's cool and that that could have been
it too yeah that last remark line you
know pulled an idiot out of the water
was pulled a dead body out of the water
yeah that's it the only difference
and you know i look divine intervention
or whatever you ever tried to recover a
single swimmer at sea on a foggy night
two miles out in the ocean crazy that is
not like you plan to do that you got an
ir strobe you have to go white strobe
you have to freaking swing or cam light
above your head like it's hard if they
had thermal
they didn't i mean
if they didn't have thermal that's a
miracle honestly quite honestly and and
if you told me if if i got a call that
hey some idiot got naked and started
swimming out to sea i'd be looking 300
yards out yeah
maybe maybe 500 yards out
maybe a thousand at the most there's no
way someone's going to be too much like
that's crazy that they found you
dense fog dense fog so dense
on uh the south side of the rock where
the breakers are in the entrance
tomorrow bay there's a fog horn i
couldn't hear the fog horn
and you can hear that for miles the the
fog is so dense and it was it was
padding sound i couldn't hear the waves
um you know it does really weird things
to light there is barely any light at
this point
no starlight no moonlight i'm just i've
just been swimming for an hour
and when this boat rolls up i think i'm
losing my sanity because i i was like
they just have an idol and it's cruising
and the captain has his feet hanging
over the front of the boat and he's just
like sitting there with his feet
and he's like hey what are you doing
i'm swimming he sounded like the coolest
dude so cool he's like making fun of you
right yeah what are you doing i'm
swimming
no [ __ ]
you know like even now even even even
currently you're like this you know that
was the first indication to him that he
was going to take a different approach i
think and then he's like so what's going
on and i i give him a summary of what's
happening
and he's just like
yeah i was thinking about pulling you
out of the water but
maybe just stay in the drink
he says this to me
and i was like yeah
man it's cold it's cold he's like i see
that
he just makes fun of me
and then he doesn't help me he throws a
cargo net down the side of that ship and
he makes me clamber up the side of that
boat with my i mean i couldn't use my
fingers i couldn't feel anything you
know an hour and 50 50 to 53 degree
water um also like i had to have kept
swimming pretty actively to not be
hypothermic you know you have a minute
you know of kind of like active use 10
minutes of
use of your fingers digits and then an
hour is kind of the threshold where you
start losing control your body
and uh and i was at that threshold and
he throws a cargo net over the side of
the boat climb up
you know i'm not helping you
you you did this you get out show me
show me
he didn't say anything besides there's
not going to be somebody to do this
again that's all he said 20 minute boat
ride back in got to go back all the way
around the rock come back into the bay
and then go to the coast guard station
dock not a word just sat there
and then what'd they do with you nothing
he asked if i was good
i had to walk from the coast guard
station back to my car at the rock it's
about a mile did you feel
what you were you thinking every step i
was trying to did he give you clothes
i had a blanket check i had a wig that's
right you say one of those old navy wool
blades yeah it's like green yeah and it
is i mean it's sandpaper yeah is that
what you said
they don't have real blankets like well
i don't know what they have now but for
100 when i went to boot camp like you're
sleeping with one of those things and
then like the standard issue blanket if
you were somewhere was that stupid green
wool itchy blanket it is terrible and to
frozen skin it feels like hot needles
it was terrible and i and i walked all
that mile back to the coast
to get my car it seems weird that this
guy wouldn't have been
like hey this kid needs some help like
some some mental health assistance here
i um
i don't remember what i said
but it was
definitely gratitude and it was
gratitude that i'm alive
and i
if i was looking for a baptism however
you emerge from the water emotionally
and physically post baptism i think
there's this transformation where
all right i definitely did not start
doing it right but i was done doing it
wrong
and um
i don't know if his discernment maybe
was it was
naive on his part uh
from that moment i mean you you would
have to have
strapped me down like when i went to
selection
they would have to have found me in my
sleep
and executed me in my sleep for me to
quit
like this was the beginning of that
mentality where there's nothing that
you're gonna do to stop me
what was your family's reaction to the
two girls it's like when you write about
it in a book
your dad finds out he's like well i you
know heard you got a girl pregnant he's
like and you say yeah and he's like no
this other girl you're like i was too
much of a coward to tell him god so they
find out from my pastor because the
the other woman calls my church
to try and [ __ ] because she's trying to
get resources
like how am i gonna
pay for
you know
birthing this man's child
and uh
so she's calling the church be like can
i can i get help and the pastor's like
wait a second who are you that's not the
name i know so when he calls my dad my
dad's like
what what's going on and i was just too
pathetic of a coward to to have the
balls just to tell my family hey here's
here's decisions that i'm struggling
through right now the reason i have to
go to san luis obispo every single month
is to get an hiv test
and the reason that i'm you know i don't
have any money for anything is because
i'm paying two separate women
uh because we're preparing
it's expensive to have a child
you know definitely prepare for having a
child don't do it on plan and the
children the kids end up being born nine
days apart is that right uh two weeks
two weeks apart
they're amazing yeah yeah they're uh
they're uh definitely blessed to be here
freaking awesome yeah
uh
you had after you already mentioned this
earlier in the podcast but after
september 11th you had gone down
to the recruiting station and
like put me in coach
you tried
you tried the navy so you were you
thinking seal team for sure and and it
was closed
no recruiter
so the next one was the marine corps how
did you decide between the marine corps
and the army uh
the 18 x-ray program
was the
the marines didn't have a direct route
to
go there was no marshal at the time so
they didn't have a clear defined pathway
to go to recon right and go in as a
rifleman from rifleman you can um go and
try out within
you know your own unit and then if you
get selected you so like that was gonna
be a very undefined process when i went
to the army recruiter they said all
right well here's this new program to
make it special operations
um you go through infantry school you go
to airborne school you go to this a
twitter called sop c you get through
stop c then you can go to selection
and uh if you get selected then go to
the q course if you finish the q course
then you get to go to special forces
it's like as clean of a track as you
could possibly he laid it out for me
but they didn't call you so you did you
did that after september 11th but there
was no room no right and so you're just
you're carrying on with your life all
this other [ __ ] happens yeah
and then by the grace of god like a week
after the swimming incident the naked
swimming accident my phone rings yeah
your phone rings and they say hey we got
a slot for you yep in in the army in 18
years his name was vaught recruiter
vaude or vaughn or something like that
it's like we got we your asvab score is
good d-lab score is good we can send you
to maps in in two weeks
to in process as a
an 11 bravo to become an 18 x-ray
so you're this is like a no-brainer at
this point this is like no there's no
choice there's not you you you signed
that line as soon as that paper was in
front of you that's right
uh
and then how long was it before how long
was it between that call was it two
weeks before you left oh it's out of
there yeah
that's pretty awesome yeah there was um
from the time
from 9 11 to the call was like 10 months
and then um
they didn't do a delayed entry i
finished my undergrad was in grad school
so they're we're trying to finish school
but ultimately once i got my ship date i
just left
i thought it was better to just go just
go yeah
boot camp
fun you had fun at boot camp i did
because now how old are you now 23 yeah
23 years old
um
no factor
then you you get this bonus program of
the special operations prep course
and
part of it is
is this this whole idea of this 18 x-ray
program means that you can do this
really kind of short path to get to
special forces
which some people in special forces
think that's like not right that's not
the right way to do it and you don't
deserve to be here and you need to pay
your dues like i paid they're not wrong
well
the only thing i'll say about that is in
talking to
a lot of the sag guys from vietnam that
that went in warren sag where they had
more than 100 casualty rate yeah
a lot of those guys
they took them right off the streets and
sent them to special forces and and i've
had those guys tell me like yeah
whatever
and they were bad at they were as badass
as any humans that have ever walked the
planet the guys that weren't soggy that
was the last time that they did that
x-ray program that's what they did from
there
yep and that they
rinse and repeat they're like we need
dudes we needed dudes then this is what
we did then let's just give it a try now
[Music]
so you're good so you go to the special
operations press prep course what you
call sop c yeah so you're in sopsy and
it's just basically a boot beat down
yeah it's just in twitter
uh pt twice a day land nav twice a week
rock run ruck run ruck run
um
and it's weird
i don't know if i grasped this so you're
there yep you're living in a barracks
whatever there's how many people are
there with you
uh over the course so the can a couple
of greenbr or a couple of kids died in
selection the fault the pr the prior
summer so they cancel selections from
uh heat exhaustion okay exposure
so from may until august they cancel
selections at
in north carolina so the course that
you're all trying to get into is
canceled we have to wait three months
for the first one to happen in august so
you're in this special operations prep
course yep
and it's supposed to be a six week
course it ends up being a three and a
half month course
and that's what so i so i was tracking
this and people just keep showing up
that's right to get ready to go to the
to to the to go to sleep person
selection
but they're
they're just quitting it's a revolving
door of quitters of buses arriving every
weekend from basic training so you go to
basic training you go to infant school
you go to airborne school and then the
guys that make it from there hop on a
bus and go to fort bragg north carolina
they show up at sopsy barracks and you
you show up to your morning formation
and then you go off and you get your
dick pushed in
[Music]
that's it and from may until august
every bus that came in was a new load of
people for them to get rid of
so i think over the course you know
we're somewhere between five to 600
studs show up
during those three to four months and
how many of them went to selection 91
check
and you were just there the whole time
we got there we got there in may
i'll tell you what the 91 dudes that
went 88 of us got selected yeah that's
what that's what you go on to say yeah
so typically you get 8 out of 100
at a selection so if i have 400 people
there you know we're going to have 8 16
24 32 guys that get selected and um
so we got we batted 88 out of 91.
there's no way
that you could get rid of us yeah
because you've been
done just getting crushed
well every event that happens in
selection they had tested us on every
month during the three months so when my
12 mile i knew what my i knew
exactly my pace counts my times my five
mile times like bring it bro there's not
nothing
kill me in my sleep that's the only way
and how long is selection itself a month
and that's 27 days that's more of it was
basically the same as sock stop c but
it was counting now yeah yep that's it
so when we get there it was selection
was easy for us because they they had to
stick to
the
the clear
you have to test guys in vacuums to be
able to compare
make sure that you're giving the fair
test measurement to these guys going
through
so um
when we
didn't have to go into the gig pit in
between events we got to sleep in
between events this was new to us
i was like what is this and we had been
cheating for the past four months you
know we had figured out we had
reorganized ourselves into alphabetic um
uh
barracks
so and we would line up alphabetically
um so we knew kind of the fire order of
how people were going to be called we
had figured out a rotation of when guys
were going to be running to the board so
we'd only have two people up instead of
you know the prescribed number that they
would require so when somebody would
come in somebody would alert us we'd all
wake up it's in there we're just
cheating and we cheated our way through
everything going forward
cheated cheetah cheated
then what sucks is though you get done
with you get done with uh selection and
then
you get sent back to sopsy again
for more time in purgatory yep
well it's a it's a new sopsy this one's
called sopsy two
so the next detritter where they lost
all of us and this is what i say us the
18 x-rays
most
special forces guys going through post
selection the the next phase to go to is
small unit tactics phase two
and most infantrymen you got 7-8 you
know you've been spending time in the
82nd or you're coming from ranger
regiment you know how to you know how to
do army things we don't know how to do
army things
so when we get done with selection they
put us into a pre-small unit tactics
training course
um it ends up not being a hyatt trader
we only lose maybe 10 of the guys that
are there
and they are legitimately teaching us
react to contact how to do an ambush
like basic 7-8 infantryman stuff
for when we get to small unit tactics
because small unit tactics isn't a
triter they lose lots of guys there
so you actually got
extra preparation to get ready for for
small unit tactics school yeah
so you guys must have done really well
and that as well
yeah we were we were starving to get
into the q course proper and phase two
is the first
post selection that is the first moment
where like you are in the queue course
you are now in the pipeline to become a
green beret
and then what's next so what came after
that so then you learn your
you get
up to this point you are an 18 x-ray you
have a not defined mos
so then you get your
you get to go to your mos school you
have a bravo charlie delta or echo
i got bravo which was a weapon sergeant
and then you got the so i went to my
three-month mos training which is phase
three and did i read this right your
the weapons the 18 bravo's the the
highest attrition rate that's right how
come
um
or dumb
at first
uh
it is
it is um
we are not just it's not just weapons
like they're called weapon sergeants but
we're tested on base security um we're
test we're responsible for
um all of the
elements of the oda's kind of
preparedness for running ranges and
deployments and um if we're going to be
going traveling overseas the bravo is
the guy that's going to have the force
response plan the emergency action plan
the evacuation plan
um in addition to you know knowing how
to run a mortar how to set up uh you
know close air support that is all bravo
stuff
are you guys like you guys do the close
air support on the radio too
no kidding on regular odas it's
typically the bravo or the echo that
goes to those courses jack
uh so you go to that school
you're the honor graduate of that school
yep
yeah
that's fun what were you what were you
what did you excel at in the school i
loved guns um i was i
as an armor now and i own a weapons
manufacturing company
i've always just loved the
like watches and um firearms i love the
the mechanics of how things work
and um i
and one of the funnest things about the
18 bravo course is you'll get this like
bucket of parts and it'll be an uzi
there'll be a you know parts to a goosed
off that you don't get to build because
the rest of gustav's not there you know
you're gonna have an fnfl you know
you're gonna have an ar and you get in
like
go time starts now assemble you're like
well uh i don't have the tube so i don't
need this and then you just start
putting things together like this is the
block from the uzi cool here's the
trigger assembly to the uzi all right
here's here's the trigger and just
it was like and my brain just loved it i
just loved it
uh
all right on so that means you're going
to be in 18 bravo and then what comes
next is robin sage next lang so they did
it a little bit different for us we did
sorry you did some compressed language
school yeah
yeah in
which is last spaniel yeah we
normally you have like three months in a
language because every green beret has
to have a minimum of a second language
and uh they took
anyone that had any degree of language
and like this is peak war you know this
is 2004 2005.
and uh body bags are coming in every day
at the jfk chapel at fort bragg they're
having a new ceremony for a dead green
beret like this is and our instructors
are just livid that they're the ones
that are stuck at swic having to train
us
you know they don't want to be there and
i get it they want to be back with their
teams
and we the the young
want to be green berets like we are just
chomping at the bit to get out and we're
doing everything we're doing we're
trying to cut every corner we're trying
to if you graduate on a friday most
people would want like a month to
recover not at this time can is there
any way is there any spots for me to
start on monday
and um and when somebody says hey you
can
skip two months of language school if
you do this program yep throw me in
there and what did you take spanish yep
wish i took russian
yeah yeah
uh
so then comes rob robin sage
and this is where like it seems like all
your mischievous life
gets to
be utilized that's right you get to you
get rewarded for being sneaky um one of
the ops that you talk about one of the
training ops that you talk about in
there you're supposed to assault some
place and you guys go in
and and drain like
most of the fuel of all the generators
yeah and and you have it all kind of
timed so that
in the middle of the night all the
generators fail that's right which means
all the lights go out which means
there's confusion by the cadre and then
you guys roll in there yeah like
you're getting after it matt yeah we one
of our friends um that he had like a
staph infection he was he was support
for the cadre
and uh we were supposed to turn all our
cell phones um we had prison pockets so
our cell phones were definitely still on
us
so we're getting text messages as we're
getting like our where our next
objective is going to be we're getting
the updates as to when the catcher are
going to roll in and blow us out we're
getting like play-by-plays of what their
plans are
and
so we get where the objective is going
to be what time the hit time is going to
be so we get there as they're setting up
we siphon out gas out of the generators
we already know which vehicles are the
cadre vehicles so when they roll up to
start setting things up and the lights
go out and we're just like dude like we
had axle grease over our faces we had
blacked out our uniforms and we just
cruised up and stole all their stuff we
stole their tobacco we stole their
headlamps we stole their uniforms
i stole a kit one of the cadre's kids
toys out of his car
you know
they loved it oh yeah
you know this is this is again peak war
where they're like okay these dudes are
hungry yeah that's what we want yep
that's awesome um you go to see your
school you freaking cheat in seer school
yeah in a big way yeah you go
you go out and you hide mres and caches
throughout the ao
so you can eat yeah
again
we uh we get informed as to where our
evasion lane is going to be
he gives me like a left azimuth and a
right azimuth and this is my evasion
lane
so we go and i take boxes of mres and i
go and i dig them and plant them with
10-digit grid coordinates as to where
these boxes and mres are on our evasion
lane so when they get cut loose when
they let us loose and be like all right
we're going to chase you guys you know
you got your couple hours to go
um like we just bee line straight
azimuth
to the first box mres
dig those things up
and you had a crew that was in on it yep
a bunch of 18x rays
mostly except for one air force guy
and um to his credit he
uh you know he didn't want to break any
rules and he thought that we were
cheating
and we were
and um so when he said he wasn't going
to eat the mres cool we we ate that
emory of his but we we helped him and as
best we could like if he's going to be a
man of integrity and ethics
we hunted for him you know we forged for
him um we tried to get and he would get
all of that food like if i'm getting
dear corn if i'm if i'm if i'm dumpster
diving into somebody's backyard and i
find you know a leftover sandwich like
he's getting all of it he's not getting
split 12 ways he gets all of it so he
was better off than any other dude in
any other evasion team
as like there were
11 other people forging for him
and um
until you finally reach the your
motivation to not get caught is the
longer that you stay on the lam the
longer that you stay running that's less
time that you spend in the concentration
camp getting using advanced terror
interrogation techniques so
you get a week and camp slappy
period you're gonna get you're gonna get
period unless you get caught early if
you get caught early every day that you
get caught early is an extra day at camp
slappy so when we get to
the you know the final phase of seer
the camp's already full we're the last
team to roll in there and uh you know we
get betrayed by our contact our courier
that's supposed to take us out of the
country and he turns us over to the
invading forces
and we have black bags over our head
they pop them off they start slapping us
and they're going down the line and all
of us are lined up and they're doing the
interrogation thing
pretty rough and it's one of the most
dangerous times is when you're initially
captured so there's really strict things
that you're supposed to do to not
encourage them to be more violent
because that's when executions happen
in real war you're like
immediately after capture like that's a
really dangerous time you want to be
really compliant you want to really
stick to this this method of
um being as complicit as you can per
perception wise
until that dude's bag comes off and he
just starts singing like a canary
these guys cheated they buried food and
the whole it was like you could hear a
pin drop you could all the cadres
stopped talking all of them descended
like sharks onto this one guy and they
said what did you say they said they
buried food this whole team has been
eating they had mres they knew exactly
where they're going to be going
they took all 11 of us and they
separated us immediately
so seer school became real
and it went from school to real life
immediately
because
if you cheated if you got caught for
cheated all this idea of being a green
brain would be thrown out of the wind
it's gone
no recycling
yeah this is an integrity violation it's
different than failing
failing
you sometimes get to get rehabilitated
and come back
if you cheated you're out
yeah
so
all of you
separated have to maintain
the same story 11 of us for seven days
waterboarding
ice tanks
um pain positions and all their
interrogation was based around did you
cheat or not that's right
yep did you have food where did you get
the food
who buried the food
um hey tim told us you know you can stay
yeah
but we're taking tim out because tim's
already gone you know tim told us
and um and uh you can stay we just need
to be corroborated
so um you know shawn stain
he backed him up and we just need one
more it's like they they're good these
guys these are professional
interrogators
and and the whole team held whole team
suck it
not one of us broke
and the final day of seer school when
things just start getting crazier and
crazier like people are flying through
the air you know and like
getting made fun of getting beaten
getting sprayed down with hoses it's
getting worse and worse and worse and
worse and all of a sudden
a moment happens where you know it's the
end of seeing school and i'm not going
to ruin that moment because it's one of
the most significant emotional moments
and
it's um
and i just look around i got my 11
brothers
all all 11 of us standing right there
can cadre show up to our dawning of our
green beret so at the end of the school
they're like hey we need to talk to you
guys and we're like
zero chance bro
cool i see you got your art you pulled
your id card out of your neck and it's
hanging from your lanyard here i don't
give a [ __ ] you're like i don't there's
zero chance any of us are saying
anything you can meet us when i put my
green beret on so we get our knife we
sign our name in the book of truth
we throw on our green beret we learn
what group we're going to and they're
all standing there at that ceremony
being like
we need to talk to you guys
it was it was a proof of concept one for
the one of the first times they had to
legitimately do interrogations on people
that legitimately had something to hide
to see
and it proved that the things that they
were teaching
worked
yeah it's awesome
that's
that's pretty awesome that everyone
stuck it out yeah because when they
start saying hey look we already kicked
him out he's he's he's going to the
whatever you call it in the army we call
it the fleet the navy but they're saying
hell yeah tim already or hey tim just
ratted you guys out he's trying to save
himself over there he we're keeping him
because he said you're the one that
planned it
they start doing that [ __ ] man they're
breaking people down
zero chance but the worst part was they
had one guy you know they had one guy
that had told them everything so they
were going off of all of his information
which was all true so it was a really
hard thing in my head
as they're recounting well like we knew
exactly he he very accurately described
which i was really impressed
that he could remember
you know he didn't have the grid
coordinates but he remembered exactly
where it was off of the airfield it was
about 200 meters in from this road off
of this airfield it was under this big
log
and
um
i gotta throw out uh
a warning to anyone that's going through
selection what tim kennedy did is not
smart don't do this don't do that and
the idea of like if you ain't cheating
you ain't trying it's actually not a
good thing to do because you're risking
your career and tim kennedy and his 11
friends freaking got away with it
by a miracle uh don't do this kind of
[ __ ] learn how to cheat at your oda yeah
when you get there you and your team
there's there are methods about how
you're going to cheat in country it's
called resistance it's called
unconventional warfare and there's
doctrine designed about how to do it
yeah that doctrine is written by the
crystals and mattis's read that doctrine
and cheat that way don't don't do what
like a 23 year old idiot and his 23 year
old friends did
there's so many things
you do not want to put your life
your life your life as a special
operations guy
at risk for anything right for nothing
so if you're in a going to these one of
these selection courses
just
take the high ground on everything
really and if you don't you get caught
and it's like no one cares like i would
i wouldn't even be talking to you right
now you'd be you'd have been like some
random dude yeah if i would've gotten
out of the army like i've been psychops
yeah i did civil affairs yeah like it's
just don't do it um i wanted to throw
that in there because
you know i i think it was for me it was
like third phase and buds where
the instructors started saying
if you ain't cheating you ain't trying
this [ __ ]
you're only cheating yourself that's
what they said now i think about they
say you're only cheating yourself
and
man you don't want to get caught bro
there's two it's too awesome
to be a part of the community
to to risk it
over something
that made your life a little bit easier
yeah for those days anyways i had to
throw that caveat in there no that's big
exclamation mark
um
context of time though
this is
2004.
like
we wanted war so bad
you know
for sure for sure
and
i mean i don't know i don't know if your
if your thought process
was i don't know what your thought
process those dudes this is what it was
there's dudes on horseback
fighting with the mujahideen uh-huh like
no but my point is like
i i
when i was going through buds i like sat
in my room on the weekends and sharpened
my knife and polished my boots a guy
could go out drinking like do i was like
bro i'm not risking anything i'm not
gonna i'm just i just want to make it
through this [ __ ] um
so what was your so i think we were a
product of their own creation during
those four months in sap c
where
we had to learn how to cheat and
everything we had we had to reorganize
our barracks we had to um we went and
stole washing machines from other
barracks at the 82nd and move them so we
could do more loads of laundry i went
stole washing machines we went you know
there weren't enough beds for the number
of guys that came in so we went to the
82nd and stole their beds out of their
their not occupied barracks
um
if you watch like the original green
beret movie with john wayne and one of
the opening scenes they see you see this
huey come in and they're just stealing
stuff from the supply yard
and uh like
that's what we're doing yeah you know so
in by seer school we had really refined
we had been cheating this whole entire
time out of an essence of survival
and uh and that was that carried over
negatively there was a culture that had
kind of been created yep and that yeah
bled into the next video as a leader be
really careful about the culture that
you create because the byproduct of the
product of that you create in the
environment that you build is going to
be what you're going to have to deal
with
so like yes you can make things so hard
that
sometimes the the creation from this
environment from this culture is going
to be worse had you just changed what
that culture was
you know
you got married yeah
when did you get married after once you
got your green beret yeah i had a green
beret
done a couple of trips gone to a couple
schools i was getting ready to go to
iraq
and that was uh
that's when
ginger
finally conceded
you broke her down psyops i know i did
it was um
it was not
she wouldn't talk to me
so i had to say she's smart she's smart
so i had to figure out who her pattern
of life is like was i figured out who
all her friends were i befriended all of
her friends and then um i figured out
like their center of gravity like where
they went and why they hung out there
and i created i fabricated environments
that were where they would go to create
opportunities for me to go and find her
and talk to her and then ultimately i i
created this event that was live all the
things that they loved live music good
food wine
and um
and i told them different times
so i i told my principal which is my
wife to be to be there at one time and i
told all of her friends different times
so then when she showed up 30 minutes
late but 30 minutes before the rest of
them came which was an hour after i told
her
i had already pre-planned a text message
to go out to all them be like ah cancel
don't worry about coming over and i tell
her oh man the uh nobody else is coming
let's just go out to dinner
and that was it psyops yeah
you get married um and you get
you get put into the sif that's right
which is again now you're an 18 x-ray
which means you haven't been
in in the regular army at all you've
gone straight straight through school
and you get put into the sif which is
the commander's in extremis force which
is normally some more experienced guys
yeah it should be definitely
but you get thrown in there yeah
john mcphee uh sheriff of baghdad he was
he was a great cag operator
he is the team sergeant for this team
he had known me kind of from fighting
and um he
knew i was a
i don't know what his motivation was
like he knew as a fighter he knew as a
shooter and they were looking for extra
bodies to get ready to go to
iraq
and um
so
they he went and snagged me
it's pretty awesome super awesome
[Laughter]
but you're so you got a good reputation
as like a fighter and you're the
undergraduate and all this other stuff
but you're still a new guy showing up at
us yeah still an fng uh
but a hungry hungry bulldog
yeah you i imagine they were freaking
stoked
yeah
no
it's wild that he you know he goes and
gets me i show up at the team room and
i'm standing in front of the team room
with my bags and they're not letting me
in you know i stand out in front of that
team room for a day
just standing there for like 10 hours
the door comes open like we told you to
leave
no
i was assigned to this team like well we
don't want you so go away i stand there
for 10 days or for 10 hours waiting to
be let in
so
they finally let you finally let me in
to go move the gym
oh yeah they make you move the gym and
then say i don't like that way it looks
now move it back put it back
um
and then you're deployed you you end up
jumping right into a deployment to iraq
right away yeah i get done with
sephardic
which is a required school to be part of
the the sif and um it's a
three-month-long kind of hostage rescue
direct action school and um
as soon as i graduate from that
i get on advance already gone
pds pdss is kind of complete avon's done
they're already in country i get on the
next plane flying with the team
how
freaking amped is tim kennedy at this
juncture i'm so happy yeah i was like
freaking
thrilled
to one be in the unit to have finished
sephardic so early like that's a school
that you usually wait five six years to
be able to go to i graduate from the q
course i go to sephardic and i report to
the sif like this is wild and then you
you know you're do you guys know you're
slotted to deploy you know where you're
deploying to i don't
um but they do
i'm i i haven't even i haven't even been
read in yet you know so i have no idea
what anything is i don't know where the
deployment is i don't know where we're
going i don't know where our mission is
so you get done with sephardic then you
check into your team
and how long does it take for you to
find out that you're going to iraq
the three weeks
so this is now so it's 2006. yep so iraq
is going off it is crazy
yeah
you're how do you get there do you fly
c-17 c-17 but where do you stop do you
stop anyone on the way over you must
stop somewhere shannon air force base i
think
and then you roll where do you land do
you roll into baghdad no we got all
assad
yeah direct into al-assad
and your tim kennedy has got to be as
amped as tim can you get this forward
yeah the um
the combat approach of military aircraft
into a combat zone it is not like a
delta airlines you know
please put up your tray you know bring
your seats to an upright position and
make sure that your seat belts are
attached that your bag's underneath the
seat in front of you like that's not
what's happening it's like this crazy
corkscrew circle as they drop from 30
000 feet down to land and the final
corkscrew is your final approach like
that's it
so as you know we have humvees and we
have our our trucks and uh all of our
pallets of guns and our connexes and
it's like
to the ground the gate opens and you get
hit with this hundred and something to
green temperature in the dark of night
and it was
freaking amazing
the first time i flew to baghdad i was
with my platoon who were flying in it's
the same thing
and
uh i'm always like i'm not gonna show
anybody any emotions at all or whatever
i'm always just like looking around
they're all good and the the plane
starts going into that mode and you're
like we're like getting jerked around a
little bit and this one buddy of mine
who's like a
a young enlisted guy but an awesome guy
he's like got big eyes he looks at me he
goes these are evasive
i can't even say he's like these are
evasive maneuvers and i go we'll be good
so i'm like just totally calm cool like
oh we'll be good no factor you know
something like this but i remember
thinking these are some of these
universes what's the yes
right now
um
awesome so you're on the ground
your
your mission and kind of the countries
of much of the country and certainly a
lot of special operations at the time
was focused on
getting amz
um zarqawi he was the number one guy in
iraq for sure the number two guy
underneath bin laden
um
but
he was he he was
super hostile super aggressive uh been a
lot he pissed off bin laden he was going
so far i mean you got a good quote in
the book uh
something along the lines of hey when
when osama bin laden is telling you you
need to calm down that's an indicator
that you might be a little out of
control and that was zarqawi for sure
madman yup um violent violent to a
degree
we're pretty comfortable with violence
even now looking back the things that
the type of way that he the tyranny that
he
put on both the iraq's the iraqis and
americans i mean it was an extra special
level of evil yeah this is the guy that
was decapitating um
you know just on camera just cutting
people's heads off nick berg
uh
this guy's a a hateful
he was the black water contractor
capture right the blackwater guys that
got burned alive
dragged through the street that was him
um the dudes that were put in the cages
in bernal like that was him the
you know drilling screwing dude's hands
to the walls so they could watch their
families get tortured and murdered that
was him like he's nasty this guy's an
awful nasty dude awful
excuse for a human being
uh and so that's what you guys are
focused on that's what much of special
operations and and
what like this means going after
everyone in his network everyone that he
touches everyone that he everything that
he does we're watching we're tracking
we're trying to get a step ahead of them
uh
your first op
you're going on a capture kill mission
some hvt some high value target
you helo into the target
you're approaching this enemy building
um i'm gonna go to the book on this one
because it's pretty good oh
uh john this is john mcphee um
you say john has us all moved back
about 100 meters forms us into an
l-shaped ambush on the building and
begins a call out it's exactly what it
sounds like we get on a megaphone we
start telling the people to get out of
the house within five minutes two guys
and five women and their children leave
one of the women tells us her husband is
still in there
we ask him to get out for 15 minutes
it starts nice
but at the end our terp is essentially
screaming get out of the house
[ __ ] we're coming in to get you
he doesn't budge
we're going in
the four of us walk to the front door
as dave frederick's ben rios mario
montice say that right yep mata say
montessay
and manny villalobos
move to the back door through the
sheep's pen the rest of the guys are
either hitting the other buildings or
covering the windows of outs just in
case the guy guy tries to squirt out
we're set
as the number one man al pulls the door
open and i is the number two man
throwing a flashbang john is a number
three man covers the doorway with his
rifle in case someone tries to take a
shot at me or al as we do our jobs bam
the flashbang goes off and we flow into
the room one behind the other we see a
guy sprint past the door our terp yells
for the guy to get on the ground over
and over again the guy is not going to
the ground
he is defiant my red dot is on his chest
as our owls and john's
he takes a breath and makes an athletic
movement away from us
i hear al switch his weapon
from safe to semi it's such a small
sound the tiny click of metal on metal
but all veterans know what that sound
means
it's go time
you can always hear it through fat flash
bangs through grenades through artillery
that little click engages the mechanism
in your brain that tells you this event
is now real my eyes see where this man
is going and my brain slowly passes that
message to my body
he grabs an ak-47 and starts to spin
towards us
somewhere between the time he grabs for
the gun and the time he turns toward us
with it i move my weapon to semi as does
jon
by the time
the man's gun gets two-thirds around the
half circle from where he grabbed it to
where he's pointed it al
i'll squeeze off one or two rounds
milliseconds later i double tap the guy
john shoots him almost the same time i
do also double tapping the guy falls the
ground lifeless there are five maybe six
holes stacked on top of each other
through his heart
to be honest if you don't look carefully
it looks like one bullet wound
i just killed for the first time
although i think al's round gets the
actual credit but at the moment i'm
actually impressed with how good we are
i thought this would be a bigger moment
i thought it would have gravitas it
doesn't he was a bad man he tried to
kill us now he's dead
it's that simple for me what isn't
simple is hearing his wife's screams
when the shots ring out there's no sound
like the sound of a woman seeing her
husband die it rattles me and lingers
we collect intel off the entire building
we get blood samples fingerprints face
pictures and we take the body with us
there's a ton of valuable intelligence
here and this huge unexpected win
tactically
but his wife keeps screaming at us she's
saying we murdered him it doesn't matter
to her that we gave the guy the
opportunity to leave the house it
doesn't matter that he tried to kill us
we killed her husband
i look at the other men glaring at us i
look at the kids crying
did we just make more terrorists
will these kids grow up to try and kill
more americans i probably would if i
were them
the wife complains enough that there's
an immediate investigation of al's
decision to pull the trigger this is a
huge shock to me isn't this war this
[ __ ] guy was going to kill us
nevertheless the sergeant major took
statements from everyone
they did a forensic analysis of the
shoot and concluded that what we did
that what we said happened is exactly
what happened al is cleared
when we get back to the house
when we get back to the base the guys at
blue tell us we did a great job they
apparently watched the whole thing via
satellite now there's a lot more trust
they don't think we're idiots anymore
we're off to the races
good way to kick it off
yeah the um
it's weird though you know the um
it's weird in the sense that
you know
flash bangs
you know call outs when we're doing a
call out we're also flying throwing
flash bangs you know get out of the get
out of the out of the house like throw a
flashbang in there you're on a
microphone
um like this this dude did pre-position
weapons inside the house and he didn't
know which way we were going to come in
so he was kind of squirting to where his
kind of designated fighting positions
were hoping to get us in hallways
not not bad i mean that's
legit kind of tactics on his part
clearly thought this through yeah i mean
it's 2006 it's these
these guys have been working for a while
yeah and for him still be alive he knows
something yeah
and uh
you know in that rotation of
that half-second exposure
it's the book and
when the gun is seen is or i intense you
can't even put attach how fast these
things happen you know you as he turns
from around the corner you don't see
anything until you essentially see the
barrel and the barrel's already starting
to come up so it's just like
and that's three people shooting at the
same time
and um
and then it's just it's not movies you
know it's not a dude flies back or
there's he just drops just drops and
that's the end
and then you continue with your
clearance yep
yeah you step over that body
and uh go to the next room
it's weird
um
but you had to after this op you know
like you said you you start to build
trust with the uh blue that's there
which is the navy component um sounds
like it was a little bit of a rough
start with those guys because they maybe
didn't
didn't have the same level of trust with
you guys before this hop or something
um
this was c37's first combat tour okay so
that i think that reservation was well
founded
and um you know they they
their roe their kill chain in their
vertical kill chart
they were looking for really specific
targets
we just wanted to get in the fight
you know so they didn't want to
use air assets at the expense of missing
an opportunity for a tst right which i
also get
but then we just wanted to get in a
fight you know so it was kind of
priorities they had already been there
they're they're they're working off of
you know you if you think like in the
movies you got this
this big wall and you have the top
zarkawi and then you have all of the
targets and you have clear lines of
people that might know him you're really
hoping for one of those to populate as a
target
and if you meanwhile there's
332 other people that also need to die
and you're like we'll take those two
yeah
yeah but what expense right if 160th if
we have two chinooks and and four
blackhawks and we use all of them for
this mission then this dude that's like
nine tiers down and then somebody that's
on tier three pops up but we missed that
one because you know we're off doing
something else just to find work
so yeah
um
so you you know kick ass that sounds
cool but then what's interesting is uh
the next night or the next op yeah they
like come up shy a a helicopter for
whatever it was mechanical reasons that
happened it got lit up those v those
helicopters getting shot every night so
the next stop that you're supposed to go
on they're down a helicopter so they
can't take everybody but they can kind
of rework the force list and get almost
everybody in there so everyone's going
on the off except for one dude me tim
kennedy gets left behind so angry
uh
so they go out and i can't even this is
like torture this is the second op that
they go on
and you don't go and you you just feel
like you're being tortured yeah and
you're sitting there getting ready for
qrf and all this other stuff but it's
just freaking
so pissed
in fact you're so pissed
you're so pissed that when
they get back
you pull
uh uh mcphee aside
and you like berate him like hey that
was bad bad call bro you know you should
have taken your best your brightest dude
you lit you have a book you say uh could
you imagine you say i'm the best shot
the most physically fit and i dominated
on that last miss and i should have been
the first to go not the first
to not go like
that's the kind of an e5 i can't even an
e5 that's crazy i've been out of the q
course for two months
or i've been on the unit for two months
yeah
and uh an e5 is walking up to the master
sergeant
be like listen listen man
let me tell you what you should have
done
let me tell you let me tell you why
you're wrong yeah all the ways bro
that's crazy yeah
all right hey man props you put it in
the book man no it's in there it's it's
it's a good perspective for those young
troopers out there man it's good
perspective because because you can feel
that way sometimes you be looking at
some guy like i should be going and the
worst honestly here's what sucks the
worst way to get to go on the next
mission
is to go to that person and say you
should have put me on this mission it's
the worst way it's like saying hey man i
think i deserve my purple belt now like
don't do that no uns you're setting your
mouth
zip it go in there and do work yeah
uh
he goes old school though
and and basically says all right i'll
tell you what kennedy
go grab your boxing gloves so we're
gonna settle this you know in which case
you're like oh hell yeah we're gonna
settle this boy
but he's a stud john looks just like you
he's just a brick you know he's broad
shoulders thick neck you know chunked
ears he's grappler he's fighter
and uh i've seen i've seen uh pictures
of him and yeah he looks like a beast of
a dude yeah
i don't care i'm gonna scuff that one
guy up
and unfortunately for you he's not one
he's not thinking one guy he's thinking
gang foo
so i walk into that tent and the whole
team's there
which which should have just been such a
lesson in such a moment where it's like
a dude
my whole my whole team is on the other
side of the line i'm on this side of the
line but instead i was like dude i'll
show them
let's show them what they're missing
you know i got this part that book right
their leadership strategy and tactics
it's the the section the book is called
conform to influence and it's i'm
talking about when i was a new guy
because tim kennedy you wouldn't have a
freaking patent on being a young jackass
i was a new guy and i was like
you know trying to be hardcore and like
people be we'd be going for a run our
team would be going for a run i'd be
like wearing boots putting on a rucksack
running the old course with a rock on
and
like my god like my platoon mates and
i'm a new guy would be like dude hey man
you need to chill out and i'm just like
maybe you need to be more hardcore like
you know what i'm saying like obviously
i'm freaking hardcore over here i got my
rock on i see you with a pair of running
shoes on what's up you tell me what's up
no
and uh what i finally realized
at a point you know like someone said
hey hey rambo you need to chill out and
i was kind of like
it took me a minute to realize oh
if i'm not part of this group i have no
influence over this group whatsoever and
i'll just be ostracized and i won't be a
part of this platoon and
when i realized that i was like okay i
get it
and this is a classic example where it's
like when you're standing and you're
looking at everyone on your team on the
other side that's that's
that's a signal
to you young trooper you're in the wrong
yeah
and look you might be you might be air
quotes right about this particular item
or that particular item
but when there's 12 against one
you're making a mistake somehow you're
doing something wrong you're not
building relationships like you should
uh
and they line up on you and you go two
minutes two minute rounds with these
dudes
do do i do pretty well for 10.
start getting scuffed up the last two
shane thompson good boxer beats me
then john starts laying it on me and i
was like all right i wasn't so bad then
i go back to number one and i go back
through the team again and then the
whole team they just beat the brakes off
me one dude after another and uh until
i'm sitting there on that
those tents you have uh
the whole thing's kind of plastic you
know but you carry dust and iraq has
especially at all assad it's like this
moon dust so there's this thin layer
that's sitting on top of this plastic so
it's like you know it's like the drool
and the blood is dripping out of my face
and the sweats coming off my forehead
and it's hitting that moon dust i can
see the white
under
plastic
and uh and it's it's this bright white
of my blood and sweat and saliva
splashing in front of me as the rest of
the team is just walking out and i'm
just looking at my own like drool
and again this is one of those moments
where in the book i'm like oh cool he's
going to get this lesson learned
and you you freely admit you're like
there was a lesson we learned there i
did
you're like see it took those guys two
rounds to get me yeah
so don't
[Laughter]
man um
but you you continue doing ops uh
and
you guys sounds like you got a pretty
good op tempo going june 7th 2006
you do this bit there's a like a whole
you know uh
almost a wide
series of operations that's going on as
we're as as they're getting closer and
closer and closer to actually figuring
out where zarqawi is
um kag's out rangers are out ictf is out
you guys are hitting targets after
target after target um
amz finally gets tracked to a building
and the air force bombs it
zarqawi's dead uh and what's interesting
is i i was you know you and i were
talking about this before we pressed
record but i was in iraq at this time
too i think you got there in march and i
got there in april
so
that was a big deal
um
when
when zarqawi finally got killed yeah
pretty awesome
it got wild for a couple months after
that too yeah well that's what i was
going to say is
i
when zarqawi got killed i
didn't think it would have
any impact on the amount of operations i
didn't think it would slow down the
insurgents at all and in fact the
insurgents kind of went ham after this
point they really started going off
uh
so it
it picked up you know quite honestly
yeah and it sounds like it picked up for
you guys too yeah
how how often are you guys going out
every night you know when we left
al-assad and and we ended up in the
green zone the international zone
in baghdad proper
um
i mean whether it was a gaffe or a half
whether we were being a ground assault
force or a helicopter assault force i
mean every night we were getting out and
getting after it i mean
you'd hear the ictf half of our troop
was
um over with ictf out of blood and you'd
hear them in gunfights and then we'd be
on the other side of the town hitting
another target and they'd hear us in a
gunfight and then one of us would be
calling qrf and our qrf or a couple of
bradleys and an ember and an m1 abrams
and that thing
down the street you hear that thing
most beautiful sound all i mean you've
ever heard is a bradley rattling into a
building with insurgents hiding inside
of it
god bless the 25 millimeter chain gun
uh
so you're getting some good experience
um
did you guys take any casualties on that
planet no
i mean not a lick
the uh you know a couple of purple
hearts that were kind of
kind of kind of give me
um like some shrapnel from a grenade
that went off a ways away and like hit a
dude's hand um but like real no no
casualties weird hammers yeah and uh
well that's what's awesome
you know
you've got to have some level of luck
but when you're setting up these
massively offensive aggressive
operations a lot of times you're
catching the enemy
not ready for it which is exactly what
you're that speed surprise and violence
of action it's so it's so easy to say
speed surprise and violence violence of
action but when you're on the receiving
end
of
let's say a company you know of
60 soft special operations guys where
every single breach point of your
building explodes at the same time
simultaneously every exterior breach
point shatters every window has
something flying through it and there's
a gun getting stuck in every single
opening of the entire building and
there's bodies coming through everything
one of those exterior doors and the
entire complex gets secured in a matter
of eight seconds
it is there's there's no there's there's
nothing that you can do there's nothing
yep
uh
it's a good way to win man speed
surprise and violence of action
so
you get done with that deployment
um
you fly back to america
uh you and your wife
go you know you get your wife you get
some good food
you're a little you're still scanning
for threats a little bit you know
how was it driving how was it driving
around like i remember when i came back
from my first deployment we were in
humvees all the time i was like driving
around like remember the bridges like
everyone's like oh if you go under a
bridge that's where they and so you go
like any car that's getting closer you
sort of get that little like i'm about
to freaking pit this dude off for sure
you know um somebody doesn't use their
blinker i'm like it's a vbi you know
and uh there's like a dead dog on the
side of the road it's like there's an
ied plant in that dog there's a that's
that's a dead dog bomb i know that dog
you know i've seen that one before and i
get a smell of trash and i immediately
get flashback you know if heaven forbid
i smell somebody smoking a clove or i
drive by an indian restaurant i smell
some curry you know and that mixed with
the fuel and exhaust of a vehicle i'm
boom i'm right back into combat
it's wild yeah yeah
the brain is cool yeah um
but then what's what happens uh
you get told mcphee
tells you you're going to ranger school
yeah
and he also says if you're not the honor
grad of ranger school you're out of chef
that's right
how were you fired up for ranger school
i was
it was there were other schools i wanted
to go to i wanted to go to sniper school
you know i want to go to halo school um
i wanted to go to school to school
i wanted to like to combat dive school
and so there are all these schools i
wanted to go to
um but the former ranger regiment team
sergeant again here's here's another
little clue into how how useless and
ignorant and selfish and egotistical i
was as in this this period
like those are all my schools i was not
even thinking how would it help how
would i become a better asset for my
team how would i become you know as a
new guy a better leader how do i
understand the army a little bit better
you know there were there were so many
good schools that should have been on my
list and the very first one as a wise
new guy with a ranger regiment former
ranger regiment team sergeant like the
first words out of my mouth should have
been i want to go to ranger school team
sergeant you know like not hey i want to
go to halo school like what a
tool what a bag of dicks i have
you know
in the seal teams
often not 100 of time oftentimes ranger
school is punishment it's it's a it it's
punishment it's also a little bit of
purgatory that you can redeem yourself
so if you got a problem
if you've done something if you've been
off track
they will send you to ranger school it's
sort of like halfway punishment and also
a road to redemption jason redmond who's
been on here um you know he he he was
he was an enlisted guy became an officer
and
was
not quite ready for it and
he his redemption was all right you're a
little jacked up we're gonna send you a
ranger school it's a great school you
know it's a it is a leadership school i
think there's a lot of misconceptions
about what ranger school is
um you think about the army rangers
which is a special operations unit that
does really rad special operations
things as a direct action force and then
you have ranger school which is a really
great leadership school and as an 18
x-ray
that has not even spent a day in the
regular army like the one school i
should have been raising my hand to go
to is ranger school and uh not as a
punishment as like i need this like this
is who this not developed soldier this
is what i now need
but that's not what i'm saying
[Music]
so john's giving john you know like and
at the time and i was so mad at john and
uh john and i've been talking since this
book came out and you know he and i j
he's like i may not have been the boss
that you wanted but you're as the boss
that you needed
and it's so true yeah he was such a
great great human um he's not a great
human he was such a great leader that i
needed
uh yeah
before you go to ranger school you go
and compete for the second time in the
army combatives championship yeah and
you win
wild tournaments
the uh i keep using the word wild
because i don't know
i mean well i think i'm
i've been using that word a lot today
too i think i started off the whole
podcast talking about there's a wild
story we're about to read but yeah wild
the tournament is a is a three-day fight
fest
you have one day of grappling where
you're gonna you're gonna fight
somewhere between five to ten times in
one day and the next day is pan craze
and you're gonna fight if if you're in
the heaven forget forbid you lose one
grappling match and you're in the loser
bracket for you to fight your way back
into the winner's bracket you're gonna
fight five or six times in in full mma
pancrease fights
so now you're somewhere between i don't
know 10 to 15 fights by day two and then
day three how long are the fights
they're they're full five-minute
three-round fights
15-minute fights
damn
yeah dude
paint race they're going open hand on
the ground open hand strike standing
what's what's their open palm to the
face closed fist anywhere else
kicks anywhere uh and all submissions
are in
yeah
and then day three is mma for the
championship
just just mma just mma
gloves or no gloves gloves
that's a good question
yeah so you know again peak war
peak like
war your spirit wore your ethos of the
military everybody could compete in this
you know we had seals that were in it we
had marine guys that were in in it we
had plenty of green berets ranger
regiment guys like this was the
tournament of all tournaments within the
military and this is your second one
when was the first one the first one
when i was in the queue course
i just rolled out and one [ __ ]
so dumb the chance of getting hurt in
one of these fights and getting you know
out of the q course uh but one of the
the the swick
cadre we're like hey man if you win this
i'll give you a an army achievement
medal or something and i'll give you a
three-day weekend i was like i'm in so
like oh i go fight this i get a medal
first of all i get a medal the medals
are cool i don't have any of those and
then i then i get a three day weekend so
i did that well worth it yeah no count
so this is your second one uh that you
win you win this again you became the
first i think the first person first
person to do it twice back to back
then you go to ranger school the same
day
what's the weight classes in the in the
combatives same as mma so i fought at a
light heavyweight so i fought 205 um
light heavyweight on sunday was
the light heavyweight championship mma
mma bout about 3 p.m in the afternoon
and i checked into ranger school at 6
p.m
credit
dumb
that's freaking awesome man uh
you you go through ranger school um
in the book there's a lot of cool cool
details about it in the book um
give me some highlights rap week i mean
you must it's weird that you're just
like a combat experience guy won the
combative tournament special forces
sephardic sift team and you're rolling
into of school yeah rank doesn't matter
in ranger school that's pretty awesome i
love it you're going stripped you know
so staff sergeant combat patch special
forces airborne none of that's on there
right i got my name tape that's what i
got
and um
i know that's one of the things that i
love
about the military
is
it is exclusively
off merit
nothing
i don't care your color i don't care
your religion i don't care anything
about you i care if you can do it here
is a very clear task condition and
standard you're either capable of doing
it or you're not you're either going to
be a graduate of sniper school because
you made this shot or you didn't
that's it period and and ranger school
is very defined in that way
the the grading for your patrols are
very clear the grading for the the
physical portions are very clear the
time requirements for you to make it
through
the obstacle course are very clear
everything is just so clear here's your
time to disassemble and reassemble the
240. that's it that's it
but you can do it or you can't you've
either prepared and trained and you know
how it works or you don't
and
that's
in in between every one of these gates
is
their opportunity and the goal is the
cadre is to show they use all of these
gates as mechanisms to train somebody
about how to lead
they use
like they have to tear down the person
to see
who that leader potentially could be
like anybody can be a good person when
you're well fed when you've had a great
night's sleep you know like when you've
been hanging out with your wife sure i
can go in there you know in a nice suit
and be like hey you guys are doing
really great great teamwork guys but
what does it feel like when you have to
volunteer
to be up on another security shift
because the dude just fell asleep and
you're either going to be a good
teammate or you're not
like do you have that yeah and by the
way all the people that you're leading
are also sleep deprived exhausted tired
frustrated pissed off and all that yeah
when i joined the navy
the marine corps
at that time
they didn't even have name tapes on
their uniforms
it was just like you were a marine you
were a freaking lance corporal or a
corporal or a sergeant or that's what
you were yeah it was freaking legit back
in the day
i remember thinking i had so much
respect for that i was like oh hell yeah
the marine corps doesn't just you're
just a marine you're a marine what else
you don't need a name
hey marine get over here god devil dogs
um
uh one thing that you pointed out to the
book that never it never
i never understood it
until you explained it in the book
and that is when you're in ranger school
they call you ranger yeah and i was i
always thought that was backwards you
know like
that hey you're not a ranger yet you're
in school so why would they be calling
you ranger and the way you explained it
the fact that you were watching a guy
quit he's quitting pretty deep into
ranger school he was maybe like 30 40
days into it we're in mountain phase
so you know we're yeah two phases in
halfway through it and this guy decides
to quit
and you were because he was cold i mean
you know that yeah
cold gold gets you total get you cold
gets you
yeah you just quit
um
but you were listening to the
instructors kind of take him aside and
they start calling him by his name and
by his rank and they're not calling him
ranger anymore
and i was like oh
damn yeah i never heard it before you
know when when you quit you just
disappear and like rap week you're just
gone
but there you're on this ambush line you
know and it's been
ranger this ranger that sometimes stud
but usually like hey ranger get over
here
and um when they're like hey
sergeant smith come here and i was like
i would have been like dude get me i'm
sorry i'm i'm going back in that patrol
right now i don't care yeah
what makes people quit in ranger school
self-selection is is the biggest
attritor people literally just quitting
and um
it is
the environment's not rough you know at
georgia benning it it is it is a great
conducive environment for you learn how
to do basic patrolling mountain phase um
i think it's the accumulation of
you you you start internalizing all of
these things that you're gonna have to
do and it seems this like this this
daunting task like i can't i have to get
this these these patrols have to get
through these patrols i have to make it
through these events i have to do this
timed thing i have to do this rook
and here's like
looking at it from start to finish the
deeper into it you go
the fewer and fewer quitters you get
and it's not because it's any less hard
because it is it gets harder as it goes
it's because
the
there's less tasks in front of you
so people are staring at the giant
weight of
all these tasks and they can't take it
they get tired they get cold and they
look at this long list of things that
they have to be able to do and they're
like i just
can't do it
yeah the uh when you were talking about
sopsy
at a certain point there's just like
nothing you can do to make these kids
quit nothing
like they get kids done with hell week
and you're like
that you could tell them to do anything
they don't care anymore about anything
they're just like
we you can just injure them with
baseball bats or something but other
than that they're going to keep moving
forward a little i have a bengal tiger
and a cage over there if you want to
graduate you're going to go fight it yep
cool
i'm in
how much weight did you lose
so zero
in ranger school you lost zero weight i
lost no weight in range the average
weight loss is what 25 pounds yeah
10 of your body weight is what you
typically lose and you you set up
basically a system of kicking ass and
taking mres
[Music]
we should make a shirt of that
so
staff sergeant combat sf graduate if the
west point kid you know hey pl he walks
up to me is it tim i need to go on this
can you do this
like yes i can i want your main meal on
your crackers
i'll carry the 240. i'll go ahead and
i'll be like you know you're you kind of
like ops support sergeant and i'll i'll
walk the line i don't need sleep i can
do extra work i like i can go for
forever
you gotta you gotta feed the beast
and uh so like if you wanted to go it
would it was fair you know as i appeared
number one on everything like and and
peering is another bigger trigger right
so in every single phase you grade 1
through 12 or 1 through 13. 13 gets cut
and um so the top 12 guys kind of stay
but that that baggage carries over with
you so um you know i was peering top of
the list because i was doing all the
work but guys knew that there was a
price to pay and that was
the peanut butter
or that main meal
and they must have been
really needing your help because they're
starving you get one on one mri a day
right yeah you get a no-go on a patrol
you gotta get a go you know if you get
and then you the cadres comes up to hey
you're gonna be the you know you're
gonna be the pl on this next patrol
if you don't get it going there you get
a second no-go like you're at a ranger
school no go ranger yeah
so uh you know they hey man i just got
my patrol i got a no-go on my last
patrol what do i need to do
gotcha yeah you know first give me that
ham boy
first you
you pay the piper that's incred how much
how do you think you'd get like three
main meals a day at least
yeah
really yeah i mean so they're you know
two or three patrols a day and i was
probably
stepping up
to
two or one or two patrols a day so i'd
get an extra one or two every day
again i just kind of i didn't want to
put that in the book because
i don't know man i you probably
helped a lot of people i mean yeah
that's hard and people wouldn't be
giving up their food unless they really
needed it yeah they got their goes yeah
i batted a thousand
i did
you know if if you give me your main
meal you're gonna go no
dude we'll work for food candy come if i
walked up if like some dude was
let's say we just had a
react contract or we had to go set up an
ambush and i went to patrol line and
there was they were not that they're
scared of me but if they saw me coming i
mean they're they're on their gun
because they know it's coming like the
dude is going to get a go or tim is
going to have his or tim's going to take
a a pound of flesh
dude you must be the first uh first dude
to not lose weight in ranger school
that's amazing
so when i graduated i fought a fight for
the ifl a couple of days later
and um and i fought as a light
heavyweight and i had to cut weight to
make light heavyweight so i know i
fought light heavyweight when i went
into ranger school on sunday and then i
graduated and i fought the following
weekend at light heavyweight
so there you go i did i did put on the
ranger pounds right after graduation was
just like sucking everything
and you ended up being the honor grad
yep
and
you say you go back and you want to
throw it in mcphee's face like you see
yeah i'm staying
look i did it and he's not even there
not there he already moved on bro
so he psychologically warfared you yes
he did you couldn't just go to ranger
school you had to graduate honor grad
which was extra all kinds of extra work
because the difference between like
passing and being number one then the
difference amount of work is huge yeah
when i get back to the team and it's
like
at crickets there's nobody there
god and then four days later four days
after ranger school you get in this
fight you get this fight for for the ifl
the international fight league
yeah
normally and
normally you take months to recruit
recover from ranger school you know guys
aren't walking right you don't have to
take a pt test for sometimes six months
to a year
and uh your body is your digestive
system's trashed and
your energy what was your digestive
system like after
that many days of just mres
this is
um
the day i graduated um
i wanted to attack my wife
i wanted to kill an elk and i want to
find it and i wanted to fight a
velociraptor like that that's the energy
i had when i got done i was like i want
to be back you know the team sergeant ed
weems was like you know take a week off
come back to the team next monday and i
was like
no you know what what are we doing this
week he's like take a week off
and come back on monday then my phone
rings and they get a fight he's like
take that ed i'm gonna go fight an ifl
fight
uh
you win you win your fight in the ifl um
and again you got cool details and
anybody that's any kind of remote fan of
mma at all or actually sports in general
the the freaking book has some kick-ass
details on
what's going on behind the scenes
there's so much that's happening besides
what you see on the 15 minutes on tv
uh which is awesome
you end up going to sodek the special
operations target interdiction school
the sniper school uh this was wild
you're going through that
you're you're doing your last
pass fail evolution it's a field shot
that you have to take
your partner freaking quits yeah you're
shooting partner quit so sniper is a
two-man thing it seems like it's a
one-man thing but it's actually a
two-man thing you need someone to call
the win and call the shot for you and
your partner the last day of this
freaking course decides to quit
um god bless his soul
he he um
he was carrying some baggage you know he
had a lot of
traumatic stress things he was working
through
um he ultimately died
in a training event oh horrible and um
he burned in on halo jump and you know
there's
check it's hard um
stands up just quits he quits so so now
you're now the the cadre
says all right you know kennedy's
partner quit um
who who wants to who wants to call for
him and the caveat is that kennedy's
getting one shot
the instructor's gonna choose the shot
from the field he's gonna pick whatever
one
and
whether kennedy passes or fails is on
you as you know calling for him so
you're sitting there like looking up
everyone else is done everyone's done
they're done they don't have to do any
more [ __ ] and you're looking up there
you're like seeing who's gonna who's
gonna hook it up for you and uh i gotta
go to the book on this one because it's
pretty funny
you see i scan the bleachers
i know my chances are not good who would
wanna do that but i don't wait long a
burly asian on the far left side stands
up immediately
picture the batman costume but asian and
that's basically mike glover
this dude isn't worried at all he walks
over like he's about to choose a salad
dressing at a salad bar not making a
decision not making the decision that
will affect whether i pass or fail
what if i put your graduation on the
line glover the sergeant asks i'm making
the same decision sergeant glover
responds i like this guy well i guess
it's lucky we aren't doing that to you
glover
uh the country take one round out and
place it in a little ditch
proffering it to us like they're serving
the dessert at a fine dining
establishment if you get a first round
hit on our target kennedy you graduate
if you don't you fail sniper school
they choose the 700 788 meter target
it's the furthest one from our position
mike looks at it very quickly and gives
me the adjustment
his confidence and speed scare me a
little i'm not used to it after spending
the whole course with my partner are you
sure i asked calmly mike repeats exactly
when call he just said i make his
adjustments and squeeze the trigger
i see the impact and then a second later
hear the ping
dead on balls [ __ ] accurate
mike claps me on the back and says good
job that was it
freaking glover dude
coming in hot um
that's awesome
so
mike
is a is a rare soul yeah he's awesome he
is he's he's a fierce passionate human
um he's also uncompromising you he did i
don't think there there's something with
him where he doesn't know how to back
down to any fight
you know whether he's like being
censored on social media he just doubles
down you know if if um
you know in some of these schools there
were times where
there they would question that you know
he's he's he's another stiff guy coming
back from a combat deployment and you
know maybe they're
questioning an approach that he would do
and he's like no no this is right you're
wrong it never you're just not back down
and
and i understand it there when the when
they
there there is a moment where they say
hey what if we put your graduation on
the line he waits he's like that won't
change my answer not a minute he just
stands here
and then they're like
okay we're not going to do that but he
stood by those words where
a random dude that he's never shot with
on a random target with one bullet a go
no go and he was like yeah i got this
[Laughter]
hell yeah yeah freaking legit one of the
few dudes on the planet that my phone
rings i'm gonna go
help him with whatever 100 man yeah what
a beast
um
you graduate sniper school obviously you
got another ifl fight and you win
you do another
all-army combatives championship and you
win that for a third time yeah
um
you get a sponsorship
from ranger up yeah
with nick yeah who wrote this book with
you that's right
nick is a former army army infantry
officer west point guy yep um
and he had started this company ranger
up and
i think you described as like the first
of the military
apparel company thing yeah yeah is
from grunt style to nine line you know
they're they're they're a plethora of
them you know i think the two at the
time ranger up in 762 where the like the
two
military apparel t-shirt companies that
you'd see it the a fees or you'd see
soldiers walking around bending or brag
you know sporting their like tough guy
shirts
but uh they were the first
uh
you lose a decision to jason mayhem
miller um yeah that sucked
i didn't lose that fight
you lost the decision i lost mayhem
miller yeah
how come you lost
um
man i don't the uh if i went back
one i didn't finish
the uh there are multiple times where i
was in good position there's there's a
famous photo i'm on his back i have a
rear naked choke
and uh and i'm like looking up at the
refs
and and at the judges being like
yeah showboating
up against the cage i have his back
hooks are in rare naked choke is
underneath there and i'm doing like the
nick diaz moment remember when nick dies
got that triangle in and he like sits
down
flips off everybody imagine if that guy
got out
you know like that was what happened a
couple of times okay not just once but
twice where i had i had already fought
jason before yeah i fought him in the
ambulance and i destroyed him i mean i
just like
massacred him
threw him every which way the rules were
kind of pride so i could soccer kick on
the ground i could knee on the ground so
in the grapple transition which is like
where i really like to be i was just
inflicting non-stop damage for the whole
entire duration of the fight
similar to the
time i fought scott smith and i fought
scott smith again
um and i lost to scott smith i fought
jason i smashed him and then i fought
him again and i do the same fight
he doesn't
you know he he shows up different it's
like again i'm too stupid
to change to adapt
so
you kind of like go on a vengeance
fight
after jason miller right yeah
and
when you describe this in the book man
you really it sounds like you're a
little bit sketched out about it yeah
you so just to set up you you have
another mma fight you're about to deploy
again you're about to go to afghanistan
and you have a bad taste in your mouth
from losing to jason miller
and so you get another fight and
you like annihilate this guy yeah yeah
there was um
there was no i didn't i didn't go in
there to win i went in there like hurt
and i i very
you know this like high level athletes
they're not going in there john jones
isn't going in there to like murder
somebody he's going there to be a
champion
and i was going in there to hurt whoever
i was fighting now that was
um not typical of any time that i've
ever fought i wanted to be the best
fighter that i could be and i liked
fighting i didn't like fighting because
i was going to hurt people that's like
psychopath stuff
um losing that fight getting ready to go
to war
into afghanistan and this is now 2008
afghanistan which is like 2006
iraq like this is peak war and i'm like
in the zone i wanted i wanted violence
you know i was um and i wanted to hurt
somebody
so how did you beat him was it like a
mountain oh still around a pound yeah i
i pick him up and i put him on his ear
you know i take the earth and i hit him
in the face with the earth hard and he's
already on he's already on
whack-a-doodle street when he hits the
mat and i go straight to a dominant
position and i start dropping hammers
and um
you know he's he's out in three and i
probably hit him nine times
and um
you know when you're in that dominant
position your fist hits their face
their brain hits their head their head
hits the mount mat
the brain then hits the head again so
like you're like his brain is getting
concussed eighteen twelve
times yeah
and i was hitting hard
so and he didn't get up for a while did
he they they he they so he stayed
unconscious in the ring they brought in
the stretcher they moved him onto the
stretcher they carried him out of the
ring he's still unconscious like we're
probably seven minutes into this
he's been unconscious for
you know six seven minutes
check yeah
but he's all right eventually he's fine
sure yeah
uh
now it's time for you to go on
deployment again
you deploy
as an
as an augment
to help other groups
as a sniper pair do i have that right
that's right did i read that right
so we volunteered
the
yusok this is pre first special forces
command
they had seven groups going over
and they come and they ask for
they come to the halo sniper team which
is the team that is on and they said hey
does anybody want to volunteer for this
company's deployment because we are
looking for
this specific thing and that was to be a
sniper asset that's kind of like
as part of the siege of sodif asset so
if a team is going to go do a specific
mission they'll have this these guys
you know kind of on the deck they can
just yeah we got him here you go that
was the plan
then as soon as you get there your
sniper partner your shooting partner his
gets like a dear john type letter
situation and the worst kind of deer
john letter
bank accounts empty divorce paper served
motorcycles sold
he had friends calling and be like hey
bro i just bought your guns
you know
she went like scorched earth she salted
the fields this was total nuclear
nuclear on him
so he has to so he goes home yeah and
this means
tim kennedy's on a solo operation
it's by myself in
afghanistan uh
and this is where the section that i
opened the podcast from um
the chapter's called the valley of death
and as i was reading this
i was getting
uncomfortable and sketched out just
reading it i'm like i i don't like any
i didn't like anything about this right
so you're you're you're going on a
resupply mission you know raise up my
mission oh we're gonna go do resupply
okay let's think about what this means
here you gotta go 150 plus miles um
from your location in kandahar out to
fob anaconda
the way that you're going to be going
out there and this is what you're
writing about it's a channelized road
system there's like
there's not a good way to go no
it's just not conducive to
a comfortable passage safe passage
okay so i'm now i'm reading this and i'm
like okay well that kind of sucks you
know but you know sometimes you gotta
suck it up and then i keep reading you
got 80
jingle trucks 80 freaking
supply trucks but they're not american
supply trucks they're not driven by
american
army drivers
they're afghan jingle trucks which is
like these
i don't know they look like freaking
gypsy vehicles absolutely
uh bad maintenance on them no armor
obviously driven by afghan drivers who
have you know
questionable loyalty at best they have
questionable loyalty
and then you've got i mean obviously
they've got no columns there's nothing
this is just this is just i don't like
any of this
and then you got your security force
which is made up of
an american sfa team right augmented by
one tim kennedy yeah
uh
you guys got rgs
so you got the mine resistant rg's how
many rg's did you have three okay so
three rg's you got a czech special
forces company they've got slick humvees
and no they're the land cruisers oh okay
oh no
are they they're not armored though no
okay
so it was a resupply and an emplacement
of the check company okay so it was a
required
um we had to move these guys into this
firebase and so they had to go they had
to make this drive
they were
this company of czech guys were going to
be at firebase anaconda for the next
year and we had to resupply
their substance for the next year in
addition to the oda that was already
going to be co-located on the on
firebase anaconda with them got it
and in addition to all them you also
have uh afghan soldiers with you mm-hmm
and they've got humvees the a a
commandos okay
how many of them did you have do we have
just rough numbers eight trucks okay
so you guys go on this uh clearly
you are well not clearly but most likely
compromised as soon as you leave because
all you got all those afghan drivers and
you guys did everything you took their
phones and all the stuff that you're
supposed to do but
fighting starts almost as quickly as
almost as quickly as you start i mean
the fighting starts um
and the sabotage
that those things were happening as soon
as we rolled out of the gate in addition
to you know getting in contact
within hours of leaving kandahar um
each of the vehicles of the 80 vehicles
you know we had three drivers in each
vehicle so we had 240 afghans that were
inside of these
yeah i love it you're just immediately
this is so terrible i don't like any of
this no
uh but this is this this is the soft
model like this is the sf buy with and
through you know we're we're doing the
special forces approach is we do
everything through our partners you know
the advise assisted company we're doing
this is a triple a mission you know
we're advising the checks we're advising
the afghans we're assisting them and
we're accompanying them so this is this
is this is a sf mission to the core as
dumb as it is
um
you got a czech soldier that gets
wounded pretty quick out of the gate he
gets medevac out of there uh eventually
you you hit this pressure plate id
that's where i open the book open the
podcast up with there's a the freaking
vehicle in front of you lands on your
vehicle yeah that's a hell of a an ied
uh you got small arms you got rpgs
coming in on you and um
i gotta read a little chunk from the
book here get into some details
dust is still [ __ ] everywhere but a
lane of light clears from us to where
the front vehicle had fallen off of our
60 meters away when we were backed up it
is eerie kind of like when you're
sitting on your couch on a lazy day
looking out the window and you catch a
beam of light and watch the dust
particles whirl around inside it the
beams are on either side of us full of
dust but the lane to the vehicle is
clear
it is almost as if god cleared a path
for us but that path didn't make my life
any easier those dudes are still alive
they're still [ __ ] alive iris shouts
out he's right i see it too one guy is
moving i'm gonna sprint to them man
irish yells to me that's a bad [ __ ]
idea man and if you do it we're all
gonna die
i tell them
there's no lack of seriousness in my
voice i do not think we have any chance
of surviving that run right in the heart
of this ambush irish looks it right at
me and says i'm going
he takes off in a dead sprint i hear the
guns pick up they see him i'm still
holding my sniper rifle for some reason
i don't grab my ar as i take a deep
breath
and sprint after irish
i do not want to be doing this i do not
want to expose myself but i don't want
to fail my comrades even more
we get to the vehicle unscathed and i
look inside [ __ ] they are in bad shape
the first guy has lost both of his legs
at the quads they simply aren't there i
pull him out in a sandbag carry and his
bile and blood and guts spill out onto
my uniform rolling down my stomach and
soaking my legs even with the adrenaline
and the fear and the explosions and the
bullet bullets i acknowledge that this
is the most disgusting thing that has
ever happened to me
iris grabs the other dude who is in
rough shape but still breathing as we
start moving the 60 meters back to our
vehicle i see a squad of six to eight
young
six to eight guys moving out of the
woods to finish us
they are the assault element getting
ready to fight to the x and kill those
of us standing on it
i have a choice i can drop this guy and
leave him for dead so i can fight
two-handed or i can fire my cannon of a
sniper rifle one-handed rambo style in
their general direction while trying to
move my wounded guy to a high carry with
one arm on the other side
whether it is courage or because i knew
irish would have just picked him up and
carried two guys i opt for the
one-handed fire i know i am not hitting
anything i know i'm not even close they
see us a squad against two guys who are
carrying wounded afghans and have no
real ability to return fire we are
dead then
thank god
keller sees them
the sweet melody of the 50 cow fills my
ears and they evaporate
when i say that i need you to understand
what i mean they didn't die it wasn't
like there were corpses sitting there
they [ __ ] evaporated
there was just a pink mist floating in
the air where they had been
it is like that
jake gallon hall scene in jarhead where
he says he wanted the pink mist do you
see after pulling the trigger on a
sniper rifle i had never wanted it
before but right now i have never been
happier to see anything in my entire
life
keller just saved me for what proved to
be the first time of many over the next
few days
yeah
i have recreated
that and i don't understand
how keller was able to shoot them it
doesn't make sense we're in between him
he's
in an elevated position in on the top of
a humvee
shooting down through us and around us
and the the taliban are below us
so he's he's like threading the needle
in between us with a 50 cow
you know and
that's a big bullet
and it's a big bullet that carries a ton
of energy and he is 60 meters away
so we're talk peak energy
perfect trajectory one it doesn't make
sense how he did it two
um it wasn't pink mist it was just they
were there and then they weren't
you know there was a line of dudes
it's the dumbest thing that we ran down
to the x the kill zone of the ambush to
grab those bodies because that's the
last place that you want to go the first
thing you do is get off the x
but irish goes down there and when we're
dragging these bodies you know i have an
sr-25 sniper rifle with a suppressor on
the end of it with a loopholed magnified
optic on top of it and i have a dude
like this trying to shoot and then
i also felt those rounds traveling past
past us and it was
it's like us getting hit with that round
going past our heads as those bodies
just disappeared
um keller
yeah god bless keller
freaking johnny on the spot with the mod
deuce and god bless them all dudes
right
all right uh
this
a and if you're listening this and
you're like wait a second who's keller
and and and who's irish yeah you got to
get the book
you got to get the book and you'll get
the the backstories on these guys these
are current dudes as well so um
yeah i'm just saying from the point of
like if you're listening to me read this
and you're like wait a second who's cow
it's you you need to read the story and
you know you might not find out their
their real name and date of birth and
their social security number but you'll
the story will make a little bit more it
will make total sense because i only
read a little chunk of it
um but just to give an example of
number one what the book's like but also
some of the intensity of the combat that
you were that you're talking about and
that you learned from
uh
this goes on man this goes on what was
the total what was the total time it
took you to get to
um anaconda
from the time that we called a tick no
from the time that you left how many
days what a week
and you guys are fighting kind of the
whole time yeah we we go we call a tick
out of a tick and a tick out of a tick
we we call broken arrow
at this ambush so from the time that
broken arrow is is kind of this
if you don't send us every available
asset we're all going to die type
emergency call
from that moment we have three and a
half days
um i think we had already been in
movement for three days so i guess six
days total
yeah so just so everyone understands
that the broken arrow is a call that
means you're going to get support
namely air support from
all over the place to come and help you
out yeah everybody that's available will
come and give give that support
um
you eventually link up with the oda team
that's from anaconda they come out to
meet you guys they're fighting through
the village to us and we're fighting
through the ravine to them
and that happens about two
two two and a half two days into this
gunfight
eventually i'm going to fast forward a
little bit you get to
this one of the villages that you
were taking fire from you guys decide
you got to go in there you got to clear
this village of enemy fighters
this is now
like urban combat you're going street to
street you're going house to house
um at one point there's a
pkm a machine gun is just unloading
rounds at your team as you're trying to
push through this compound
let me go to the book here
i can see the barrel of the pkm sticking
out of a small window in the courtyard
25 meters away
the rg that's your big uh mine resistant
vehicle the rg is still smashing into
the wooden gate
but the door will not give and the
rounds are pouring out of the pkm into
the vehicle
it's only a matter of time before we
start getting killed i need to take out
that gun
i reach for one of my frag grenades
pull the pin and take aim at the tiny
window 20 to 25 meters away
if this wasn't combat my friends would
be laughing at me at this moment you see
i suck at throwing i mean i really suck
yes i'm a professional athlete yes i can
do all measures of physical activity at
a level most people can't fathom
but you know what i never did growing up
ball sports
it was so bad that when i joined the
special forces and had to throw
something to one of my teammates i
believe it was a roll of hundred mile an
hour tape
they were so horrified that they began
instituting football throwing practice
as part of my training regimen
i might be the only sf guy ever that as
a new guy in addition to the normal
tasks of shooting planning and physical
fitness
had to work on my spiral
but here i am grenade in hand with my
team counting on me
and i launch it
and it is perfect
it isn't a lob that lazily floats into
the window it doesn't bounce in it's a
[ __ ] aaron rodgers laser that flies
from my hand and connects directly to
that window it is the best throw i ever
made
in a weird [ __ ] up way it is one of
the happiest moments of my life
a grenade going off in the movies is
very different from what happens in real
life
it's not a giant fireball it's not
dramatic it's a hollow thud
it's that late night sound of opening
the refrigerator to see what's in there
and the watermelon rolls out and hits
the ground that's all a grenade is after
you throw it a little hollow pop
and after you hear that pop you either
want to hear nothing or you want to hear
men screaming
you do not want to hear women or
children scream
you absolutely do not want to hear that
yet that's what i hear
my soul churns inside the helplessness
tears me apart i want to take that
[ __ ] grenade back so badly i can hear
kids screaming they don't understand why
this is happening to them i can hear
mothers screaming mothers that are
punctured by fragments of a metal and
can barely hold their lungs
their screams are the sounds only a
parent can understand of desperately
wanting to help your children
but not knowing what to do to help them
or in some cases
knowing it is too late to help them
every scream tears me apart
after everything i've been through i
thought my soul was dead
i was as hollow as the thud of that
grenade i thought there was nothing left
it all comes flooding back
i am a raw nerve of emotion
and each sound coming from that room
burns me worse than anything that has
ever happened to me shame horror and
guilt that what i have just done
envelops me
i have seen this before in others as an
emt the drunk driver that has killed
someone
they sat there on those street corners
crying trying to sort out in their heads
the disparity between who they thought
they were
a decent person
and what they had just done
but i cannot stop and cry
i have to
move keller and i flow into the
courtyard with the pkm out of commission
the rg gets more aggressive and i see
the wall start tumbling down
everything is moving fast and keller and
i do not want to lose momentum i flow
right mike flows left the mission
this mission never would have happened
in iraq and goes against doctrine in any
unit in iraq we had a whole company of
sif working together to clear buildings
a normal infantry would have at least
four on the door followed by another
fire team right behind them at a minimum
with another squatter platoon in support
we have a whole compound to clear and
it's just me and keller that's it
when i hit the first doorway i instantly
see food everywhere it's a kitchen
i can smell the tea kettle with the
clove tea that everyone here drinks
it has just been made i can smell right
now as i write this it's amazing how
smell stays with you you can forget
details and images specific words and
conversations but the smell of a moment
is forever
curry clove
the screams are louder now and i move
toward them i follow a hallway to a 90
degree turn and as i hit the edge of
that corner i get the first traces of
smoke and dust from the grenade
at this point i'm in this room somewhere
between 30 to 60 seconds from the moment
it exploded and the scene is awful
it is worse than i expected
when you throw a grenade into a building
that has walls two feet thick all that
over pressure has nowhere to go
this is an america where the pressure
will break the dry wall or blow the door
off
their bodies took the brunt of it
there are two women
six kids and an old man inside
i am once again that kid standing on the
street looking at a crashed church van
so desperately wanting to help but not
knowing where to start
except this time in addition to being
the guy who so desperately wants to fix
it all
i am also the guy who crashed the van
i screamed for the ginginator to come
and help
why the [ __ ] isn't he in here
because there no there's no reason for
him to be here
but i need this fix i cannot have this
on my ledger
they have to be okay
he screams at me to come back and man
the gun because he is running the
grenade launcher and cannot abandon his
post i take one last look at the room it
is so dark the floors are dirt and dust
floats in the air
i am standing in a real life nightmare a
horror film
the smell of death emptied bowels and
vomit hangs in the air
the hot machine gun is right there
someone was shooting it god damn who
the old man one of the women someone
else
everyone that can scream is screaming
some aren't
they aren't all going to make it
i did this
i am the bad guy
i hate war
the um
a couple of seconds before that
mike gobel
he uh as we approached that door that
started getting
disintegrated from the machine gun fire
i don't again
can't make any sense of it
as we approached the door i was on the
right side he was on the left side i
reached for the handle to push this door
into the courtyard open
and i mean athletically you know green
berets are not small people like just
bam pops me in the center and i fall
away from the door as the door starts
shredding
machine gun fire to start zipping
through it i don't know what he heard i
don't know what he smelled i don't know
what happened i don't know if it was a
sixth sense thing he shoves me
a heartbeat before the door just starts
disintegrating that's the door that i
throw the grenade through
as he like peels off to try and find
mike comes up and we end up clearing
through that building you know the um
when that grenade goes off
you know it's just
that's it
and um
it's over pressure that per that shoots
tiny little projectiles of shrapnel in
every direction indiscriminately
traveling in whatever direction and
trajectory that they have
that iranian
that was in that machine gun position
had body bunkered himself with women and
children
and for them you know it's a win-win for
them
we we hurt civilians
it's a win for them
you know or they're protected by these
civilians
and it's a win for them
a different type of evil
as uh
i've been
attacked about this as if there was like
any bravado or braggadoci
pride in what happened in this like
there's not you know there's it's
absolute
uh pain
but this is war
and
as we have people that volunteer to go
and do things
travel overseas or you know go to
ukraine and you know fight fight for
with them you know like you've seen war
i've seen war and um i'm always just
like
even in america where people are talking
about real revolution and i was like bro
like you don't know
like this is war you know this is um
it's the worst thing that we can do to
each other we do it
the uh
a friend of mine
um
did this show
on the history channel
um
it's now they changed the name of it but
it's called the war fighters
and
i got interviewed for this show is about
is to highlight mark lee who was in my
task unit who was killed in iraq
but
it's you know they they interviewed us
it's a he did a great job the the guy
that put it together um and it's awesome
it's an awesome program but there's this
one part that they edited out
it's me talking and and they're asking
me about
they're asking me about war i don't even
know what they're asking me but i do
know what i said i start talking about
if you're gonna go to war you have to
have the will and there's two wills that
you have to have the will to kill and
the will to die and when i talk about
the will to kill
what what i said was you have to have
the will to kill not just the enemy
because when you go to war civilians are
gonna die and if you think you're gonna
somehow avoid that that you're so good
or that things are gonna go your way and
it's not gonna happen you're wrong
so if you're gonna go to war
you yeah you gotta have the will to kill
the enemy that might not be that hard to
fathom or to figure out but you have to
realize that civilians are 100
gonna die if you go to war
and then obviously the other part of the
will is the will to die because once
again if you think you're going to go to
war and you're not going to lose any of
your friends
well you're wrong
and you think you're not going to lose
any brave american souls you're wrong
so this is an example that this is
another thing um
one you know i learned so much from the
troops that i work with and and the
conventional forces that i work with the
first the 506 they had a an expression
that they said good shot bad result
which means
hey this soldier was doing everything
that they were supposed to do they took
a shot that was completely authorized
that made sense that followed the roes
and it so happens that there was
collateral damage there was a civilian
killed the it wasn't what it looked like
and it was a good shot and
they they did the right thing but the
result is bad and that's you know when i
was reading that i was like man
good shot bad result like you have to do
you have to take that risk otherwise
everything goes goes to [ __ ]
um
doesn't make it any easier though
when you
when when when people when [ __ ] like
that happens
what at what point do you think you
started processing that at a deeper
level like thinking yourself
trying to understand it
ah man
and when we finally made it you know
when uh the jinjinator and i switched
positions now i'm pretty much seen red
for
a week
you know i'm just like in fight mode
and uh i get
inside of the
rg and i'm on the grenade and i see
squirters coming out of these buildings
and i'm just like laying waste to these
people
uh when we make a firebase anaconda and
um i'm avoiding going to the medic shed
i'm
by all me i'm not i'm not getting near
it i'm not even looking over to that
side of the base i'm playing sniper
hopping up on top of roofs smacking
dudes that are trying to embed ieds
around the base
um
i'm just like doing every activity that
i can do to keep myself occupied from
dealing with what is in the med shed
with which is all these women and
children that they're trying to save
when i finally go down there
and um
and i get to hold one of the children
that was wounded you know that that's
when i started
finding
purpose again you know that uh
killing's not gonna heal it
it might help a little bit sweat is not
gonna heal it it's gonna help a little
bit sleep is not gonna heal it it's
gonna help a little bit you know but
going and doing good
and going and figuring out what is the
next thing to do
like
that's really gonna heal it you know
that's gonna help
so
this ended up being a really
significant kind of change in my
approach to how do i deal with
post-traumatic stress how do i you know
mental health how do i
you know it's not any of these little
things it's all of them
exercise food fitness
relationships and also
facing those demons you know like i lit
i went into that and i picked up this
damaged wounded child that i i damaged
and sat there and face to face held
held this child
and um
you know
smelled it
felt it
it's little tiny heartbeat
you know twice that of ours
um
so i don't know
how i faced it i don't know how
like i'm sure it's not fully healed
you know the uh you reading it still is
just like a gut punch when i read it on
the audiobook
and i had to stop 10 15 times
just to get through it you know i'd get
up i'd walk i'd come back
and uh that poor audio guy having to
deal with you know this man-child crying
in between every sentence
yeah do it better
you
you get an um
pretty much you get to anaconda you you
sleep you shower you reload your
sergeant major contacts you and
he just wants you to get on a blackhawk
and fly back to kandahar
and
the choice is yours
what you want to do and
i mean
by all
by all
meaningful
consideration the trip back is going to
be the same as the trip out
maybe even harder because now the enemy
knows you're gonna be coming back
um
so you have
a convenient little out for yourself
yeah a convenient little opportunity to
uh
to to not have to ride this convoy back
and that's a decision point for you
and i i go to the book for this part um
you say
i have to see this mission through
i thought about it all night while
holding that little girl
there is a recurring pattern that is
forming in my life and i don't like it i
don't necessarily run from my problems
but i'm definitely not addressing them
either
i've always found a path around the
thing that scares me hurt me or upsets
me
it is the same unhealthy coping
mechanism that i've used ever since
jared died
fireman problems cool no big deal i'll
become a cop screwed up my chances of
becoming a cop because i paintballed a
kid cool i'll go in the army
and now my boss has teed up a perfect
scenario for me to do that again
i can leave right now safely and go on
another mission with the brits or the
french or get some cool combat patches
from their militaries and pad my resume
no one would judge me
my boss is literally telling me
he would like me to head back
i do not want to go back into that
valley i am scared as hell
but i can't shake that night in iraq
when john mcphee made me fight the
entire team after i mouthed off
i said all the right things back then i
said i understood that the team can
accomplish anything but the individual
is weak
but i also thought that i'd beaten up
eight of them and even though they all
beat me up no single one of them could
have taken me i let myself cope with the
humiliation by protecting my ego
i ignored the reality that no one man
least of all me is that big of a deal
i'd heard the sayings before
and thought i understood them
you don't leave a man behind you fight
for the man next to you
but i didn't understand them
until this moment
there's always an easy way out
there is
in marriage
you know
you're traveling on work
and uh you go down to the lobby you
shouldn't have gone to the lobby you
know you should gone to the gym
you know you walk through the lob you go
to the bar you should have gone to the
bar you should have walked through the
lobby got in your car and gone to a jiu
jitsu gym if you didn't you get there
there's a girl sitting down at the end
she's a flight attendant you know
you could have not talked to her but you
did there's always there's always an
easy option
and um
that hard right is is is you know so
hard
it's called the hard right
and you know that that path that that
the high road is a lonely
road that feels so
destitute from from anything else
that is the only road to be on you know
and and this is one of those moments
that it was so crystal clear it was so
black and white and that doesn't happen
very often in war where the where you're
served on this platter these options of
right and wrong
and i had every excuse you know like i
can fake this injury um man i i would
have got selected but you know i rolled
my ankle
no you didn't you quit
you know like
man i i
i had my wife not been mean to me had
she not talked smack before i went on
this trip you know i went to no and you
know this is on you man so every single
time that easy option you know you said
the convenient choice
it's always right there
and um
you know for 20 something years it was
so simple just to make
the the easy wrong
you wrap up this chapter you say that
mission of anaconda defined me and in
many ways still does it was the honor of
my life to serve with these men every
member of the oda that fought through
the valley received at least a bronze
star every member of the check was
awarded the checks was awarded the
silver star with one guy receiving the
check medal of honor
an extraordinary number of men were
awarded the purple heart when i landed
in afghanistan
i wanted these things on my uniform
i wanted the bling that told people i
was a badass
now i felt like i didn't even deserve
any of it
and i didn't want it if it was offered i
didn't even report my wartime injuries
to my actual chain of command
everything i had done thus far ranger
school sniper school deployments
fighting were no longer accomplishments
meant to stand alone
they were tools to make me better
and the only thing i proved on this
deployment was that i wasn't good enough
and i never wanted to not be good enough
again
i decide as i board the plane to fly
back to
fly back home to fayetteville just as
the ufc fight for the troops event is
starting at fort bragg that i am going
to spend the rest of my career stacking
the deck in my favor so the men around
me will never have a liability in their
midst
i will never live up to being the man i
once thought i was and i will certainly
never be perfect
but i can be better
lessons are sinking in at this point
they're getting there but
it is uh
it's tragic and embarrassing
that this is what it takes for me to
start learning
you know um
these are hard lessons
but uh
now you know 15 years removed from some
of this
those um these are lessons that
i revisit you know i'm going back to
that well all the time to drink from it
you know the the drink the that well of
embarrassment that well shame that that
well of pain that the memory of mistake
and um that's fuel
you know it's fuel that
motivates when i'm like man i don't want
to get up
i don't want to go to this dumb
resistance court you want me to take a
40-hour resistance course
okay
no
i'll do that
you
know um
you get back
and you're you're back in the fight game
you got a whole another career going you
know you're in the army but you also
have this other career going you get a
fight against nick thompson in
strikeforce and at this point you're
training at team rock in fayetteville
this is like a hard but basic gym yep um
and
just like i said it's like a hard but
basic gym you guys are you guys are
going hard um
nick you you beat on june 16th 2009 you
beat nick thompson he taps from strikes
[Music]
you're a positional grappler you know
about the sometimes you just put a dude
to a place he can't move oh yeah he's
stuck there yeah and when somebody's
able to sit there and rain down punches
on you and um you know you can't get
your arms free to tap
you're just you're just looking for a
way out
yeah
uh dominant grappling the the
at this point now this is like the first
little
friction we start to see with the army
at least the am i right in that like the
army is now saying because strikeforce
is
you know on tv and stuff like this
and the army does not want you doing mma
no which is a crazy thing to think about
man
what better representation for the us
military than to have
a green beret
out fighting in mixed martial arts on tv
and winning and kicking people's asses
how is that not good
i mean i concur like i agree with you
yeah but the chain of command ultimately
like they didn't
so you know the motto the green brace
the quiet professionals and when you're
when you are a main event
on show time you know like
that's not quiet
um
you didn't
it wasn't this fight or was it this
fight where they actually announced you
you know you said hey i'm tim kennedy
i'm a you know a wrestler and a mixed
martial artist from team rock and
they're like okay cool and then they
announced you as like tim kennedy
special forces ranger snipers
like i don't know who told them okay i
didn't tell them this you know but they
they had done figured it out
you were ahead of your time with that
though because now you know 15 years
down the line
the the army marine corps they sponsor
you know
timers on you know on every ufc fight i
mean every i mean i'm i pave the way for
we have professional gamers we have
professional fishermen you know we have
professional athletes we just didn't
know how to do it then yeah and we're in
the middle of war right so i do get it
you know like
how how can you go they didn't know that
they're going to have such a recruiting
problem plot problem in two years from
that moment like in two years from that
they're like in a bad position
but at the time teams are full dudes
want to go to war they're not burnt out
yet you know they're not quitting
they're not going to find other jobs
outside of sf because they're not ready
to go on their ninth deployment
um this is before all that this is peak
war and uh then they have this dude
that's moonlighting fighting
so you know while i say i don't
understand uh how short-sighted they
were i also understand
like you know if you're the commander
and you're sitting there and you have
one of your studs that's on the weekends
going off to atlantic city and fighting
in a mma bout wait is it even legal
right now i guess it is in that state
you know but john mccain is sitting
there being like oh it's not legal in
arizona you know and so it's
i do also get it
yeah i guess i can kind of get it too uh
but it sucks it sucks dude i wanted my
cake and i wanted to eat it too
uh
you know you got great advice ben rios
who's a green beret my brother yeah dude
he gave you
such solid advice and i'm gonna quote it
he says if the army loved you
they'd figure a way to make this work
and he goes this this whole comparison
between like hey if this was a girl
and she really loved you like you'd
figure out a way to work to make this
work he says so if the army loved you
they'd figure out a way to make this
work they'd make you sign a longer
contract they'd outline recruiting
things you can do or deployments you're
gonna have to take
what they what they're doing isn't love
that's envy
are you to let someone else's envy
dictate your life
that's of incredible advice and what
what makes it incredible advice to me is
ben rios is obviously like a confident
dude that was confident in his damn
manhood to be like oh my friend tim
kennedy's a badass and i support him
being a badass he's my boss
freaking awesome he's my senior 18 bravo
you know and that is uh so yeah you're
not you're not wrong man the layers of
his wisdom and he had done a lot of
living uh good living in uh being in
seventh group for that long pre-war so
he had the war on drugs you know
colombia trips all up and down south
america and central america and the
caribbean during like seventh seventh
group doing some pretty seventh group
things
so there's a lot of experience in there
so when when
when he just
truthfully and he was
he's a very stoic person
him to kind of just lay things out there
man it was every single one of those
words was just resounding in my brain
because he you know he meant it like
what a great human the envy part like
man so it just hurts like
it
for someone not to see you do being
successful
and being in part of your community and
being like hell yeah instead being like
what the hell is he doing
that to me that smells
it smells like envy it smells like
jealousy that's what it smells like
those aren't good characteristics yeah i
was telling somebody the other day i was
coming on here
and they started shooting rounds off
your bow about you
about your career and about how you like
how you are as a as a as a real leader
and i'm sitting there just like listen
to this person
you know and i'm like every word that
they say it is so apparent how pathetic
they are you know the how envious they
are of your success and how jealous they
are and anytime that our veteran is is
talking negatively negatively about a
veteran i'm always like what's going on
with you but then when they start taking
shots shots that are usually unfounded
and or fabricated or even worse com
complete just
lies out of positions of envy
that's a bad that's a dangerous position
to be coming from yeah it's it's a
bummer man it is uh it's sad you know
one of my buddies uh stoner he was
trying to go to princeton he's a seal
officer and there was like this weird
program where he could go to princeton
and he and he's so
he wasn't he worked for me now he wasn't
working for me and he says hey you know
i i want to go to this program to go to
princeton
and he goes what do you think about that
i go it's freaking awesome why he goes
like some other people are telling me
that like i shouldn't go
and it's it's gonna be a bad move for my
career and i was like
bro
who's telling you that like that's the
most insane thing i've ever heard i was
like you know what that is that's
jealousy that's someone thinking oh now
this guy's got combat experience and
he's and he's also going to be a
freaking princeton guy oh [ __ ] i can't
compete with that no you shouldn't go i
was like dude 100 go i go you'll have my
punk card when it comes to education you
can be like i went to an ivy league
school [ __ ] is that cool i'm going and
he ended up going
but uh yeah that's a bummer it seems
like there's
unfortunately some of that activity
going on here um
it's cool to get a litmus test though
you know i have i have a few friends
that every time somebody i'll like name
drop them and i know these people very
very well but they don't know how well i
know them um but they know like the
public persona of this person and when
they start just like racking off about
this person
man i know about you now like you done
[ __ ] up like i know that my my little
person is my litmus test who i know is a
great person that i know is a selfless
servant that is a good father that is
faithful and you're like your list in
all these things that i know to be to be
like i know for a fact to be lies and
you're just regurgitating the same
[ __ ] that everybody else says it's
like
gotcha bro i got your number gave away
that position yeah
that's a bummer man uh luckily for you
the texas national guard step up man
the guard has been so good in in so many
ways you know they
behind the tomb of the unknown soldier
carved like etched in stone and it says
you they uh we don't accept the soldier
and lay aside the citizen
that's so beautifully said
and uh we we always look to the soldier
to the marine
and uh and we forget that that's a
person right that that is a citizen
first and we have these these sometimes
unrealize these unrealistic expectations
about who this person who the citizen is
and what they should be doing and how
they're going to behave in war and we we
take this
these expectations and we throw it in
front of them and it's it's not real you
know like that is a person first and
foremost and it's a citizen that you
know is married and that has a family
that wants to provide for their family
and they they have aspirations and they
have goals and they're also human you
know they make mistakes and they don't
do the right thing
and you know behind the tomb the unknown
soldier etched like that and it's one of
my favorite things to to look back on
every time that i'm
looking at
whether i'm in a position of leadership
and i'm looking at a soldier about his
behavior i always look at like who that
person is first in the context of of
them as a citizen and as an individual
as a human
then i move on to
what is happening as a soldier
yeah
yeah uh
when when we got to ramadi the groups on
the troops on the ground were national
guard unit out of pennsylvania and a
bunch of other places but oh man what a
bunch of studs
some of them yeah well for us all of
them every one of them i you know like
what they did and the lessons they
taught us and
they were just awesome awesome
human beings um
and luckily the national guard is not
technically the army active army yeah so
you were able to
get in the national guard which is so
the national guard requires you to be a
citizen so you have to have a full-time
job because the national guard like you
only work a percentage of the year you
know about about a month
out of the year
two months out of the year you end up
working cumulatively for the national
guard
the rest of the time you got to put food
on the table and however you ever do
that that is your job
you know as um
some people are senators some people are
um plumbers yeah
police officers work for the department
of state you know lots of different jobs
i was a fighter
so you're training you so are you still
training that team where are you
training now did you down in texas now
so i do one fight out of texas when i
fight jacare for the world title and
this is for the strike force yep for the
title force middleweight title
and you lose yep
and you say it's so just clear dude i
barely lost that fight
i think i won that fight he's like yeah
you just lost to jason no so crazy for
me it's like this i like i i hate that
you lose bro i don't know if you can
hear that i'm like and you lose like it
bothers me so much man
uh i don't know i yeah um
and that was like a close fight right
jacare
and
what you didn't really like let it go or
something in that fight yeah i fought
like a super conservative you know i'm
beating them on the ground i'm throwing
them around but i'm not taking any risks
i'm not really um pushing the pocket uh
i was i was apprehensive to her to the
ground with him until i finally went to
the ground with him and i picked him up
and i threw him on the ground passed his
guard he like should have done the whole
entire time my game plan was i thought
he was going to try to take me down and
i'd be piecing him up on his feet
because my wrestling was going to be
better
except that he didn't want to go to the
ground
he thought my wrestling and my jujitsu
was as good as his so he wanted to stand
up and strike and it was three four
rounds into it when i was like oh he's
not trying to actually
what's going on here
maybe i should change my plan
uh and that's when you realized you
needed uh
uh to go to one of these professional
camps um
and your your decision was kind of
between
between uh
jackson
twinkle john and aka
uh
you end up going to jackson winkle john
yeah
and do talk about
so at this point you got gsp
and rashad evans they're both champs jon
jones is on on fire on the way up carlos
condit
cowboy cerrone nate marcourt holly holm
aleister overeem keith jardine i mean
this is like a freaking
killer crew dude killer crew
salty
um and the variety from the young
hungry jon jones
to the prestigious the prestigious
athletic prowess of rashad to the
international experience of alistar
overeem to holly holm who had i think at
this time
maybe a dozen boxing titles
um and then carlos conda and cowboy
cerrone and demacio page who had been
winning titles and different
organizations all over the place so when
you walk in here you just see like
walls of belts walls of belts of world
championships
so it's um
it's cool
[Laughter]
uh
you you talk about rolling with jon
jones for the first time or training
with john jones you said that was kind
of next level scenario yeah there was um
i'm turning gordon ryan these days
and he's the only person that i can kind
of kind of equate it to
where
like we've been grappling
for 30 years
and uh like we got tricks up our sleeves
and i will i won't teach a trick i will
use a trick
and they will not like recognize it
absorb it and then apply it
in the same in the same flow of around
yeah i've never ever in my best moment
ever
learned or been able to adapt that that
fast
john was so
capable physically but intellectually
and it's weird that you put in like the
cognitive elements of fighting but yeah
he's he's a
savant
you know he could take something in real
time and artistically steal it and then
put his own flair to it and then do it
back to you in a heartbeat
and um that's who that's that's that's
the jon jones that i meet when i get to
jackson's you know it's the same
gordon ryan that i that that humiliates
me every day on the mat right now
the world
is gonna have to wait for gordon to
decide he doesn't want to win anymore as
far as i can tell right now you're
you're
he's just a savage the
i can hang i can go in there with the
whole room
all the dudes and i can he like i'm 44
you know 43
i can do fine
um not get embarrassed
you know lose some positions you know
maybe occasionally get caught with
gordon i can't breathe unless he wants
me to breathe i can't score a position a
point a takedown
he will give me an armbar like this
and dead to rights i have all the way in
and uh and then he just moves and gets
out of it he will never be beaten unless
he's bored and he wants to do something
else dean lester i had dean lister came
in one day and he's like hey arm lock me
and i go okay so i put an arm lock on
him
and he gives me his straight arm
not like clinched up like he gives me
his straight arm
and he's like okay i'll say go
he he says go and he gets out straight
arm lock bro i mean it is extended i'm
gonna all i have to do is move my hips
whatever three inches and he gets out
and he does this five times in a row and
then he says okay
he goes let me show you what i did and
he goes okay now you're trying and he
submitted me five times in a row like i
couldn't get out of his [ __ ] at all uh
another interesting story this just
happened we were doing a seminar or we
were we were teaching like some basic
self-defense
and he's teaching
a way to get out of what position was it
oh like someone's just bear hugging he's
a basic self-defense it's a bear hug
right
and there's a guy in the crowd and he
says hey with this hand do this and with
this other hand do this
and you know go and then the guy raised
his hand and he's like yeah what's your
question and the guy says hey i only
have one hand uh what should i do and
dean without missing a beat he's like oh
and you only have one hand you turn your
shoulder a little bit more and come over
like this he had the answer like
completely on the tip of his tongue so
cool
for all for a one-handed grappler bro i
was like this is crazy
um
so yeah
that's what that's what i see like
gordon's just gonna be
there's people out there like that uh
i'm cornering for rory mcdonald in a
couple of days with john danaher
uh roy is fighting for the pfl
uh the red king like they're amazing
yeah for sure and dana herr
is uh
he's weird he's brilliant
but that room
just like
at jackson's in the peak just like going
into an oda when they're getting ready
to go to war
there's like this this palatable tension
of people starving to get better like
people starving for perfection
and it is it is the most contagious
place to be and i i i know you've been
gravitating in different you know
entrepreneurially into different
business adventures
um
like you want to be part of this like
hunger
of this this starve this drive and it's
almost it's hard to describe what what
it is when you got in when you walk into
a room that's what the danaher team is
like right now yeah you know when you
got the gary tonins and you got the the
gordon orions you know and you got the
giancarlo bedonis you know and you have
uh just like the list goes on and on
is gordon gonna fight mma
i know he's signed to
oh really yeah within one right yeah
yeah in one
dude the dude hits hard
he physically is a freak he could make
205 if he wanted he doesn't need to um
his wrestling is amazing his judo is
amazing obviously his jiu jitsu is um
perhaps the best ever
the um
i don't know if he needs to
does he want to
sometimes you know he he sees because i
i still train full mma so i box a couple
of days i wrestle a couple of days i do
jiu-jitsu a couple of days then i hit
strength and conditioning you know five
five days a week so there's my you know
nine to 11 workout sessions in a week
and um but you know he's doing 14
mat sessions a week
like he he'll have to give up
yeah 10 or 12 of them to focus on
mma yeah i don't know if you could do it
i'm not sure i want him to yeah
i kind of want him too to be honest with
you because it just i think it'd be cool
to get that
get that get that kind of skill level in
there and and also you never know
man you never know like
he if i was him i would want to know
like i would want to put it to the test
let's go
and and see what happens
yeah
it'd be rad gordon i vote i'm voting for
you to fight man
i'm writing checks that i don't have to
cash with your ass so sorry there gordon
uh
so you're in there now you got you got
um you start fighting
you beat
melvin manhoff you beat robbie loyler
lawler which is i mean those are two
freaking
rearranges my nose though oh yeah that's
robbie right there was that a yeah
robbie laughing yeah it's robbie
uppercut right here
[ __ ] he's a beast though yes i love
him so much he's a great human too yeah
dude he's just freaking awesome he was a
southpaw blasted with my head on center
double leg as he threw a rear hand
uppercut and just like
put me on queer street man
he's like
meanwhile the ufc buys strike force oh
and they get me and
with that they get all the fighters and
all the contracts and so boom you end up
in ufc
and
you kind of talk some smack about you
about ufc
you kind of talk some [ __ ] about ufc
because ufc was
bigger but like more corporate they were
had more control
they would they could get away with more
with the fighters they didn't have to
give as much
and you didn't really particularly like
that too much um so you talk [ __ ] a
little bit
talk [ __ ]
i said that did you not i said okay what
i said jocko is that a a garbage man has
a better career than a ufc fighter
okay is that [ __ ] talking carry you be
the judge
yeah yeah okay am i wrong we're no
you're not wrong but we're [ __ ] talking
we're talking union wages right we're
getting legitimate medical care you're
gonna only have to work shifts um you
know a manager is not taking 20 of my
purse i think there's no way that a
garbage man isn't making more money than
95 percent of the ufc roster there's no
way and it's all facts it's all facts
that's all facts and that's what pissed
dana offers because i wasn't wrong yeah
you know if you weren't if you weren't
jon jones if you weren't you know connor
hadn't hit this the scene yet like
you're if you're not the chuck liddell
you're not making bank yep
yup
um
dana white not too happy about that he
was mad yeah and and and look to dana's
uh side you know he's trying to grow
this thing he's investing all this money
to advertising and do it the expansion
all this stuff and like he gets to the
bottom of that list and it's these
fighters you know and they're just
wanting to get in there so
there's not much real demand signal for
him to pay them all kinds of money and
they're still not yeah they're still
getting they're still getting the shaft
yep
uh
but
so dana i mean i don't know if this is a
direct result but it kind of looks like
it
you get your first uf is this your first
ufc first ufc first ufc fight and you
get paired up against hodger grace
stylistically
we're talking about the greatest
grappler on the planet yeah
yeah as my first
fight yeah and this seems like a good
way
to get rid of tim kennedy
and
get him out of this game if you don't
want like you don't like the money here
cool we're not going to pay you because
you're going to be gone how about this
we'll send you roger gracie roger gracie
yeah
uh
you kind of messed up dana's plan on
that one a little bit yeah so before the
fight he takes all the fighters he kicks
out all the coaches and he just berates
us he's like listen if you guys want to
make more money you go out there and
make it i'm not going to name any names
tim kennedy but let me tell you what if
you want to go out and make money don't
grapple wrestle [ __ ] somebody i want you
to go out there and knock them out you
know if you want to get the payday go
out there and put do the work this is in
front of all the fighters in the locker
room calling me out by name i'm just
like
you know chris liebin's in there
connor's in there uh i mean there's like
this awkward
and uh so he's like
so what i do i go out there and wrestle
[ __ ] the living daylights out of hydra
gracie bro that was that was insane that
was an insane fight um yeah
hodger gracie is
i mean just just going off the stats of
his life
he's absolutely one of the greatest
grapplers of all time
ghee nogi across the board he's just
he's just awesome and
actually he he was on your back for what
two minutes three minutes yeah um so i
shoot a single he's six eight which is
bizarre anyways that you're shooting a
signal right that's free that you're
shooting on him
is kind of bizarre was was that your
game plan like i i can take this guy on
the ground i wanted to put him to i
wanted to push him to the fence and i
was using a leg attack to pressure him
to the fence okay and uh except that
he's long enough because he's
essentially a giraffe
i think he's six six or six ten he's
wildly tall okay and he kicks a foot up
and around
as i'm on his single and gets a hook
around my back while i'm honest just get
at it this is lame then takes my back
you do not want hot his best position
is back
and so i have the best grappler in the
world in his best position and we're
90 seconds into the round dude
it's a lot harder to put a rear naked
choke on someone with gloves on it is it
is a lot harder right yep and it's a lot
harder when somebody can punch you yeah
you survived that and then he's tired
yep um he put it all out there
it is a weird energy system when you
like you do this isometric hold and
every choke has a different squeeze and
like my guillotine has a different
squeeze than my than my rear naked choke
my head an arm choke has a different
squeeze than my legs to padre you know
he definitely like
get hit the gas you know just dumped
everything into that rear naked choke
and when when he started getting punched
and i pulled his hands away and i did
that back back escape you could just
feel his adrenaline dump it's just
tanked there's something all the
psychological
impact of you have a great position you
should finish this fight right now oh
you can taste it i mean let's face it
you know he gets your back and he's like
oh this is over yeah and then all of a
sudden he's a minute into he's like okay
it's not quite as over but i'm still
gonna finish it oh it's not over yet
it's three minutes here you know what
i'm gonna squeeze as hard as i can and
get this thing finished i can taste it
yes i didn't have to worry about this
who this guy who's this tim ken i'm not
worried about that anymore because now i
get to go and celebrate this big victory
and he just got out yeah and i got all
these rounds and i just gave up the best
position i have
that hurts
and uh i experienced that myself in the
uel romero fight a little while later
yeah that's you know it's uh it's hard
when you you have everything and then
momentum just goes
it happens in war too like it feels
everything's going going right you know
you're just smashing it and then all of
a sudden
rpg hits
and all the momentum stops yeah
you know uh
but you end up just
just
actually dominating him all respect to
roger gracie but you freaking
we're taking him down yeah and
and i take him down more times in that
fight than his entire career
cumulatively and i land more punches on
him in that one fight than in his entire
career cumulatively yeah it was a
freaking impressive damn display and you
know what you know these times where i
was like and then you lose and i'm all
sad i was freaking like damn
that's right finally he pulls one out
that's what's up man america baby
um
so that was awesome
you
then you have fight for the troops in
fort campbell kentucky where the 101st
airborne division is you fight against
hafiel natal
stud love that guy
you get a ko in the first round a crowd
goes freaking insane
um
because you're you and the crowd is the
crowd the crowd is a bunch of slaughters
fan it's just like fifth group is there
one
there's 101st is there i mean i deployed
with every single one of these guys i
went to cue course with a whole bunch of
them one of the dudes as i'm walking out
to the octagon he leans forward and he's
he's like trying to grab me as i'm
walking to the cage the last time i saw
his face when is when i was handing one
of my studs to him after getting blown
up the last time i saw that face face to
face
was when i was giving him one of my
dudes
oh just like
this is wild that's the emotion walking
out to the cage every military fighter
that had fought that night had lost
and then i'm the final mate it's on me
main event fight
every military guy is fought and lost
and um
you know
hype yeah got a lot of emotion in there
and next up is
bisping douchebag
uh you guys had some bad blood um
and this goes on for years like it's
years worth of bad blood yeah he fought
one of my buddies jorge rivera cheated
in the fight bragged about it he spit on
one of my friends during the fight like
literally like spat on him and uh and
then said a whole bunch of hellacious
things about jorge's family
and just
bad human things and so from that moment
i had a target on him you know i was
like i want this guy you know you don't
you don't disrespect my friends like
that you don't spit on have you ever
spit on somebody no have you ever no no
right like who does that
my mom quickly like reviewing my life
like that i just gave you an honest
answer
there was there was one incident i got
spit on and that that didn't turn out
well that resulted in a bad night yeah
for for the other person for the other
guy yeah was that when you were a
bouncer or something uh no that was uh
back when i was in the marine corps oh
really yeah that was an issue
yeah what happened
so uh greenville north carolina uh party
town ecu oh yeah um and we were it was
after a night out we were all you know
hammered uh in in my buddy's apartment
fight breaks out in the hallway and me
and my buddy go out there to see what's
happening and uh it's a it's a friends
of ours and uh fight goes down
long story short uh
everybody's dispersing we're breaking it
up and um i'm trying to help break up
this fight and uh
i'm holding the guy back and i'm like
look man calm down he's like man like
[ __ ] you
and like spits in my face
[Music]
so double leg ground and pound
we're standing in front of a stairwell
and this guy
gets
sparta pushed essentially down the
stairwell oh damn yeah and it was bad
idea do not push people when you're
around stairs it's it's a bad idea this
guy breaks his arm
um yeah it turned into a whole thing he
got reported you know to my command it
was just bad business don't do that or
don't spit on somebody and don't spit on
people or get thrown down the stairs
so as i reviewed my life over here on my
end uh i have to confess
uh this is going back way back i'm
probably
12 years old
and there was friends of the family
they're staying staying at my house the
kids the parents went some like vacation
somewhere and the kids stayed at our
house
and like these are like our you know
friends of the family scenario and the
kid the son
is the daughter's my age the son is
maybe two years younger than me
and
he
like playing around kind of he spit on
me
right and i was like oh
so
i i chased him and eventually i caught
him
and i i had the for whatever five
minutes of chasing him around i was
saving spit in my mouth and i pinned him
down
before we knew what the mount was i got
the mount on him held his hands down by
the wrists
and i didn't spit on him i drooled on
him for about 30 seconds
and as i was doing it he was shaking his
head like no no no it was just going all
over his face bro sorry about that tommy
i did you know all in good fun but uh i
think you you drew first blood bro so
that's what you get yeah uh michael's
bisping drew first blood and i drew last
blood that was it
what i like my favorite part about
reading about that fight was when you're
you have a good first round
you have like an okay second round
and greg jackson gets you in the corner
and he goes specialist kennedy why do
you want him back in this fight i was
like that is so freaking brilliant i
took him into deep waters like the
khabib quote take him to the deepest
waters of the ocean drown him there
first round take him down there and then
second round i just started like playing
and um
and jackson was like
why do you want specialist kennedy why
do you want him back in this fight you
know take him back into the deep waters
and drown him there i was like
roger you know
you know
greg he is brilliant he really is a
brilliant guy he knows how to get to his
fighters and man he got to me and then
that third round came and it was a
different thing for the
next few rounds i was sitting at my
office at trade at one day and i get a
call and they're like hey jocko there's
some guy named greg jackson from the ufc
that's getting a tour today do you want
to give it to him and i was like what's
his name greg jackson i go how hell yeah
yes i do and that's how i ended up
linking up with but we back in the day
we used to wrestle we used to compete
against all those guys they'd come out
here um and enter all these grappling
tournaments and we'd we'd be competing
against them
i remember uh
i i had a match against keith sardine
and i lost
yeah i lost
but dean he had to go against dean and i
was like hey dean i go uh
he's okay so what's the guy like and i
go i go he's strong you know he's a good
grappler his wrestling's not very good
he goes oh okay cool and dean goes out
and gets taken down by like
the first like 10 seconds because he was
like so i like relaxed dean too much on
the takedown and so mean keith jardine
took dean down and and then i think dean
got a knee lock on him
and he's hard to finish dude
dean got a knee lock on him and dean he
did not tap and i've been in a thousand
of dean's knee locks and i've tapped to
997 of them
and keith jardine was just like whatever
and dean beat him on points but damn i
was like hey dude this dude ain't
tapping for no i would see him in the
usa because this guy's not topping
anything ever in the ufc ever when um
i was getting ready big fight
um peak
fight camp type shape and keith comes in
to be a body for me and um
he's he's not in f he's not in fight
shape i think he's even already retired
he's literally just like dropping into
the gym to be a good friend be a good
teammate
and um i do a round with him and it's
competitive i do the second round with
him and he starts
beating me
i do a third round with him and he mops
the floor with me
and um
he just out conditions me outworks me
hits the takedowns gets to positions i'm
scrambling to get away i'm fighting to
get back up i'm just losing everything
everywhere and there's a photo of me on
my knees at jackson's and i'm just
sitting there
and you can see
and
blurry out of the in the background is
keith
heading the bag
he just got done murdering me for 15
minutes and then he goes over and he's
hitting them and i'm just sitting there
like what just happened
i'm in fight shape i'm ready to go i'm
two weeks out you know i'm starting to
peek
and he just comes in i mean keith is
he's a freak yeah and he's a great
person oh yeah a super nice guy um
for when he beat chuck liddell
how do you beat chuckled up he out
pointed him in strikes damn bro
that's crazy
too
what a beast
he was just one of those guys that went
man when he showed up
yeah hasn't he been in movies now and
stuff yeah he's he's a great actor he's
like the the ever villain he's so
awesome
of course dude i type cast that guy all
day as like the meanest guy in the
background good stunt man too
yeah
when i when i made that movie range 15
he came out and helped us do he and greg
came out we lost our stunt coordinator
and keith and greg came out and helped
me
save the day so good friend i love you
keith
uh you were mentioning
joel romero september 27th 2014.
this is
you wanna
this seriously bummed me out bro yeah me
too
so bummer night good word so this
so you're so now you're at a point
you've been winning you've been winning
you'd be biz being you beat these all
these other guys lawler manhoff uh
hodger gracie
rafael you're on a streak
and so now it's starting to look like
title shot time yeah bisping's champion
he just beat luke rockhold oh that's
right
that's right chopping left hook
on a two week notice good for bisbee
good on him um
so now bisping's the champion so now
you're like triple hungry yeah you're
like that's chomping at the [ __ ]
and you got joelle romero who is a a
cuban dude he's
a silver medalist wrestler if you don't
know who he is
just
picture superhero human looking
body i mean he looks like a freaking
mutant
uh
and this is a hell of a fight he's on a
streak too he's destroying people on his
side i'm three he's two in the world
first round
it's a close round
um it's a close round yep competitive
back and forth maybe take down maybe if
i was a judge i'm judging i'm giving him
the first round i don't know is that
right is that accurate you think
it's super close it's close
second round
uh
you catch him
and you catch him with like the mayhem
combos
and you
have him
rocked beyond rocked and it's it's about
to be over like you got the skewed it's
done
um
then the bell goes so he's he's he's
saved by the bell which unfortunately
in mma that's a thing and
if you if the bell goes it's over yeah
that round is over
um but you got him man like dead to
rights this guy's
down
you're definitely gonna get him in the
next round
he goes to his corner you go to your
corner
the
like the call comes seconds out which is
so in mma
you're all your corner you you know like
i'm a i've been a corner man a much like
you i'm working on tim i'm telling you
what's up and then then the refs say
seconds out they do that at like 45 50
seconds they're telling you seconds out
that means you as the coroner need to
get out of get the stool get the water
get the ice get all that stuff out of
the ring and you got to get that hell
out of the ring
that call comes and his corner doesn't
leave no
now
the round starts
round starts and his corner is like they
spilled ice
they're like they're trying to converse
with them they're telling to get out of
the ring they're saying they don't know
what's going on
another
47 seconds goes by which listen
47 seconds to recover
is
is in an absolutely immense amount of
time in this ten seconds ten seconds in
boxing uh
it is so much time to recover
that it's ridiculous so he doesn't
answer the bell so yeah so if you don't
get up
you lose athletic commission the rules
are super clear
bell sounds uh you have tense if you are
not in the fight in 10 seconds it's dq
automatically that's just the way that
the rules read
but back to uh
the gracie you know
um
at
bing round five the start the round
starts fight doesn't commence and i look
at him not getting up and i see john
dealing with things well this is this is
again you said hodgepodge this is a well
this is against this is well yeah but
back to hodge gracie i start departing
like i start getting the adrenaline the
fight's over oh this is with hodger no
with hoel what happened with hodger when
i got out of his rear naked choke and he
had that big adrenaline dump
i started experiencing the same thing
against uel where i'm starting to think
about my after party my mouthpiece is
out you know i'm looking at dana white
being like you're gonna pay me and
you're gonna give me this title fight i
earned this i did exactly what you asked
i just beat the brakes off your number
two dude you give me michael bisping and
you're gonna call me world champion and
then i'm gonna say i'm a garbage i'm
going to be a garbage man for the rest
of my life as i leave the belt on the
ground i already had this thing going
through my head in real time all in that
47 it was the best 47 seconds of your
life oh dude i was celebrating every
which way i'm trying to find my wife you
know like you know what's coming
sweetheart you know like you put on them
red panties is ah conor would say so you
are down the road victory you're done
and all of a sudden john mccarthy's like
hey get your mouthpiece in yep let's go
and the whole time he's on the stool
he's on the stool just looking at him
dude it's freaking just getting back in
the zone
we're going the opposite directions
right he's fighting his way back into
the fight i'm fighting my way out of the
fight you know uh fault on me
failure failure on me you know i should
have just sitting there
just staring at him
you you take every second you want
i'ma take that and years off your life
when you finally stand up
not what i was doing
so you get up and now he catches you and
uh
you you get caught you lose
i
don't yell at the tv very much
i was [ __ ] irate bro
um
i was so i couldn't i yeah
um
that was ridiculous
it was totally ridiculous and and and
really what that means just so everyone
in the big picture like
you get a shot where you're one shot
away from the title shot
one time in your career yeah you get
that and then you either win
and in most cases
that's your shot you know that's like uh
raging bull right this was my shot this
is your shot you know that was your shot
that was my shot
and you bust your ass for all those
years to get to that point you had it
and then it's gone yeah um and gone in
the worst way yeah you know that's
that's what hurts like you know if i got
if i had lost you know it's just like
got it man i should have been better you
know but it was like it felt like it was
stolen from me you know it's just
yeah and i don't know we were recording
when i said this but like
for me
i like swore at the tv and was all mad
and then i like got another piece of
chicken and went about my way and you
like god
uh
so did you did you get to the locker
room what do you think when you get to
the locker room well when i'm walking to
the back
joelle comes up and grabs me and he's
like hey man i'm so sorry you know oh
you you [ __ ] speak english now
you didn't speak english five minutes
ago when you wouldn't get off the stool
and you're pretending like you don't
speak english you're like knock it off
man you know the rules you broke the
rules you cheated you didn't answer the
bell the fight's over he's like i know i
know i'm and then his corners trying to
pull him away as he's sitting here
apologizing for cheating and i and i'm
just like
you know
this is on you there's on your
conscience this is on john john messed
up you know big john mccarthy should
have called it
um
did you protest did you put nah
i've never protested a fight ever i
don't know bro i respect that but i
think i would have been like if there's
one time to cash in those chips on on
not
so like what i'm gonna get a title fight
off a contested fight right i don't know
everyone watched it everyone saw this
dude sitting on the stool not answering
the bell it's literally called stool
gate but it's still i don't want a title
fight that way
could they ask for a rematch i don't
know you know what i'm saying holmes um
i don't know all right but you did the
honorable thing hey roger that i lost
are you thinking about retiring
yeah this is the beginning of um moving
on
the uh this is
you know they they give me a rashad
evans at uh madison square
and um that that fight you know being a
former teammate had a lot of you know
i'm really confident in this fight
and it is also he's a former title
contender it's a co-main event with
connor um this this i mean this is a
fight that puts you back into the title
contention
and um so with that i'm okay
maybe not very often do you get a second
chance do you get a second shot
and uh i fly into new york um the
weekend for the madison square gardens
fight my plane lands and i get a text
saying
rashad can't pass his medical to fights
off
you know that was kind of like that was
a second strike into the what am i going
to do in the fighting world
when that rashad fight fell through
i had cut weight real bad to they
wouldn't pay me my fight purse unless i
made weight god those savages so i had
to cut
hard to make that weight and then they
made me fight
five weeks later against kelvin geslum
so then i had to cut weight again five
weeks later
and i was trashed
and that was the third and final nail in
the coffin of me like i'm done fighting
meanwhile you got a a chapter in here
that's called tv in a movie
you're just like uh getting after it in
like 47 different directions
you end up doing
the deadliest warrior which was flooded
you give you give such little details in
here about your you
in that show
you're going against uh what koreans was
it yeah korean special operations guys
and um
and and the show people say hey can you
put some coals in their target that are
closer to the bullseye so this looks
like a little bit tougher than like
challenge for you yeah and you're like i
guess so not a problem
it was so it was so it's supposed to be
television it's supposed to be close and
competitive and exciting
um you know and they couldn't
they couldn't hit anything right so
i would go every shot that you saw the
koreans take the korean special forces
guys take on their targets i shot for
them every single one of them there was
not a single shot that i didn't shoot so
i ended up doing all of the shooting for
the whole entire show
okay so you do that you do something
called
ultimate soldier challenge which is
you and another green beret and you're
going against some a pair of contractors
you're going against a pair of norwegian
er and you guys kick ass again and once
again you have to like reshoot stuff so
that it doesn't look like you're
crushing everyone so yeah is this bad tv
this bad tv and you know it's um
but they're taking war fighters that are
like doing real war and they're like
throwing him into these competition
shows and like shooting competitions
and they
all we've done
for the past 15 years
is uh shoot things
so
it was not good television uh
this is my personal favorite celebrity
boot camp season seven boot camp two
i'm figuring it out man those are the
worst people on the planet actually no
the second worst now that i'm working
in the non-profit kind of ngo space
especially in humanitarian aid and
evacuation and like really really
important work
the people that
that are evil in that world they're the
most evil like i hope that i can someday
call them by name and be like you
pretended that you're doing humanitarian
aid but you're paying yourself 10 000 a
day to go
not really do anything at all but then
you went in front of cameras and said
that you rescued all these afghanis i
know the truth you weren't there you're
a liar someday i'll get to you but
besides them
these people these like hollywood second
string people are so pathetic ouch
they're so pathetic
cokeheads liars manipulators is it like
is it is it like a whole season you do
this for or is it just one show i do i
do it's a whole season for them yeah but
uh the the way that i think it was like
a vh1 show
um they had like a dedicated drill
sergeant that would take these people
through a season and then they would
bring in people every episode that would
do different challenges and different
types of fitness things so they would
they would take these really fat
soft-bodied
gelatinous
people and try to get them hard in the
season
it's a perilous endeavor
uh you can't make a marshmallow get in
shape like that's just it's a
marshmallow
set on fire uh hunting hitler
yeah it's pretty rad um
you you're out searching for nazis is
what you're doing yep and you find like
nazi stuff man everywhere and nazis yeah
nazi stuff you find nazis what would you
do though you like so you're getting off
active duty and somebody from new york
with a jewish accent calls you is like
hey jocko
you can fly a drone you can do ground
penetrating radar
would you what would you think about me
paying you to travel the world to hunt
nazis yeah
right yeah as you know okay
all right this is amazing
best thing ever
i was in uh
and that ends up running for three
seasons
and got a fourth season that was going
to be
completely bonkers and what happened
pissed her channel lost lost their balls
what was what were you guys going to do
in that third one we're going to talk
about one operation paper clip uh so we
traded nazi scientists uh we gave them
kind of leniency we gave them
free passes for their crimes
as nazis to come work on the space
program as we're fighting now the
russians and they're in the space race
so
that was one part of it another part was
a bunch of the nazis one of the rat
lines that we didn't cover we covered
people going through norway and going
through the church and people going
into south america one that we didn't
cover was going to north africa and into
the middle east a whole bunch of nazis
went to north africa in the middle east
and um the founders of the mujahideen
you know as we pulled all these
photographs and we started figuring out
who all these people were facial
recognition you would see founders of
the mujahideen you'd see all these like
little brown dudes
and then you'd see this tall six foot
three blonde haired blue eye guy you're
like huh this is 1946.
and uh who is this guy okay facial
recognition oh that is skorzenski what
is skorzenski doing in saudi arabia
with the founders of the mujadin as we
know al-qaeda isis the taliban the plo
and like what do they have in common
with
oh they want to kill jews
cool
as israel is trying to become a state
and they're fighting for partition right
golda meir is like trying to
how are we going to become a country and
they're buying pt-109s from german
surplus they're preparing to like the
invasion of every single country around
them
those all of those countries were being
advised by former nazis
so history channel was like
uh we're not touching this man so the
corporations that were funding it from
vw to mercedes to you know
this is real
they said no no way can we talk about
any of this stuff it's relevant
currently because some of these
organizations still exist today some of
them are political organizations that
are now lobbying for
um relevancy and um so yep nope can't
talk about any of this
so that was that that was that
luckily you had a movie to make yeah
yeah a naked tim kennedy fighting randy
couture
uh
are you laughing at or zombie randy
couture or naked tim kennedy both in the
same sense ridiculous
hilarious yeah
i uh
when that movie came out one of my
friends is a writer and director and
stuff up in hollywood and he
is friends with
rocco
and
he called me said hey this rock was in
the movie won't come up and i was like
the premier and i was like oh yeah the
article 15. i was like hell yeah i'll
come and see that
so i go and watch the premiere up there
in hollywood and um
actually were you there no okay nope i'm
trying to think of who i ran into people
anyways matt best evan uh
nick
jarrod and rocco are the hollywood one
okay well i'm sure i ran into those guys
i don't think i knew any of them yet but
um
so i like watched this movie and i'm
expecting it to be
you know bad a little over the top or
no i didn't expect to be bad like bad uh
like a bad movie but i thought you know
it'll be kind of crazy
i watched that movie when i was like god
damn
there is
there is no that's a no holds barred
movie man that is a no holds barred
movie hundred percent no when there's
like a
a zombie [ __ ] tearing a dude's dick
off
they're trying to put a tourniquet on
this guy's pelvis and you have two medal
of honor recipients you know leroy petry
like who is already missing a hand from
throwing a grenade as another medal of
honor recipient is trying to throw a
tourniquet on his other hand after he
just got his other hand blown off it is
so dark and so terrible it is it is
insane it's insane uh
it's a shocking movie how good did that
movie do
it was the number one
independent film
ever up to that point god
number one privately sourced and it'd be
number one on amazon number two on apple
and the number one movie to date
up to that point um a couple of movies
have passed us now as an independently
sourced and financed film dude it's
freaking crazy and i remember watching
it going well i guess we're going to
find out what the limits are because
there ain't no limits in that movie at
all it's nuts it was so fun though yeah
but it was it was it was
the veteran community came together to
do it you know there were all of
wounded veterans coming without limbs to
be our zombies yeah like volunteered to
do it they're out in the sun you know as
is in l.a at
the middle of the summer
and the whole entire fight world you
know we had really like top 20 dudes on
the planet showed up to be like the
super zombies to include randy couture
phil davis and keith jardine julie
kenzie
um it's crazy yeah yeah it's just uh
epic um so if you haven't watched that
yet check that out uh
then you do this show called hard to
kill
which is bizarre
because a dude freaking
a dude freaking locked you into a damn
fiery
fake uh cockpit of an airplane yeah i
was an experimental aircraft and uh they
drenched it with aviation fuel and they
took a screw and they drilled it into
the back of the cockpit so the canopy
wouldn't open and then they set it on
fire yeah so
let me just give a little more info from
the book
you think to yourself okay here's a
here's here's what we're going gonna do
they say we want you to escape from this
burning cockpit you go okay cool if i'm
gonna get into a place that's on fire
i'm gonna make sure i can get out so you
drill this you rehearse it you go
through the motions under your seatbelt
whatever here's how you open this thing
you go through it over and over again
like any normal soldier would rehearse
a potentially life-threatening evolution
so you get it done you're like okay now
i'm ready now you can put gasoline on
this thing and i'll sit in it and you
can light it on fire and i'll get out
i'll go through the procedures that i've
just rehearsed 100 times to make sure
that i don't die in here
well some freaking jackass
wanted it to be better t wanted it to be
better tv yeah
so puts one single screw
in the back of the cockpit
where you are actually now walked in
this [ __ ] yep
yeah the uh i mean he wasn't wrong it
ended up being really great it was a
great team
so the cockpit ultimately didn't open uh
i teared i tore the entire canopy out of
the aircraft like that's how it got out
i tore through all the fiberglass and
the plastic that around the fuselage of
the canopy of this aircraft to finally
get out burnt my back melted my t-shirt
melted the seatbelt for me to get out of
this and this was their second plan
their first plan was to set this thing
on fire and push it out the back of an
aircraft so then i would fight it my way
out of it then i would go into free fall
as if i injected like a halo and then i
would parachute down into the ground
that was their first plan when the
insurance company said no this was the
second plan
so
they ended up taking my visor and and
frosting it over and covering it and
then throwing me out of the back of an
aircraft in a blindfolded freefall that
happened in the same and the same
episode that they screwed me inside of
an experimental aircraft drought doused
it in aviation fuel and then set it on
fire
yeah
my top my television time has come to an
end
what the hell is up with that
the start of the show was really
altruistic you know we wanted i wanted
to highlight
dirty jobs is going in and showing like
all the cool things that you know
blue-collar workers do
and i think there are a lot of people
that do really incredible jobs they
don't get any credit and that was the
goal was to go and highlight some of
these people that every single day go
out and do really really rad things
um you know not just first responders
even though they do it every single day
you know but the guy that climbs up to
the top of a cell tower to like make
sure that the the flashing bulb works
that's sketchy like that's dangerous
like electricity static electricity like
just the wind the the you know as it
takes you two hours to get to the top of
that the temperature could change um
you know guys that go deep sea welding
you know on mixed gas as they're trying
to fix pipes that
that's super sketch you know you you
make a cut the wrong way you're you know
using a torch or welder and that bead
drops through in that pipe that's over
pressured
you're dead and uh and it went from a
really cool show talking about this
group great group of americans doing
very american things to like let's see
if we can kill tim
oh i don't want i don't want to do it
anymore
so would you do one season of that yeah
hard pass
yeah
um
you got this section in here about um
human trafficking and and you get
connected with a group called deliver
fund
and what they do is they do their best
to get in there and get people out of
these situations and
to help set up law enforcement to
arrest human traffickers is that an
accurate description of the liver fund
and
they're slightly different now but at
the time that was there that was that
was what they were doing yeah um
you end up working on a team that's
doing this you end up
doing surveillance and again hey i'm
skipping through a bunch of stuff right
now get the book for all these details
but you end up doing surveillance you're
putting together target packages for the
police
um and i thought this was uh
man enlightening and scary and
disturbing
and horrible
and informative thing to to learn about
i'm gonna i'm gonna go to the book here
on what you what you saw
uh
the situation almost always looks the
same trafficking operations run out of
hotels or motels on the ground floor
there is a madame
or quote bottom [ __ ] gotta hear her
the bottom [ __ ] is pure everst
she's usually 25 to 30 years old and she
is [ __ ] the pimp
she used to be one of the girls but for
whatever reason she showed loyalty or
skill
and she elevated herself out of that
part of the business the bottom [ __ ]
typically runs four to six girls she
recruits them when they aren't just
stolen
gets them
hooked on meth or heroin keeps them high
and gets them to rest when they're off
duty
interacts with john's when they arrive
and basically runs the day-to-day
operation
the reason i say she is pure evil is
because she worked the job
she knows how terrible it is she knows
what it did to her
and she is still willing to do the same
thing to other girls
girls
little girls
the girls are usually 14 to 21 and the
bottom [ __ ] keeps them in a room
together and releases them one at a time
to rooms they have upstairs when the
johns arrive
you usually don't see them older than
that because the johns that prefer
non-con consensual sex prefer younger
girls once they don't look young anymore
they are either sold into slavery
elsewhere
killed or thrown out onto the streets
now with a heroin hab habit and no way
to get a fix
or if they're smart enough and evil
enough
they become the new bottom [ __ ]
back to the pimp the pimp always locates
himself close enough to get involved if
a john gets violent but always far
enough away that if the police come he
isn't really involved in what's going on
the pimp may only have one bottom [ __ ]
or he may have up to five the structure
of the relationship of the pimp and the
to the bottom [ __ ] and the bottom [ __ ]
to the girls though is always the same
above the pimps are the higher end
traffickers
what we do
is try to get let's try to hem up the
pimps so their asses are on the line and
get them to turn
on the traffickers
so that's a
nasty world to see yeah
being um
overseas so many times in in north
africa and in eastern europe and south
america
and like my peripheral i would see this
type of nefarious activity but that's
not what i was there to do you know
whether i was there for a fidget j set
you know whatever my mission was
uh but i would always see it and it
always like
ate at me you know is this gnaw of babe
you can't do anything i wanted to but
there's
that's not what i was there for
and you know even in combat zones you
know we'd see it we would see the the
poor little boy with the makeup on like
we know we know what's happening to him
you know we see that young girl that
doesn't have her parents anymore and she
is just at use of the taliban
and um
so i i really wanted to make a
difference in this world and so i
started working for multiple different
non-profits and ngos and this this is
the story that i i really use to to
demonstrate
this wasn't just a weekend this was a
weekend of many weekends that happens
all over the united states and all over
the world every weekend
and how how difficult it is to to make a
difference and how hard it is to
to effect change in there and um you
know if you've been to las vegas and you
get off the strip and you go a couple
three or four blocks into the poor areas
and you see that 30 year old girl that
is just tore up with scars up and down
you know and she's homeless now like
this is where she started like this is
where she was 15 years ago if she's
alive which she's very very one out of a
hundred live that long
like the life expectancy of a human
trafficked girl is is somewhere between
eight to ten months
months
um are these girls american where are
these girls from um here they were um
[Music]
you
depends on like the size of the network
you know when you're that this was
happening in texas so you saw a lot of
girls from louisiana you saw girls from
florida you saw girls from california
you saw girls from new york new jersey
so there were some great rico type
charges as these girls were being
trafficked across state lines but that
never came to fruition
but most of them were american girls and
that line between like a consensual
prostitute and a trafficked person is is
a very blurry one when when you have
addiction and pimps and and bottom dams
involved like where is the line of me
wanting to be here it's not clearly
defined it's really clear when a girl is
under 18. like she doesn't have a right
to consent but then when you look into
that that girl even under 18
that that girl she has no home life you
know she was probably coming from a a a
very low society
minority uh you know on a border town
she has no place to go her mom was
probably an addict her dad was gone has
never she's never known him so she does
have she doesn't have any other options
and it is uh it's really
it's hard it's heartbreaking to be in
that world and try to figure out how can
i help
you know and and like the alpha in me is
like cool let me find a target let me
create a target package and we'll
prosecute these guys like that is the
the simple answer that isn't really the
real answer
you know we're talking halfway houses
and rehabilitation and um you know
emotional and physical counseling and
support for these girls
like i was thinking about any of that
stuff i was thinking about being a
hammer to these dudes and which is a
small part of the problem
yeah
on this particular one epstein's not
dead
he's dead but he didn't kill himself
that's a great example if you look that
is the bottom [ __ ] you know you saw
that girl she was not just you know
keeping these girls she was training
them how to perform these acts for these
people as these young girls it is just
it is a
horrible world
horrible
yeah and
in this particular case that you're
talking about you and your team you guys
are all busting your ass to try and put
together these freaking target packages
and you're gonna like bust a bunch of
these people and you get shut down yeah
for political reasons uh donation money
whatever the motivations were ultimately
we predict we put together i mean
black and white closed case here you go
this guy here's video of him buying this
girl in exchange for services you know
he took money paid this person and in
exchange he got this thing here's the
video of it here's the pictures of it
here's his phone number here's the text
communications here's everything and uh
nada god
the evil
is well connected yes they are yeah you
know if you're able to trade
in one
human pain one human suffering of drugs
you'll do it with people if you're gonna
do it with drugs and people you're gonna
do it with guns if you're gonna do it
guns drugs and people you're gonna do
with
young people
you know your your line just becomes
product yeah yeah you kind of talked
about in here like if you're willing to
be a drug dealer then ever it's just
like
what else you're just gonna do it all um
that whole thing
doesn't seem to
i mean it affects you it impacts you but
like you seem to get more determined
and is
is it safe to say that
sheepdog response is like a response to
that and i mean obviously there's other
things but it seemed like from the book
people learning how to take care of
themselves is
incredibly important especially when you
know
you can't take care of everyone i mean i
had this conversation with my especially
with my daughters like
when they were young
hey i'm not going to be with you
you know i am not going to be with you
and if you don't know how to handle
yourself
bad things are going to happen to you
uh you created this awesome program
sheepdog response
talk talk to us about that
the um
i'm starting to get my traction now like
things are starting to make sense as to
how how can i impact change how can i
really start making different making a
difference
and um you know like i well i can't be
in every hotel motel why i can't be in
every super bowl why i can't be at every
movie theater
back to the soft model of you know we
are force multipliers you you take 12
special forces guys you drop them into a
country and they're going to train a
company a piece you know so like you're
you're going to have 1200 people in six
months from now that are all fighting
alongside these green berets that's 1212
because you're gonna also have to deal
with the 12 oda guys that now each have
100 dudes working for them
that's the soft model so i come back and
i'm just like
okay
i know what to do military's already
showed me how to do it i'm just gonna
buy with and through start training
people americans about what it means to
be individually responsible what does it
mean to have to provide for your own
security like if you really believe that
no help is coming and i know that
firsthand that no help is going to come
like you have to be able to do it
yourself
um if i can make community stronger if i
can have somebody sit in a movie theater
so
you know in aurora for the next dude
that's why the debut of the next batman
movie that comes in to hurt somebody and
then there's just this one dude that's
like
not today yeah you kidding me just puts
that dude in the dirt
caves his skull
the story's over you know like no
headline news no anything
so you know we're running a couple
hundred courses a year now uh
sold out like
in response to not just this but also
seeing the active shooters the bombings
in boston
um
we we have to get our teeth back you
know you don't you don't look
you don't look at a flock that's being
attacked and be like do you want
we should take all the teeth out of the
sheep that's a good plan like that
doesn't do anything right you know i'm a
dude walking around there's rapes
happening all the all over dude i should
actually cut my dick off like that's not
going to change anything the only way
that we're going to really start
impacting change is to have
when these wolves are walking around and
they're like
is that another jock of willing you know
nope that's just another american that
got on the jocko program
that's what it is that's another dude
that started training jiu-jitsu
that's another woman that learned how to
shoot that's that's another former
traffic victim that's like nope i fought
my way free i'm healthy now and i have a
whole bunch of them every single one of
our courses we have dedicated spots to
gold star members and anybody that has
ever been
assaulted sexually assaulted
and we sponsor people all the time and
these women are fierce they are
passionate and i would never want to be
on the receiving end of trying to hurt
one of these women again because they
will find a space and put a knife in
between your ribs like they're awesome
so that's what sheepdog response is
trying to the onus
of protecting and providing for your
family is on you nobody else is going to
do it it's on you
so i am poaching you know like matt
smith our director training
uh army greenberg special forces guy
coming from special missions unit carl
kringer carl kringle kringle our ceo
he's a navy navy special warfare guy
you start going down the list in the
hallways and you're like cool a marsoc
dude another green beret another navy
dude like it's just every single one of
these absolute hammers
that are servants to just americans that
want to learn how to be better prepared
for whatever's next
the the statement that no one else is
coming
is
it it might sound if you're just
listening to this if you don't know
anything or whatever it might sound
really negative
like no one cares about you or whatever
the fact of the matter is
it is just impossible to police up the
world
and
even in the best case scenario
if you have the time to dial 9-1-1 or
make a call for help
the best response times in the world is
too late yeah it's too late
and
here's the other thing
you know we talked earlier about jiu
jitsu being a superpower which it most
certainly is
there's aspects of
being aware and aspects of knowing how
to respond immediately to something
that are also and and aspects of
firearms
that are also a superpower and
by that i mean someone that has trained
look you should train all the time in if
you if you're going to carry which you
should you should train all the time to
know
but even after a basic course
where you get a little bit of stress
test you understand your weapon system
you understand how to utilize it
that's a freaking superpower yeah and
you can
you can protect yourself you can protect
your family and you should have that
capability as a human being
so
this is like to me
what you're doing with this is just like
a
it's just the beginning
of
people becoming aware and like you said
this force multiplier where
when something happens out in the world
in i think in
three years five years
it's just like
you know how good is a hijacker going to
do on an airplane right now trying to
take hold of an airplane like it ain't
happening never get a chance
and that's where that's where we can get
to
in america where it's like oh this stuff
we're not no it's not happening no it's
not happening you're not doing that not
today not in this
movie theater not in this school not in
this grocery store it's not happening
and
do i wish that the world was just filled
with benevolent people and we didn't
have to think like this sure of course
of course yes i think that way but it's
not it's not it's not then it never will
be it never has been like this is a new
problem you know this this goes back to
the beginning of recorded history where
evil people exist and evil people are
going to do terrible things and when you
are calling for help and help is minutes
away you're the end of your life is
seconds away you just don't have enough
time it is on you to do this
and um and i don't and i say this
because you don't know what this is like
it might be medical you know it might be
a response to a disease that we've never
seen before that's killing lots of
people like oh cool you're you're out of
shape you're super fat you haven't been
exercising you were very susceptible to
this well do you want the bet i was
never worried about it because i'm
nor was i worried about my family
because we're all young healthy in shape
and uh
and insert whatever this is
and we don't know what the next this is
gonna be
but you better be prepared for it and
the only way you prepare for something
is to start training one of the soft
truths is that you can never
prepare for
a bad event after the bad event happens
you have to prepare for it ahead of time
so
start preparing yeah
and i've talked about this before with
uh
like you know with jiu jitsu or with
shooting
like hey what if you what if you spend
about invest a bunch of time in jiu
jitsu and you invest a bunch of time in
shooting and you never get in a fight
and you never have to use your weapon
okay well first of all that's great that
you never had to get a fight it's great
that you never had to use a weapon but
also you're gonna be just be a better
person because when you're when you're
doing jiu-jitsu you're getting good
shape you're having camaraderie you're
getting a cardio workout you're working
on your flexibility there's a million
other benefits with shooting oh you work
on your hand-eye coordination
you get the you get to learn how to
focus on things you get to learn how to
ignore distractions like there's a bunch
of really cool things that happen
regardless yeah so these are just good i
wouldn't even argue that
a bad thing didn't happen because you
were training these other things
and that that's a real difficult thing
to quantify but when you look the bad
things that happen around people that
are trained are less frequent than
people that are around untrained
and you're like why does this happen
well because we don't put ourselves in
those positions because we condition our
mind and our body to be in great posit
in good great places to not go into the
dark parking lot you know we start
watching videos to be better and as i'm
watching this video i was like ooh
i don't want to be walking down a dark
alley in the middle of the night by
myself i will avoid that you know it's a
good thing i learned this yeah
um
kids
i love it
and uh
you know when you when you start talking
about jiu jitsu and i just got asked
this question the other day by a kid
it's like
do i have to do jiu jitsu if i don't
like to fight and i was like
you know what if you don't like to fight
that's even more of a reason to do jiu
jitsu because if you know jiu jitsu you
probably won't have to fight yeah
because your whole attitude's different
um
and now you've got this thing called the
apogee is that right apogee
cedar park
school for kids or your kids if i can
say that yeah you can yeah yeah we've
got your book on the shelves we really
do yeah awesome
um
that's how many so so you start this
september right you're kicking that off
do we start it we we are one year in
year two starts in september
on this podcast you and me yeah
we talked about it and i was like i'm
done i'm gonna i'm starting my own
school like that realization happened
while you and just like this we're face
to face
four years later we lo i launched the
school we launched two branches of it
one is apogee strong that is an online
mentorship for young men that is uh that
is how to be a provider a protector um
you know
you are the lone security member of your
family 13 years to 30 years we have we
have 30 year old men that are in this
young men mentorship program my i'm
tipping my hat to them because it's
a cool thing to be a pseudo-grown man
but then realize i don't know how to
change my oil you know i don't know how
to you know i've never read choco's book
your book is on our reading list
um
and uh so that is one is the young men
mentorship program and then the other
one is our physical school in austin
texas
that's apogee cedar park you know 100
100
hero school bunch of just rad socratic
learners
and um we are you're you're one of this
in the books in uh
what day is today the 28th 20th yeah
with two days
is the end of the school session and uh
year one is in the books getting ready
for year two uh michelle myers is our
new director of program she's amazing
i'm just so proud it's amazing you in
every corner you just see magic
happening you see
um
so our our students are our heroes the
learners in the school they're in charge
of everything so they figure out their
day their schedule we have these
launches where everybody gets together
and if we're focusing on math maybe
we're talking about how to measure to
put um
extra
sod out in our playscape how do we
figure out area you know and there and
then and then they're off they gotta
they're they're doing their research
their guide is in there saying hey maybe
try this formula have you thought about
researching this way and uh but every
day these these kids are making all of
their own decisions
unlike in school where they're lemmings
just going to where they're told where
somebody's lecturing them instead
they're they're doing everything they're
sitting there like this is what time i'm
going to get here this is what time i'm
going to do my
my homework this is the program that i'm
going to use uh i have a question
how do i do this and the guy's like cool
i'm actually not going to tell you i'm
going to ask you a different question
for you to figure out yourself
so our guides provide no answers we just
get asked more questions
totally socratic
a lot of times people ask me how do you
get people to take ownership i'm always
saying you have to give them ownership
yes you do you have to give them
ownership it's so hard though yeah yeah
it's easier than just just give them
ownership to take the reins and
and just a release somebody
you have to have faith that the the
process because they're going to fail
is a parent okay with their child
failing
mm-hmm
i'm not going to give you a grade this
year and the parents like well i want to
i want a sticker that shows that tommy
is a straight a student
if you don't get that you know like
they're going to be learning on at their
own pace
yeah it's a different thing
yeah when you give
when you give the kids the ownership
though like they're so much more engaged
you know instead of just hey here's the
task you got to do today timmy like you
do this this and this you're like
whatever when i say hey tim how do you
want to do this
what do you think you need to get out of
this and all of a sudden you have
ownership and now you're engaged which
is freaking as it should be
um
so there you are you're you got the
school going you got the sheepdog
response everything's rocking and
rolling
and all of a sudden uh afghanistan falls
apart man
um
you're
talking to nick
on the phone i'm gonna go to the book
for this uh
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] show man he says
referring to our government's
performance so far while shaking his
head in disgust
nick's an idealist
he still gets genuinely surprised when
people fail as badly as we are failing
on this mission right now how do we pull
out all of our forces and then try and
evacuate
he isn't really talking to me he's just
venting he and i have had this
conversation about a thousand times in
the past 48 hours we sip our coffee in
silence for a little while
him wrestling with being let down by
america me wrestling with a conversation
i had earlier today with chad robershaw
chad was a rangered up sponsored mma
fighter who fought in strikeforce at the
same time i did a lifetime ago he was a
force recon marine
who was then assigned to jsoc and
deployed multiple times to afghanistan
now he runs successful non-profit called
the mighty oaks foundation which helps
veterans find resilience in all aspects
of their lives
i personally attended one of their
resiliency programs and it was life
changing
chad is a good friend
and he has a problem
his interpreter aziz is trapped and is
actively being hunted
because of who aziz is and who he helped
if he is caught
they will rape and murder his wife and
children while he watches
then they will kill him
chad isn't looking
to send messages to kabul like everyone
else
he's been working with his old jsoc
buddy santa sixx who now does
contracting work in that region putting
a plan in motion to get his ease out
unfortunately their timeline just got
blown because no one expected the entire
country to fall to the taliban in a week
chad wants to know if i will go with him
to afghanistan via the united arab
emirates
apparently santa six rides motorcycles
with another former forced recon marine
that has some kind of connection to the
uae
and they might let us use a plane to get
it into afghanistan
this already feels like six degrees of
seven of kevin bacon and i'm nervous at
the friend of a friend structure we
discussed
is there a plan i asked him when we were
on the phone earlier if we're going to
go do some crazy [ __ ] i need to know
that we're doing this to make a
difference and not just go
as i'm thinking about this
nick gets lost in his phone for a minute
and i see that i have another text
message from chad
he's heading to uae in 48 hours
the only thing he's waiting for is his
covid test to come back so he can travel
he wants me to go
i'm with nick right now working on the
book i text him
awesome
bring him to we could use him he answers
so it's on it's on
um
at that moment it's um
people falling from land landing gear
afghanistan that's uh that's what's
happening right here at this moment and
uh you know my phone was
just
our entire world are men that aren't
used to being helpless
there's something that we can always do
and uh we felt
as a collective helpless like we didn't
know what to do and that was not
something i mean that's the reason i
started sheepdog response and obviously
that's the reason that we started to
save our allies like this is this answer
to helplessness i'm just not gonna ever
accept that i don't have an answer i
that i am helpless and uh i mean in
just accepting that is
it's a form of quitting and i'm i'm not
now i'm not down with that so
it was uh
we didn't know what to do yet
but we had to do something
so
you
nick
chad
um
a woman named sarah verardo am i saying
that right that's right uh she seems
like just an incredibly awesome human
she's the
ceo of something called the independence
fund and her husband was wounded bad
and this independence fund
it it helps vets with all kinds of stuff
wounded vets with mobility with
caregivers with advocacy with casework
with resiliency family programs like
just
uh doing a lot of great stuff
the the independence fund
and she also has like good connections
because she's been very effective
uh
so she's involved as well because she's
got some good political connections of
people that can help out you guys end up
planes trains and automobiles to to get
to uae yeah
you get and again the detail look i'll
get the book so you can read this this
story um
you end up getting to uae it's like even
getting into uae you got to get like you
got to call people in congress you got
to get you know phone calls are made
things are happening
you end up
with a c-17 that's going to help you get
people out of afghanistan
that had to be an interesting flight
you're in an empty
c-17 no i'm in an empty 737. oh okay so
we also
chartered slash bought an africa an
afghan airline
and um so the c-17 is
uh had just landed and is unloading so
we're taking a 737 from uae into
afghanistan while they're prepping
the uae said okay if you can
take the c17 fill it up with perfect a
perfect roster of people you have a
manifest of
uh if we made one mistake they're gonna
cut us off like if we put one bad dude
on a plane we're out so we're being the
the degrees of of verifying who's on our
list was
very arduous
um so after we filled that first plane
up they're like
okay well you can do more let's empty
this one and like well can we also just
use this airstrip if we have other
planes
and they said yeah
so then we started this revolving door
of aircraft of using the uae c-17s and
a fleet of 737s
god
all
all plugs uh we're pulling every we're
throwing frags in every single window at
this point we we are full on we gave
zero shits we're gonna make this happen
and we're gonna make it work
because
you know this is
this is august 18.
we know
two weeks we got two weeks
whoever we get out in two weeks is gonna
get out whoever doesn't is gonna die
period
so there's we'll we'll deal with
consequences of
you know breaking international laws or
however the faa is gonna be coming at us
we'll deal with that later but right now
we're gonna save life
um
eventually you get on the ground
you get on the ground in afghanistan you
got like a
what is it shawn g
some dude named sea spray
and you you guys are the guy there's
four of us who's the other one and uh
dave okay so it's you four that are
gonna basically go outside the wire
and
link up with
the the people that you're looking for
which you have a legit manifest of
people that you got to gather up
uh nick is nick is
on base helping out coordinating
deconflicting all that other [ __ ] a
bunch of other guys what's the total
number of guys on the team a dozen guys
or something like that 12 guys so in
dc sarah verrado
sets up like this talk and every name
i know everybody remembers signal and
whatsapp and emails hey i got this guy
who's my terp here's his paperwork he's
currently an siv applicant here's his um
here's letters from the commander that
he was working with
like
hundreds and thousands of them right
like the phones were just melting down
sarah would burn through her phone like
nine times in a day
and so she is co-located i'm not gonna
say who in the government she's with but
our manifest is going through department
of state and dod at the same time every
single name that comes in we take that
name we create a packet around that name
here's all of their digital documents
and uh like here's here's their pid and
here's that they're they're good to go
once they're good to go that gets
forward to uae in uae we had eight
people that were working in our ford
operating base
and then there was the four of us on the
ground in afghanistan dave was staying
on the base and then the three of us
sean g seasperry and myself were going
out into kabul to grab these people to
conduct leak-ups to bring them back onto
hkia when did this become save our
allies this is save our allies right
that's right
when did it become save our eyes at some
point you had to put a name on it we i
mean we had to put a name on it
uh
the only reason i say that right now uh
is just if people want to help out
because i know you're still doing work
is it what save our allies dot com uh
dot org dot org so save our allies dot
org we still have safe houses all around
the middle east that we have you know
we've literally padded people out of
afghanistan and we're still paying for
these people until we work through the
department of state immigration system
to get them to go to wherever ultimately
they're going to go albania brazil
colombia the united states sometimes but
very rarely right now
um so several allies it was the founding
members were chad me nick and sarah so
from that initial phone call of hey we
gotta go get aziz and then it was well
there's also these a couple hundred
christian children orphans
they're gonna die if somebody doesn't go
get them to
well hey we also just got a call from a
senator and he has some constituents he
has like six people that were on a
missions trip in afghanistan the six of
them are stuck here can you guys go get
these americans so this list went from
like i mean it just started exploding of
hey can you
and uh
we could
you know for evil to conquer it's good
men to do nothing and we could do
something so what are we going to do
so you're on the ground
and
talk us through
without giving away details that might
compromise like your procedures but you
get information that there is a a person
that needs to get extracted yup what do
you do so
that person has submitted
to us usually by a sponsor so somebody
texted you jocko hey man we are together
here i'm stuck i've made it to kabul i'm
trying to get my way out
so you reach out to me and say hey can
you get this guy and i say this is what
i need from you for him to be on our
manifest i need his current dos
application process here's all the
documents that are going to be required
for pid once that's done all that goes
through sarah in dc
once that person's approved that person
comes back to me with a contact
i directly go point to point with them
and i start coordinating link up
i essentially have a digital packet with
them
and that packet has all of their digital
documents and i i kind of aggregate i
call collective groups throughout the
city
so sometimes i'm meeting six people over
here i'm meeting a dozen people over
here or i take a truck and i push it in
a cobble and they all go to that truck
and they all have to be the right place
at the right time with the right
information and that truck driver is
going to check everything and then that
guy is going to drive them to meet me
so then i have a far recognition signal
that they all have to know then they
come up and they give me my near
recognition signal
then they have to pid their documents so
the stuff that they physically have is
in alignment with the digital documents
that were sent and if that stuff checks
out i mean now we're like cipher level
confirming that we have all the right
people then i have to smuggle them past
the taliban and then get them onto hkia
sometimes with permission of
the military sometimes without i have to
get them on to base without the military
what was the taliban
um which are you are you just plain
clothes going out into town yeah what's
the taliban looking at you are they
looking at you like a suspect is there
enough westerners that it's you're like
it's a mix so we're in kabul right so
cobbles it's like semi-permissive
environment it's capital city but
the exterior perimeter of the airport
is controlled by the taliban
and you know whoever
controls the exterior perimeter controls
the ground on the inside so the taliban
set up a perimeter around the airport
every single main entrance into the into
the airport is checkpointed by the
taliban
so if you are trying to get on base and
you have your blue passport and you go
to the taliban
the taliban checkpoint and they're like
huh this is nice thank you for this get
back out
so they're now limiting who's coming in
and out and they're not letting
engineers plumbers you know if you work
on the sewage system if you're a garbage
man they don't want you to leave because
kabul is going to fall in afghanistan
it's going to fall without the
infrastructure of the people that run it
so they're the ones that are making all
the decisions about who's coming on and
who's coming off
we were just trying to blend into the
noise you know we were trying to be
um there were lots of
organizations in kabul that were working
all the way up to the fall and now
they're trapped too
so we were just kind of looking like
other trapped people god you know i
wasn't walking around with body armor
being a gangster
you know um there were times that that
happened but there are also times where
i was just like
you know a little snake in the grass
and
what
amazes me as you as you talk about the
effort that you went through to vet
everyone and was setting it up and just
that one you know when you said well
jacob if you text me you need this guy
and here's what you got to do
it's obviously a very complex hard thing
to do and then you got to link up with
these people in a truck or at this
building or whatever
and you guys did this over and over and
over and over and over and over again
to the tune of
twelve thousand twelve thousand people
just you
and your team
got out of there
yeah in ten days um we're on the ground
for ten days
and uh you know let's we're i think
we're at 17 000 people now that we've
moved we've moved an additional five
since the fall of afghanistan um
the surreptitious kind of expeditionary
type efforts
um the the
the government dod on hkia they gave us
a ramp when they saw that we were being
as successful as we were when you know
colonel so and so or general so-and-so
or senator so and so was like hey i need
to get this guy
they're calling us because nobody else
could do it nobody could actually go
into the city there were tons of
organizations that
raised millions of dollars
they still came to us to go get those
people
you know some of them through somebody a
lot of them didn't a lot of them
promised to throw some money and then
didn't
you know but like we were paying for the
fuel we were paying for the aircraft we
were we were the physical dudes on the
ground linking up with them in kabul to
bring them onto aichikaya
and
and it is like
this is
this is
unlike anything i've ever seen
i mean this is uh
this is
in those power vacuums if you remember
like peak isis
like this is what this moment is this is
a complete power vacuum where american
security and stability evaporated and
what was there no longer exists and the
only thing that
flows into that space into that delta is
evil it is just unadulterated pure evil
of what the taliban does and did in that
moment
and we are trying to go into that and
find these people
and uh so we did get some
degrees of approval i don't i used
approval
cautiously
yeah
because the the government knew who we
were they like if you walked in onto the
base and you looked up on that there's
our ramp with our name on it and what we
are doing like we had met like we had
tag numbers for our tail numbers for our
aircraft and they were tracking
and you know we we moved almost 11 of
everybody that left that base
we moved on eric our aircraft
that's like a
just a phenomenal
just phenomenal work man phenomenal
um
26th of august i'm gonna go to the book
the earth shakes and the explosion
echoes through the airport
that was a bomb
sean g sea spray and i look at each
other
we're simultaneously hoping no one got
hurt
and that our trip isn't coming to a
premature end
the internet moves at the speed of light
at the same time that some of our
partners from dod and dos are letting us
know there are casualties at abby gate
a gate we have frequented many times
over the past week
nick and santa six are hitting up sean g
and me asking if we're okay
a suicide bomber got inside the wire and
detonated killing 13 u.s service members
all 25 years old or younger
one of them i would find out later
is sergeant nicole g
a young leader who grew up a few hours
from where i did in sacramento
she helped us earlier that day when we
had to search the women we rescued
before bringing them on base she was
really sweet and high energy
she wasn't going through the motions she
greeted every afghan with a smile
she loved her job and her service
this is absolutely the worst possible
situation
i joined the military in my early
twenties i felt old then i felt
knowledgeable i felt like i had
experienced life
i had no idea
these brave troops
11 marines one corman and one soldier
gave their lives to help those in need
there's nothing more honorable
she didn't have to come she was uh you
know they were working i think 12-hour
shifts and that morning we're at black
gate and we had pre-positioned we're we
knew time was short and we had
pre-positioned but buses throughout
kabul
and we were telling people the grid
coordinates and and
intersections to go to to find these
buses and if you go they had a secret
word they had a fall recognition signal
the bus driver would see he'd wave them
in and then once they came up they had
to have a secret word to get onto the
bus and we filled these buses up
and we drove these buses in it ended up
being a real bad
situation with the base commander or who
who didn't want to let them on he didn't
was that all aside once we got some of
these buses
on we can't touch um
as
women
in in islam so we asked the marines can
can we have a couple of bodies to help
search these women and she
somebody hops in a car zips down to the
barracks and says hey we need some women
can you guys wake up like she just
finished a her 12-hour shift was going
to start in six hours from now she just
pops up and it's like yeah like this is
how freaking badass these people are
like these soldiers and these marines
that were there um
yes they're in the military and yes they
were told to go there but what happens
on the ground
nobody asked her to volunteer you know
she's still the one that's like yeah and
every one of these she just got shafted
x number hours of sleep she probably has
gone cumulatively four hours a night for
the whole entire time that she's been
there
and um her hand goes up she comes in and
she greets every one of these women and
children that's coming on this base with
sincerity like she's just a good human
you know and then 10 hours later she
dies at abby gate
a gate that i had smuggled i crawled
through sewage with children and women
on my back through human [ __ ] to get
through this gate and this is the gate
that isis goes isis k ie the taliban to
blow up
that's that's who these 13 are here
and after that i mean um
things going to lock down
yeah um
that's it
for you um
you got a couple more interesting
stories in there um about some other
things that did take place but
eventually you end up you got you guys
got to get out of there you're you have
an x-fil bird
um that's coming to get you and
it
ends up making emergency landing in
pakistan and it can't quite make it to
pick you up which i find very very
suspect but um
so you
you eventually you have to hitch a ride
out of there and you got to hit you
right out of there with the military
i got to read this section uh
as you're looking for someone to give
you a ride here we go every lead we run
down comes up short the military birds
are full as are the state state
department birds i begin to wonder if
we're going to have to walk out of this
place if we have to at least i know
this is the team to do it with still i'd
rather not
finally i find an airman that recognizes
me oh [ __ ]
are you tim kennedy he asks
he is tim kennedy sea spray answers with
a smirk
awesome man i'm a huge fan my new airman
friend says me too sea spray chimes
ignoring him
i ask is there any chance you could have
some room for us
our ride crashed in pakistan no [ __ ] how
many of you are there four he asks yeah
just four of us i answer hey did you
know he's tim kennedy sees me chimes in
again he is in fact tim kennedy
sean g says joining in the game dave at
least just smiles
i can put you on the ramp man no problem
my airman buddy tells us you're the [ __ ]
i really appreciate it i said then ads
so where are we going qatar he tells us
looks like we're going to qatar
i jump on the signal app and type found
a ride to qatar we'll touch base when we
land
communications now complete i shut my
phone off to save battery and walk to
the edge of the ramp
i turned to look one last time at the
vastness of the afghan landscape
i have left so much of my life in this
place a lot of americans died here
hell i almost died here
was it worth it
it's dark now but i can still see the
edges of the mountains against the night
sky
a feeling of sadness and failure
encompasses me
i might never be here again
i walk up the ramp
so
that's how you wrap up 10 days constant
operations
like we said you and your team
secured vetted and evacuated 12 000
people american citizens permanent
residents afghan allies
afghan refugees
uh this is like
10 over 10
of the total people evacuatedness
just like
work man incredible work yeah that was
um
dave and sean g shanxi's the ground
force commander and uh sea spray
i mean
i don't know
again
divine intervention you know like mike
pushing me that time or
cumulatively that group their individual
experiences combined
that that the aggregate of the four of
us who who were the three of them
they could have ruled that country like
th that is that the amount of brilliance
that was sea spraying shangji and dave
the truly three of the most intelligent
humans i've ever met
and selfless
operators that you know the
the expeditionary mind of being able to
look at a problem in this asymmetrical
way and
problem solve is is a really unique
thing in in an environment like the fall
of afghanistan you know they're they're
in the center of gravity and they are
pulling strings they're calling generals
they're buying like let's buy a bus yep
let's buy let's buy seven buses and put
them out here let's buy an airline who
sits there's like
let's buy an airline that's cool um
we'll tell the pilots that they'll get
their families out if they fly for us
it's a different kind of brain and
that's who that's who these three these
these three men are they're the most
amazing men to ever walk to face this
planet
it's awesome too um and you talk about
this in the book
basically that
you
and and it's it's applies to all of them
but all of you were like none of us like
hey i'm in charge this no i'm in charge
no we should do it my way no she's not
my you guys are all just humble like
what's the best solution how can we move
forward and that plays such a key role
like you can't you can't like argue
about dumb [ __ ] ego [ __ ] when you're
trying to actually make things happen it
doesn't work no
um
there's not time for it and there's a
consequence for it when when it does
happen
and uh
you know those men are still doing work
like right now as you and i are talking
um
you know we're we're we're operating in
other theaters and if you can smuggle
people out you have the same thing in
that expeditionary mind to smuggle
things in
you know we're doing everything that we
can like the mission statement of save
our allies it's it's war torn countries
that need help that's you know whether
it's humanitarian aid or evacuation it's
rescuing of americans
you know saving our allies it's not a
misnomer it's exactly what we're doing
and uh you know it is like sheepdog
response like the purpose of global yep
global
response we are a global organization
save our allies dot org that's it if you
want to support
uh sheepdog response worldwide global
that's what's happening there
i want to read one last section um
here from the book
just to close out
this part of the book or just to close
out from the book
this is as you're flying home you're
you're on this aircraft and you start
reflecting on things from a broad
perspective
and uh
you say this i think about my own trials
and the scars that came with them
my thoughts finally land on the moment
all those years ago standing on that
beach
i had failures stacked against me two
two women pregnant possible hiv kicked
off the police force and a host of other
problems
it seemed like the end of the world
those challenges seemed impossible to
overcome
now that night in the ocean is a blip on
the radar
it doesn't matter except
as the impetus to finally get off my ass
and attack life
those two pregnant women gave me sabrina
and julia
my first two reasons to be a better man
those girls have given me nothing but
joy and
pride being kicked off the force created
a situation where i had to come to terms
with my shortcomings i didn't fail
because life was unfair
i failed because i was a cocky [ __ ]
who made poor decisions
without that failure i would never be a
green beret i never would have found my
calling i never would have reached my
potential
thank god for those failures and that
night
the guy standing on that beach looked at
life as a scorecard that you win or lose
he thought failure was the end
he was an idiot
the guy in iraq who got beaten up for
not being a team player couldn't have
succeeded in the rescue effort i just
undertook with this amazing team he
would have wanted to lead it to show
everyone how good he was instead of
contributing to the group effort
he was an idiot
but it's okay that he was an idiot
in the army
when you graduate from being a soldier
to a non-commissioned officer you earn
the i the title of sergeant
in that moment you earn your stripes the
upward facing rockers that you affixed
to your your uniform
those stripes are the symbol
that shows you are a leader
that you assume responsibility for
yourself and those around you
it took me a lot to get there
it's been a hard road
and every step of the way every
additional rank every additional
accomplishment every great success has
required more of me
i've had to sacrifice more suffer more
and yes
fail more
failure isn't final it's necessary it's
the fuel that allows you to advance to
succeed
to earn those stripes
you need to earn those scars first
i take a deep breath
in through the nose and out through the
mouth pulling my stomach to the back of
my spine
my mind is calm
now my eyes feel heavy
and i lean back into my seat
when i wake up in atlanta it will be my
birthday and i will be 42 years old
i'm excited
this is the beginning of a whole new
amazing year
of failure
and suffering
i can't wait to get started
so there you go man there it is um
life is filled with failures and
suffering uh for everybody
you know uh
one of the things that i that i didn't
read from the book you've got some kind
of rules
and your number one rule
page two of the book number one rule
take accountability it's your fault and
uh yeah i like that a lot believe it or
not do you like that i like that a lot i
don't know where i got it
it took a long time why didn't you read
this write that book in like 97. it
would have been really useful because i
was the jackass that was uh running
around blaming other people for doing
dumb [ __ ] or dumb [ __ ] happening to me
that's why um
yeah man taking ownership taking
accountability
when you recognize and listen you can't
control everything but man you can
control a lot more than you think you
can
uh and what matters the most when you
come up against these challenges is
is
how you respond to it what you learn
from it
um
how can these sufferings and failures
actually make me
better
and that's what it's about
and that's what the book's about
and that's what team kennedy's about
that's what i'm learning to be about
you know there's a fine balance from
wallowing in your failure and being
defined by your failure and then
embracing it recognizing it learning
from it and moving on and
i have i have wallowed in it clearly as
i went for a drink
swim through the cold icy waters of
morro bay
and i've you know and i've also not
learned from it and somewhere in between
there on that spectrum is where learning
happens
and i definitely like a bumper
bowling ball going down the bumpers
have been figuring it out
so uh i think i got more failure and
more suffering ahead of me
yeah
that's how you get better man here we go
that's how you get better
uh
well i've had you in here for way too
long i apologize carrie you've got any
final questions there
uh
no no final questions we pretty well
covered it here i mean we got we went
kind of hard kind of hard in the paint
on this one yeah uh
tim before we go to closing thoughts so
we got save our allies.org
that's the main place to support
that that's right that thing you're uh
you're all over the place at tim kennedy
mma
yeah on all the on all the socials
but i don't care about that stuff like
if you're gonna if you're gonna support
us you can follow me to if you're
feeling about shenanigans but you know
between shaped sheepdog response apogee
and save our allies so
sheepdogresponse.com.com
apogee cedarpark.org.org
there you go
awesome stuff yeah any closing thoughts
brother
i appreciate you i appreciate your voice
i appreciate what you do uh not often
enough to i think are people recognized
for really the impact they're having
we we have
been bordering on a very dangerous
um direction i think our country and you
and if in a handful of very few other
men and women
have been voices of of rational logic of
like no man it's up it's up to you you
got to get to back to work so thank you
first and foremost thanks thanks for
being a voice of
of truth and uh being a voice to inspire
people like me to
to include me
to go out and do good things
thanks
well uh i certainly don't
think tim kennedy needs much inspiration
from anybody man uh awesome to see you
again thanks for coming on um
thanks for your service in the army
thanks for your continued service with
everything that you're doing i mean it's
just it's just outstanding to see
everything that you do to try and help
um
your community
your our country
and people of the world like i said
globally you're making an impact and
it's just it's just outstanding to see
you out there making it happen man
respect me and a bunch of people way
smarter than me you know i'm holding
onto their their coattails as they're
dragging me along well we both have that
benefit of being uh being around a bunch
of people that are a lot smarter than
the two knuckle draggers sitting here
awesome man thanks for coming back thank
you
and with that
tim kennedy has left the building
uh and i believe at this point in time
we are at the world record jackal
podcast
we are at the record well
i don't know man but that went by
in a split second in my mind uh
i don't know i could just talk and
listen to tim and talk with tim and
converse with tim for a really long time
so i guess pushing six hours at this
point
is pretty awesome
what uh what a dude man what a great
dude
i guess we should try and keep this a
little bit short
who's left out there
especially now that tim's gone it was
like all right bro you already pushed
the limit you already pushed the limit
boys
uh you know wrap it up quick uh
one thing i will say about tim is he has
this kind of like disregard for
you know i don't know if it's like
convention or not necessarily rules
either but if tim wants to go do
something like
tim's gonna go do it man it was just
awesome everything from you know him him
doing the mma career while he was still
in the service and then just you know
everything that he's had
a conviction to go do he's going to do a
freaking guy's answering the call man
he's just he's getting after it yeah
such an awesome awesome guy and and you
know like like i read that last little
rule of his take accountability for it
it's your fault and you know we kind of
joked about it that's the
that's the concept of extreme ownership
that's helped so many so many people out
there you know so many people i mean
so many people i don't want to put a
number on it but it is a lot of people
that have contacted me and contacted
leif and said hey yo that's what got me
straightened out is when i realized
i needed to take extreme ownership i
needed to take accountability for
everything it's all my fault that's such
a great starting point for life
and for someone like tim it obviously
has had a huge impact when he started to
take accountability for his life and
move it in the right direction and
um then he just turns into you know a
damn what do you say a
missile of some kind fire and
forgiveness what do you say
a flesh missile you've got all kinds of
stuff going on
uh
but what a great guy um
so
you're in charge of your own life you're
in charge of your own security by the
way so so check out that sheepdog
response
uh also get yourself in good physical
condition you know when you start
talking about phys when you start
talking about this remember when he was
talking about you got to be ready for
this what what is this
this could be so such a wide variety it
could even be
oh my kid fell down we're in the woods
and you know he or she child
banged their head and need to get to a
doctor and we're two miles you know
from the road and i got to go uphill and
i got to carry him yep do are you in the
physical condition to do that
because if you're not
that could be tragic i remember my wife
got stung by the damn uh stingray
and and we were at a beach around san
diego that has a bunch of stairs to get
up to to get to the parking lot
and my wife got stung and i just
straight just buddy carried let's roll
get her to the
aid station i was like boom you know
just buddy carried her up those stairs
but hey
that was just a stingray what if
something what if she had a femoral
bleed and i had to get whatever
something crazy happened yep we don't
know
so
what are you gonna do to be prepared for
this when you don't even know what this
is well let me tell you one thing be
physically prepared 100
this in my mind represents stress some
sort of stress is going to be put on you
and you got to be ready for that stress
physical stress mental stress whatever
it is that's what this is going to be
yeah it's going to be a stress on your
system yep how is your system prepared
to take care of that stress you know
that means you're working out that means
you're doing jiu jitsu that means you're
on jockofield jackalfuel.com get
yourself some mole man
i i you can't understate
the the
the beauty of mulk the fact that you
could have dessert
you can have a dessert a legit dessert
that you think my god this is good
that's what i think when i drink milk i
think you know this is a
you could you could put it up next to a
damn haagen-dazs
baskin robbins what what what do you
want to go toe-to-toe
and this one is good for me
do you track protein do you track any
like no you don't do any tracking or
anything like that i i was curious you
know
this started a month or two ago i was
talking to jp danelle about it too
because he gets he gets the protein you
know
and uh i was i was just curious i was
like i know what i should be getting in
terms of like grams of protein a day and
i i just didn't know where i was falling
so i tracked it and i was coming up
short coming up short i was coming up
short man and i i you know
got on that multiple most of the life
but why why not have two milkshakes a
day for sure it makes sense it's it's a
you know 100 calories of scoop or
whatever you're getting 22 grams of
protein a hit like you know what's nice
too is a little pregame
you know like you're oh you're going to
go out to you know to a dinner whatever
dinner something with my wife we're
going to some restaurant with some
friends it's italian food you know it's
just they're going to be throwing pasta
at you
so it's like you know do a little
pre-game get that mulk hitter because
then instead of eating nine slices of
freaking garlic bread in the openers
right you're good you don't eat it
because you're not hungry right so you
just get the chicken parm eat a couple
of noodles just because of what's up you
know but
try that pregame it doesn't necessarily
have to be a post game evolution a
strategy right there i'll be
strategizing over right a little bit uh
jackalful.com molk uh joint warfare
super krill all that stuff immunity
don't forget about the goes goes new
flavor formulations coming down yeah
they're
speaking of ownership as we know my
fault
the original flavors
weren't quite for the normal human they
were for me
uh but we we fixed them all the flavors
are insanely delicious insanely
delicious i know he's gonna give
everyone a run for their money with the
new flavors dak savage dakota meyer
the new dak savage
is
one of the best beverages i've ever
tasted in my life
so the jocko fuel guys rolled into the
last muster uh maine tai justin over
there jaco fuel they rolled in new
flavor formulations some of the some of
the mustard attendees got a little you
know sneak peek of what's coming i
didn't try the dak savage and now i'm
kicking myself because
i want to see what that's they're all
they're all unbelievably good the dax
average maybe i was just surprised that
it was so good and that the flavor the
way they nailed it
uh is gonna be so it's so good and
they're out so anyways
if you need some of that
clean energy
clean energy
you don't need to do crystal
methamphetamine to get energy
you don't need to do
378 milligrams of caffeine you don't
need a bunch of
32 grams of sugar you don't you don't
even need chemicals at all
you can just get on that on that
discipline go train not only is good not
bad for you it is good for you it is
good for you
uh jacofuel.com originusa.com if you
need some american-made clothing if you
need some hunt gear it's coming you saw
it you saw that first little i saw that
little visual
is that what's coming out first
that's will be the first item yeah
that'll be the yeah because those are
getting ready that was like the test
line that was the first one coming off
the test line
how sick was that it was so sick yeah
and that that tiger striped camo is just
it owed to sog ode to sog but also like
obviously it's functional right and
there's like there's science and pete
and all those brains back there like
figuring out the uh the function
application but it is also just slick
looking you know like you see that
pattern out and you recognize it
immediately
uh so hunts common jiu jitsu gear geese
rash guards you know whatever you need
whatever you need boots you need boots
we got you you need jeans we got you
jeans are always getting a little
incrementally better too the genes we
are learning
and so the genes are just out of
just getting better and better all the
time so originusa.com jacostoregot.com
i see you got a shirt on over there says
just again again this is my it's one of
my favorites because that that's the
mentality over here you know just again
more yep harder yep like let's get it
that's what we're doing
uh so uh jakuastore.com if you want to
get rash guards you want to get some
stuff that says stuff that we said on
this podcast i guess that's the most
basic way to break it down
jocklestore.com subscribe to the podcast
don't forget about jocko unraveling
man daryl cooper and i got uh we're
supposed to get another one of those in
check those out jockowunderground.com we
got 8 dollars and 18 cents a month
that's what allows us to do this and not
live in fear of the man
we're not living in fear because if they
throw us off it's all right we got our
own we've got our own system we got our
own
platform
thanks to you subscribing to jocko
underground.com we're also doing a
little little
alternative podcast there
we're answering a bunch of questions so
if you're if you're a subscriber to
jacquelineground.com you get an email to
send questions to i'm answering those
questions all the time so check that out
check out our youtube you want to check
out the
the
what tim kennedy looks like check out
the youtube channel jocko podcast check
out origin usa
for their for their youtube channel as
well
books
stars and stripes by tim kennedy if you
haven't gotten it yet obviously get it
only cry for the living holly mckay
check that one out all the books i've
written if you like some of the stuff i
talk about here you can check out those
books
echelonfront.com if you have leadership
problems inside your organization
go to echelonfront.com and we will help
your organization align its leadership
and get moving in the right direction
we have a a big event called the muster
next one is in atlanta october 12th and
14th we have sold out all
events that we've ever done
this one's gonna sell out too
so if you wanna come to that
go to echelonfront.com get registered we
also have an online training platform
for life
for life for life
figured out how to take ownership of
your life figure out how to lead
yourself through life
and also that will help you
figure out how to lead others
so
this is what we talk about we talk about
all these different facets of leadership
through yourself through the way you're
living your life we've got pre
pre-recorded courses on there with tests
we've got live sessions that we do what
else what are we missing role plays role
plays on there what else application
exercises
it is a way for listen leadership is a
skill
leadership is a skill just like shooting
is a skill just like fighting and jiu
jitsu is a skill it's like you can't
expect to get good at jiu jitsu without
doing it you can't expect to get good at
fighting without doing you can't expect
to be a good shot without learning how
to shoot it's a skill set
so is leadership
so since it is a skill set that you need
to learn where are you going to learn it
from
well i will tell you where you learn it
from extremeownership.com
go and check that out i'll see you on
there and
if you want to help service members
active and retire their families gold
star families
check out
mama lee
that's mark lee's mom she's got an
awesome charity organization
where she helps
veterans families gold star families
it's america's
mightywarriors.org we've also got heroes
and horses.org micah fink just taking
guys out into the wilderness on horses
to sit in cold water and eat trail food
that's what he's doing for 41 days
it really helps guys out helps them get
through the trauma that they've been
through
clearly
tim kennedy
save our allies dot org
or just
an outstanding organization you heard
about some of the stuff
what's up with evacuating 12 000 people
with 12 guys in 10 days in 10 days
that you want to see results
from a charity
go ahead and check that one out save our
allies dot org and you know what they're
engaged globally
and
stuff that i'm not gonna talk about
but globally
helping people throughout the world
that's what that's what tim and his team
are doing so if you want to help the
world you want to help people that are
that need saving
save our allies
dot org also check out sheepdog response
go go into some of those courses learn
about how to defend yourself learn learn
about how to protect your family
uh you can tell the names he's rattling
off of the guys that are teaching that
tim included i mean they're just they're
just outstanding humans and there's no
one better to learn from so
check that out as well uh once again
tim kennedy twitter instagram facebook
he's at tim kennedy
mma
uh twitter graham facebook
i'm at jocko willing where you at k-dog
carry underscore hilton
is that the best you could do you had to
throw an underscore in there yeah it
happened yeah we covered there's already
a dog out there there's a carrie hilton
out there and uh i tried to message him
and no response nothing just leaving me
out to drive so i guess we're going
underscore going underscore carry
underscore help
uh hey when you're getting on there you
want to check us out cool yeah i
appreciate it dude i'm gonna tell you
right now the algorithm's got it's got
it's an offensive
effect effective
tool
that they are using to get in your head
and steal your time from me from you
i i feel like if i'm on there i feel
like someone's stealing my time from me
i feel like oh they're getting me right
now
so look come on check in that's cool
throw a comment whatever
do not
get caught in the algorithm
um
so that's that
once again thanks to tim kennedy for
everything that he has done he is doing
just an awesome human and
you know is he a perfect human
he's not a perfect human none of us are
but but talk about
squared away trajectory
is just
inspiring to be around him so thanks tim
once again for everything you're doing
and everything you've done and thanks to
all the folks that are in uniform right
now
out there in the world
standing the watch
protecting freedom protecting our way of
life thank you to all of you in uniform
and the same goes to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service and all the first
responders out there
thank you all for standing watch
here at home and we got to hear some
stories of what it's like for an emt
what it's like for a firefighter what
it's like for police what they see every
day
thanks to you all and to everybody else
out there
just remember where tim
was at remember what tim
went through
he was in a rough place man he'd been a
firefighter
fired
he had his hopes of dreams of becoming a
police officer
had those dreams squashed
he had a bunch of problems going on
and he was
he was in a rough spot he's ready to
call it quits
but he didn't
he took accountability for his actions
he learned he grew
he worked hard
turned his life around
and now he's out there helping others do
the same so no matter what happens don't
ever give up
don't stop moving forward
and instead
embrace those scars
and learn from them
and go conquer
and until next time this is kerry and
jocko
out